[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
students
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
chess rapid and today we will revisit
the 2018 World Championship encounter as
Fabiano caruana takes on Magnus Carlsen
in a Four game mini-match in the
Winner's semi-finals it's world number
one versus World number three it's going
to be a big fight welcome everyone to
the Champions chess tour
I thought we played the free move
now he's sitting there trying to figure
this out so it doesn't happen again
push him baby go for the attack hey Ryan
I mean that King scored a guy oh there
it is
everything and that's it wins the match
against Wesley so what a performance
this was
it's The Clash of the Titans and the
Winner's semi-final took before that
four players face elimination among
staff Wesley saw fighting to stay in the
game and to guide us all through every
move in the studio Grandmaster David
Howell
Simon Williams and Danny Ranch Danny
what was the big highlight for you from
your first day in the studio wow so many
highlights a lot of people played really
well but I'm gonna go with notorbeck's
comeback against Wesley I think anytime
you get Armageddon that's got to be the
highlight of the day that you remember
right
absolutely and that went down to the
wire but not Evac it was super
convincing there Simon we got a glimpse
of the form the players are in who
impressed you the most
uh well Magnus as always I mean he won
with this weird A6 move this really
irregular opening I love seeing some
crazy openings being played um I don't
know if he's going to do it today uh
also erolion I thought aronium was very
very good chess wise he was playing
fantastic chess nice ideas and seemed to
be just on top four
absolutely and the other player who
played fantastic chess on day one not
about winning that Armageddon as you
mentioned Danny
against Wesley so David how did naughty
back make it look so easy well not a
Beck just has great nerves it was uh
kind of a clutch match that one where
another Beck he was up against it he
needed to win the final rapper Game with
black nobody can Bank on that against
Wesley so but he did it he managed it
and in the Armageddon he was just a
class apart so it's nerves combined with
fantastic chess and uh he's one to watch
he's really informed this season on the
Champions chess tour one of the biggest
comebacks we saw on day one by NADA back
he's already won one event the chesuke
cup can he do it again I'm going into
day two we still have our eight players
in action but two will be eliminated
later today we will have the winner
semi-final not about taking on lavonara
onion and of course the big match as
Fabiano caruana faces Magnus Carlsen but
we'll start the day with the losers
round one Wesley so against feather cev
itoizaga against Jordan van forest for
these players it is their final strike
it's gold big or go home them they
either win continue in the loser's
bracket or it's the end of the road
Simon who do you think has the nerves to
face that pressure
well I think Wesley so has to be
favorite depends if he can play better
today of course and I think the other
match is going to be very close actually
so we had Eduardo who qualified in a
very tense situation he played great to
do that so we know he's good under
pressure and uh he's playing against
Jordan I guess on paper Jordan is the
favorite but that could go either way I
feel wow Wesley so really wants that
ticket to the season final
and he is one of the strongest players
on the planet but he was super shaky
yesterday Danny yeah it wouldn't feel
right not to have Wesley in the final it
seems that way anyway but the truth is
if the Wesley so of yesterday shows up
today he's probably going home and gonna
have to look for one of the remaining
two events to get there because Wesley
so was was great the first half and then
beat himself and we know Wesley can
struggle at times depending on whether
his his head or mind is in the right
place so we'll see if it's the Wesley so
of old or the the so-so so so so Wesley
so we saw yesterday
we start with too much
is there a favorite in both these
matches well I'm going to say that
Wesley will bring out his best today it
feels like yesterday was just a wake-up
call and I'm gonna disagree actually uh
with Simon I'm going to say Jordan to
bank it against uh I just feel that
Jordan he's just had a great year and uh
he's looking Sharp
looking sharp he did lose his match in
three games yesterday we will see what
happens as two players will be
eliminated in division one meanwhile
some big names have been knocked out of
division three and day one was a day of
brilliant season blunders in division
two
division two of the aim chess rapid
brought a series of positional action in
an absolute Battle of a match Grand
Master David paravian faced five-time
Argentine Champion Diego Flores with a
couple draws and traded wins it was tied
going into the final game after a
blunder with Bishop D6 by Flores Arabian
found the brilliant EP takes E6 a few
moves later haravian found another
brilliant move adding a piece to the
attack also causing Flores to lose a
minor piece from there it was only a
matter of time in another matchup Dennis
lazovic put on a stellar performance
against former Junior world champion
Parham mugsudlu at the end of the game
lazovic created an incredible Force
mating sequence to take home the victory
take a look at the full bracket for
division two in division 3 to see where
your favorite player ended up after day
one
and there is in the other two divisions
also heats up and keeping us up to date
with all the action in the studio woman
Grandmaster caddy satsana chivali Gary
what a dramatic day of Chess that was
what was the highlight for you in
division two we had a hero of a day Jose
Martinez from Peregrine master from Peru
who made three brilliant moves three
night sacrifices and he won the match
then in the end of the day he tweeted
that he is happy to be able to play
quality chess from time to time but he's
a streamer he streams a lot of events
and his viewers know that he plays a lot
of quality chess
that's exactly what he needs to continue
keep up with the quality and maybe bring
in some more of those night sacrifices
there's so much on the line for these
Players Tour points prize money and the
big ticket to division one of the next
Champions chest Star Event Getty we've
got big pairings coming up which is the
match up for you oh it's gonna be
definitely buy against Martinez these
two names I think we might are looking
now the winner of the second division
maybe yes maybe no we're gonna know that
but I'm Gonna Keep the eye on this match
and we see so many young Styles and
prodigies in that in that list there's
Dan
lazulu samayam in the mix what does this
division do and winning it what would it
mean for their career atania they're
hungry they are the average of these
players is 22 years some of them are a
bit younger and they are so hungry to
win the tournaments to beat the super
Grand Masters and for them this is a
chance and this is a challenge and I
think they are going to take it
the chance for these young prodigies to
find themselves with the big boys in the
next Champions Chester event but it's
not just division two action is on in
division three as well Getty who was at
the player of the day for you there the
player of a day was crummy no it's
saying he blundered he plundered so
badly well president was their player of
the day he played this incredible move
with the Knights attacked the queen and
the Rook at the same time this Knight
can be captured by Vladimir's two pieces
but he cannot actually stand in this
game and he lost the first game and now
he's playing in the losers bracket the
Ron Fraser is having quite the run in
the planes he takes on Magnus Carlsen
and now winning in Grand style against
the 14th World Champion Vladimir kramnik
and some big matchups today which one
are you going to be keeping a close eye
on I'm gonna keep my eyes on Christian
and marmadov because these two are such
a stylish just play players they do like
tactics they do like sacrifices and I
think that's gonna be a huge Clash it's
going to be a fun day of Chess in all
these three divisions and for full
coverage of division two and three you
can go to chess.com event also follow
chess dojo's twitch Channel throughout
the week for all the action from these
uh from division two and division three
there is a lot at stake for players
fighting in the aim chess rapid and day
one was Top Class chess and a lot of fun
he does repeat with the knight and king
and that's all that he has to do right
will this be the fourth draw right now
Jordan seems to be here but not anymore
he blundered his Knight he walked his
Knight into a trap because the night
guards before the night guards do you
know what he just never bet against
Magnus 96 can be seven and then okay B7
the knights out of squares oh my God
and this is how it's done yeah I mean Mr
Carlson strikes again
what is this I did not see this move wow
right now it looks like Levon is about
to wrap this up his last move Rook H5
he's cashing in now I better say I was
having to perform some uh real uh
tightrope walking just to survive but it
looks like white will win oh wait hold
on no resigns Brooke takes G4 check we
gotta stick to this one for 15 seconds
four photos yeah he gives up the queen
and that's it finally you better say it
does resign
because now you can now you push Harry
it's almost Harry isn't it
seven point this has been Domination by
not about
it managed to avoid the losers bracket
the entire chess kid Cup on his way to
winning he barely might be avoiding the
losers bracket today three pieces
attacking free it's like the magic
number it's got to be a Checkmate right
I mean that King it's got to go oh there
is oh my gosh did he just miss that oh
my God I missed everything and that's it
takes the Armageddon wins the match
against Wesley so what a performance
this was
and we start the day with losers round
one on day two of the aim chest rapid
Wesley saw taking on Vladimir Fellowship
Eduardo terizaga will play against
Jordan one forest for all these players
they are on their final strike later
today we've got another back up the
satrobe against love on aronia and hand
the big match that we're all very
excited about Fabiano caruana against
Magnus Carlsen two players with a very
rich history and yesterday on day one
both of them won their matches in just
three games David how close are you
expecting this one to be I think it's
going to go down to the wire Tanya I
can't separate these two right now
historically ever since the 2018 World
Championship match the playoffs there
Magnus has had the advantage in Rapid
chess but fabi's been improving fabi's
been fighting back and yeah it's uh it's
hard to cool recent history says that
Favi may be playing better he did beat
Magnus in Zagreb just a few days ago of
course Magnus would go on a tear right
after that and ultimately win the event
but I agree I think that Fabiano playing
very well maybe as well as anybody right
now in the 2023 Champions chest door
he's been to two finals and I don't
think he goes into this match against
Magnus not thinking that he he's maybe
the favorite too so we'll see
and Simon they've been Rivals for a
really long time but their biggest
moment was the 2018 World Championship
match it went down to the Y it went down
to the playoffs and there we see Fabiano
caruana as the runner-up as he lost in
the rapid playoff and Magnus Carlson
taking his fort
World Championship now back then it was
clear he felt his best chance isn't
speed chess he forced a playoff went
into tie break but he can't be feeling
all that confident today
I mean that world championship match was
just so close it was really nail biting
throughout and it did come down to the
rapid where uh it has to be said Magnus
dominated that rapid but uh Fabiano's
got so much better and uh he's a great
player so I think there could be an
upset here I think one thing's for sure
we saw Magnus playing this A6 move it's
a bit of a weird move that one the Saint
George I think it's called but will he
play that against the great Fabiano I
mean I don't know would you reckon guys
it'd be really Brave in the studio I
would be shocked if we see Magnus
playing Asics against Bobby but I've
been shocked to see him playing against
A6 against anybody I also want to
quickly shout out the other matchup of
course of juicer Torah versus Iranian
aronian maybe playing the best yes of
anyone yesterday so we are in store for
a treat we've got two epic matches
happening in the winners bracket and uh
excited super excited for the winner
semi-final but before that we've got
action coming up in the losers round one
one big matchup between Jordan van
forest and iterizaga both these players
lost their matches on day one in just
three games but italyzaga he's such a
dangerous player and we did see exactly
what he's capable of in these speed
chess format in the playoffs when it
went down to the wire against Parham
maksudlu it broke the internet
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
well I don't know what was crazier the
reaction that we had from itri Saga or
the commentary that we just saw
commentary is so great and I don't mean
any disrespect to any of us and
everyone's doing a great job
commentating but I love I love the
energy that those guys bring they bring
it every time and uh ichirisago's
reaction matched it we've got to try
commentating like that today which
reckon guys
um should we give it a go now
[Music]
that took a lot of energy that did
and the players have to bring in all the
energy and the losers round one has four
players face elimination and this is the
format in the loser's bracket it is
going to be a best of two unlike the
Winner's bracket where they've got the
best of four so just two games one and a
half points is the minimum margin again
the players get 15 minutes with only
three seconds additional with every move
that they make if the match ends in a
1-1 die we will have the winning
Armageddon and the winner of the match
stays on in the losers bracket while it
will be go home end of the road for the
player who loses the match this is their
last strike they've got to be feeling
the pressure right now
they gotta be the pressure's on Wesley
so uh again I'm a big Wesley so fan and
known him forever so I'm a fan of the
Wesley so we normally see and and right
now but what what's up yeah I was just
saying Simon room game expert there
that's a shift from where Wesley was
playing yesterday it is yeah I mean
maybe he just felt that room was giving
some bad karma bad vibes bit of bad
vibes United needs to change rooms
change it up a little bit uh maybe it
doesn't have a cat flap on this room so
the cat can't come in because uh we're
wondering Wesley did disappear quite a
lot uh from from the area yesterday and
what's this move okay this is pretty
normal stuff actually but just catching
up with the game now and uh it's gonna
be exciting yeah Simon before the show
we were talking about Wesley's strategy
yesterday and you were saying he was
playing D4 uh with move one it didn't
work for him against subductor if he's
gone back to basics what he knows best
is an E4 opening uh it's an
anti-sicilian with white bringing out
the bishop to B5 and it's the line uh
the fedexev has chosen that Magnus
Carlson himself has popularized so it's
a very closed position right now but so
it's just developing and it will take a
slower Pace the next few moves but yeah
I'm liking this switch up from Wesley I
think it's uh much more promising this
is the type of position that he really
enjoys with weight yeah yeah closed
positional Tanya go ahead I was just
going to say that you know this format
can be so deceptive for the players
because it's double elimination right
you feel all safe and secure when you
start you've got two strikes but then
suddenly you lose one match you're down
in the loser's bracket you lose one more
and you're out and that's a big
psychological shift plus it's only two
games here in the losers bracket right
we have to remember that that they don't
get as many chances to go wrong and uh
that means a decisive result here okay
we saw it come back yesterday so nothing
nothing is over till it's over but a
decisive result here would be huge so um
yeah the pressure is immediately on we
see H6 here from federal save and uh
some slow some slow jam in it right
they're slow jamming right now nothing
no no fireworks yet yes I mean I I don't
know why Wesley started playing D4
yesterday I mean it's the old saying
that if it's not broken you don't need
to fix it and he's so good with E4 so so
why was he trying out other ropings and
uh if we just look at the position
already here
um it does strike me that only white can
be better because white has some nice
holes in the middle of the board and
there we go the bishop just slides back
to try to control those holes and the
main square is that Outpost right in the
middle the D5 square and could that be
an issue David uh for black in this this
type of structure it could be but both
players just playing very slowly I think
we'll check back in this one a bit later
on yeah we will control over D5 square
that seems to be the name of the game
but the other one is also on as Jordan
van for a Stakes on iterizaga with the
black pieces and this feels like the
name of the game here is the English
opening yeah Simon we're loving it of
course best the name of the best opening
clearly I mean no shot much better than
the French defense my brother London has
that well London's alright second best
I'd say but the English opening is a bit
broader I feel so you've just alienated
uh half our viewership there Simon the
London system you know
Indian
s Indian oh Queens Indian Fanny or sure
I'm more of a queen's Indian guy you're
right nimzo repertoire leads to Queens
Indians but uh anyway now we've got a
transposition actually more of a
traditional here you go telling you this
is going to be a G3 King's Indian on the
board and and we have it and the one
thing I will say here is that iterazaga
is an expert in these types of positions
every time I see him play White he tends
to fee and Kettle his light Square
Bishop yeah Jordan okay he's playing a
very direct line now white has a chance
to either block the center or trade off
a set of Pawns in the center maybe a
queen trade coming as well but uh Jordan
yeah he's had a mixtrack record uh
against this fee and keto system uh
something that I pinpointed as a bit of
a weakness in his game uh a while ago
but okay the center has been blocked
you'll do nothing we'll be happy to see
this all the pieces still on the board
and despite Black's night being forced
back home to B8 uh just the fact that
the center is now closed means that
Tempe isn't so important here Ultra
positional line in in these A5
variations where black is trying to
control the dark squares rather than uh
rather than being aggressive in the
traditional King's Indian plan where
you're attacking on the king side with
the f-pawn you're you're sort of trying
to slow slow play things and and choke
whites Queen Side Pawn store before it
gets going so
um anyway the the game is just just
beginning so trying to set the table of
course this is still a lot of theory and
both players likely still playing from
whatever they prepared at home I mean
whenever I'm playing the black side of
the kings in defense which I do a fair
bit I hate playing against G free
because you kind of get different types
of structure you want to actually get
this uh this structure you see here so I
think Jordan would be quite happy that
the center has closed down you see how
the pawns are kind of locked together
there a bit like Lego in the middle and
I think that's something that black will
be happy to get because that's more of a
traditional King's Indian defense setup
so you know you can try to attack on the
king cyber black with uh this main push
Black's gonna move the Knight away and
try to push the pawn so so I think black
should be quite happy actually with this
position
uh Simon you called it the Lego fix for
me King's Indian is always like the
Jenga fix where everything is nicely
clashed until you just put one Pawn
brick and the position explodes is that
something we can expect here I I yeah I
guess so definitely that's that's
probably a much better analogy I think
Jenga whenever I play any opening it
always falls apart
it all goes wrong as someone who's been
playing a lot of Jenga recently it's uh
that is a game that will give you
anxiety that Rivals chess even when the
eval bar is jumping up and down so that
I think that's a great call out Tanya
and I think as you were saying Simon
these G3 systems are just harder to
assault because white has more pieces
around The King and I think in Rapid in
particular it uh makes it makes it less
attractive to want to play The King's
Indian because you don't get to do the
famous King's Indian Checkmate attacks
right so
um of course these guys play for more
than than Checkmate Thrills like you and
I Simon so I think they'll be all right
yeah but uh we're quite basic humans
aren't we when we play chess we see the
king we attack the king uh but is there
a little tactic post ability here David
maybe I mean uh you what would you take
black I've never seen you play the Kings
in defense David I'm not a spirit of a
man as you Simon I've got to admit I
don't like to be cramped uh too much and
I'm always afraid of weight gaining
space on the queen side and it feels
like this is an automatic now for better
or worse a tourism should push his Pawn
to B4 before it's too late and uh after
a trade
you didn't get that by me and uh yeah
here black does have a bit of an issue
with the Knight I guess Simon you were
thinking of maybe there are tactics like
this I was thinking about it but I mean
I it doesn't seem to work I mean uh
obviously two minor pieces are it's much
stronger to have the two minor pieces
compared to the rook and the pawn yeah
and in this position white would just be
better here so it doesn't seem to work
you know it doesn't seem to work so I'm
a bit surprised that he didn't go for
this to tourism perhaps he was afraid of
the move Knight to A4 and we'll see a
few trades black has the open a file
instead he's taken an even slower
approach that seems to be the name of
the game uh in both of the matches so
far yeah just uh maneuvering here he's
just slow played it with the point of B3
instead he's going to slowly build up
maybe plan his Bishop 183 and will
Jordan turn his attentions to a typical
King's Indian plan I think that's the
question will he start playing for this
famous F5 break in the near future
we'd love to see that on the board with
players playing on either flanks
idrisaga handling the queen side and an
avalanche by Jordan on the king side
that seems like the direction this game
is headed and while this heats up let's
take this moment to check in on Wesley
so against Vladimir fedexev and wow
there's a lot that's happened David
Black's Queen targeting White's King but
I don't see too many pieces yeah uh
Black's Queen needs some assistance if
she wants to deliver any checkmates we
have seen a trade of one set of knights
hence the white kingside pawns being
damaged white has double G pawns long
term that's fine but short term maybe
some holes on the dark squares around
White's King problem is for fed to say
if it's like you say Tony if there's
nothing immediate then slowly the
kickback might start and uh Black's
Queen if she's forced to retreat uh I
think the momentum might change a bit
later on so okay how will Wesley deal
with this it's him to move it's an
obscure game I think we should talk a
little bit about the pawn structure and
maybe maybe since we only have two games
going bring up bring up the analysis and
show show how that happened because it's
not every day you see doubled G pawns
like that right in a queen on H4 but it
goes back to this position where Wesley
employed this Knight H2 playing David
and I I think that we've got a couple of
Night Moves happening over here on on
the opposite edges of the board but I
have the opening Explorer pulled up just
to see I mean we're already kind of in
original territory even if this idea is
one that one that white does sometimes
employ especially when you have the pawn
structure c2d3 E4 you're you know maybe
preparing these ideas to get space on
the king side which we should always be
thinking about but black doesn't allow
it right trades on G4 and plays Queen H4
to make sure that you have to protect
the pawn rather than playing an
aggressive F4 so anyway I think it's a
fascinating and a original kind of
position right those double G pawns may
not be something to look at but they do
hold black F5 right hold back F5 for
black so a really interesting kind of
grip that white has on the king side
Yeah you mentioned F5 under controlled
by white is D5 or break that black can
think about yeah actually just for
aesthetic reasons you mentioned porn
structure Danny I want to play the move
B3 just to put all my love and light
squares Checkers Checkers called okay
get out of chest Town Checkers I hang a
minute you know what black needs to play
here as well right black has two moves
F6 and B6 there we go let's do it yeah
we've got to put them on and we have the
perfect structure right so uh
listen we're literally just like kids
playing with coloring books right now I
hope someone Clips this because this is
really high level chess analysis this
looks like you're adding challenge
against Magnus yeah it's literally just
Checkers uh meanwhile uh Wesley so
spoiling the fun he's put a pull in a
dark Square what are you doing Leslie C3
logical move though and uh Tanya I think
your suggestion is uh really pertinent
here if black just Retreats it feels
like you're stepping back in the wrong
direction there we go feather save
breaks down the center I like it oh it
didn't happen okay right on you no Tanya
great call I think that it's it's
usually the person who controls the pawn
breaks is controlling kind of the tempo
or the direction of the game right steal
one from my my boy Robert house you
can't spell chess without him and we
often talk about that because I think
closed positions to beginner players
look boring at first but looking at a
closed position and seeing the forest
through the trees is about seeing where
the breakthroughs are going to come and
I think D5 shows that that actually
black has a lot of good chances here
because I mean now now if the Center
opens up and White's King is over little
exposed you got the dark squares that
could fall apart that Bishop on B8 is
going to be playing if you ever take on
D5 yeah I love that via that diagonal or
if you take on D5 there's even this E4
push and can I get just a you know just
to make the kids Happy show a little
Checkmate if you take an E4 and here
comes Bishop H2 and and uh so anyway the
point is the pieces are coming to life
because black controls the pawn breaks
and that's an instructive thing to take
away regardless of your chest level and
I like the black played D5 yeah and now
maybe he can continue uh this Knight is
attacked to the point D5 attacked as
well uh maybe you can continue with C4
and maybe there are some tactics taking
this Pawn oh man dragging the queen
forward uh to a square it can be double
attacked oh unlucky tricky position
right now for both players to manage
it's quite strange because the way
Wesley is playing he's kind of forcing
feathersev to play good moves yeah it's
like you know he's playing this move C3
to attack the Black Knight if black
moves the Knight backwards black is just
clearly in a very bad scenario because
he he's lost that square so black has to
play actively and um that is kind of
like strange against someone as strong
as feathersef you know feathersev is
going to play good moves and uh he's got
to find another good move here otherwise
again he's just going to be worse he
can't move the Knight back because he'll
lose the pawn so he's got to play an
active move and I I don't know how this
is going to end out but the evaluation
bar seems to start start to favor Black
here as well so people just played first
so C4 is explosive when it happens this
I mean it's uh yeah oh Danny I nearly
missed that joke there Danny so one we
you've got one Dave we're lagging here
Tanya we need to yeah
we said hey man we lost we lost the
cringy pun game last night and we were
going to bring it today it's not a race
it's a marathon that's right so we got
time for Dynamite that's uh there it is
oh there we go that's for sure no but
Tanya you called this D5 it was great C4
is now on the board this is this is
again we're early but look at the board
look at the evil board look at the King
on G1 A6 is coming like this feels very
scary for Wesley already absolutely and
psychologically right when you attack an
opponent's bees you're automatically
thinking about them just retreating with
it is it possible that Wesley just
underestimated the moment when black one
D5 I think it's a great call I think
when you play C3 you may be just
underestimated both the moves we now see
D5 and C4 I think I think that's you
look at the time it's suggestive that
he's he's losing his way it's very
strange for someone as strong as Wesley
the way he's missing stuff like this I
mean he wouldn't do this normally yeah
you know he was doing it yesterday he's
doing it today and it's not a normal
normal thing for Wesley I mean he's
normally on top of everything
some exchanges happening there and
things clarifying maybe in the position
a little bit I mean yeah he's just gonna
favor and fed to say if it's paused here
it looks like he can just take the white
Bishop but no he wants more I love this
move and look at the stretch he plays it
he leans back he's learning from there
the Iranian stretched there you know
look at the king of G1 we got we got fun
stuff here we got fireworks on the board
and and I I agree just to piggyback on
your point Simon I think that they say
class is permanent and form is temporary
and it's our job to call it like we see
it because we all love Wesley but the
truth is this doesn't look like the
Forum that we normally see from so
yesterday he played some had some
interesting decisions and here again
he's inviting a game it's kind of making
it easy on his opponents right now he's
giving his opponents chances I feel like
he did that against Notre back toward
the end and he's doing it against
Federal save right now yeah beautiful
beautiful move there from fair to say
I've got to say and okay he chooses to
save this bishop and uh the Knight was
covering A7 so it had to be removed and
now before the deadly check ending the
game for the fear of uh threatening that
move obviously has blocked it so still
alive but here it feels like momentum is
purely in Black's favor uh you can start
hitting this White Queen you can start
uh maybe even just taking a pawn
you need something now but uh it feels
like Wesley yeah missing stuff just not
on form right now he needs to pull
himself together yeah it's an important
bishop move there that white played I
mean why absolutely absolutely needed to
cover that diagonal with his last move
any other move uh he'd be losing already
we see feder said bringing a rook to the
middle for a natural move Rooks below
and open files but
um the bishop Wesley's Bishop does seem
okay and I like this idea that Wesley's
playing if you're in a tricky scenario
try to get rid of your opponent's Queen
because it's less likely you'll get
checkmated so is it that bad for Wesley
or is he is he actually just okay here
no matter what the evaluation bar
actually says yeah I mean it looks like
uh if the Queen's come off he should be
totally fine I think that's the point I
think the queen should not come off I
think Queen E7 is
what the doctor ordered and it's a
reluctant Retreat if fed to say it does
keep the Queens on because you want to
of course deliver Checkmate to White's
King but maybe you just need to step
back find a new angle and we do see the
evaluation bar here that might be
misleading I'm certainly influenced by
it I'm wondering now I mean I would
prefer black but I'm not sure it's that
good from a human perspective but uh
yeah computer seems to think black has a
massive Advantage here I like your move
Danny just coming back to E7 white has
some weaknesses on the queen side as
well I was going to say the air quality
remains good so better safe has that
going for him the room hasn't changed
air quality still just allowing him to
play some high quality chess yeah and
the position remains good as well for
blacks or fantasy of here
decide to try this one out in the end
game or will he keep all the trumps in
the position and retreat with the queen
trying to grind down a middle game he
does take a decision Queens are off the
board and immediately also snaps up the
A4 Pawn that's the queen trade surprise
you it does Super
Supreme I think that it I think that uh
we'll see what he calculated I think now
will be the move because whatever he
decided he must have some sort of
follow-up normally
um it's very strange isn't it because
we're sitting here we see the evaluation
bar these guys don't see the evaluation
bars and from feather set's point of
view maybe he just didn't realize how
good his position was maybe he's like
okay if I make some exchanges I'm going
to get nearer to a draw and uh that
might be the way I can just play this
keep it simple maybe that's you know
something that's happened here a big
decision there by Vladimir father said
will he
read Queen trade or will he be able to
grind down this end game we'll jump back
to this as this one has come down let's
head over to the Eduardo iterizaga
what's his Jordan van for us Queens are
still on the board and quite a crazy
position upon on B3 in White's Camp how
on Earth did that get there how on Earth
did that black porn arrive on B3 black
is a pawn up as well how did Black get
rid of that King's Indian dark squared
Bishop it looks like there have been
many developments in this game and uh
we'll check in on the current position
but let's just do a quick action replay
I think like the other game Danny we
need to figure some stuff out and I'd
love to figure out how we got here
because I'm it's funny this is one where
I will openly just disagree with the
eval giving black a tiny Edge I look at
the position and feel like if we okay
you get us there and then I'll give my
opinion on the live board okay 84
happened so A4 happened and this is how
what uh the pawn eventually landed on B3
black first installed a nice Knight on a
very strong square and it was here
Bishop to H6 the king's Indian Bishop
came to life the White Knight had to go
the long way around to trade off this uh
mighty steed on B3 and after a few more
trades we did see not Queen takes Pawn
I'm wondering why first of all he didn't
capture this Pawn looks like it was up
for grabs but uh after the Knight
stepped back this is the current
position Danny but I think you entered
it if we want to show real quick I think
if you take V3 then when you take E4 the
White Knight doesn't have any squares
and if you can't take E4 back because of
Bishop F5 so I think that must have been
the the combination as far as why white
had to postpone the corralling of that
of that overextended B3 Pawn so so back
to the live position it's funny because
even though I Now understand that the
black has a small Edge according to the
math of our artificially intelligent
overlords because black is up a pawn but
I look at every long-term feature of
this position and I look at the B3 Pawn
it's going to be corralled that white
has the bishop pair black has lost the
famed King's Indian bishop and white is
going to get C5 at some point which is
the Breakthrough on the queen side we
always want so call me crazy
just don't call me Shirley I prefer
white is is math similar to maths there
it is a little bit it's similar yeah
okay just clarifying that so I don't
know I mean I just tell me tell me why
I'm crazy I guess black is showing why
I'm crazy Jordan is being very
aggressive on the file but I I would
prefer white despite what the email says
and remember the players don't see that
so anyway it would be a bit of a race
right I mean Black's got some chances on
the king side as well here I mean uh
David even the next few moves will be
critical because black will try some
attack some assault against the white
king if it doesn't work then I totally
agree with Danny and uh I think a
tourism now is pretty urgent he has to
stop black from pushing a pawn to H4 he
has to stop black from maybe throwing
some pieces out the way and breaking
through with the Rooks those two stacked
up black Rooks on the f file uh they
have two Pawn slightly tender if white
can consolidate cover everything then
watch strategically winning it's fair
it's fair I guess I'm I'm just looking
at the long-term features in the chess
human in me is is coming out versus the
computer and I even if you play H4 I'm
thinking about taking it and sliding my
Rook to G3 I guess what I'll say is this
there's no way objectively that black
isn't fine because you can't argue with
computers and I but I would argue the
instructive point is that if black
doesn't stay on the grind on the king
side and if black doesn't deliver on the
f file don't be surf the eval bar
switches that's my point because white
does have a lot of those long-term
features going for him yeah I think I
choose white as well but uh not with a
not with a lot of confidence
I would go black all day long
you know I Am the Man in Black and I I
love
looking at my opponent's king putting
pieces near it and just attacking and uh
who cares what's going on the Queen's
side it doesn't matter the king's over
there Checkmate ends the game and
actually this move Harry four H4 I think
is really really quite dangerous right
because uh you want to keep things
blocked as you both mentioned uh but
it's very hard to do that so there is
you know I'm not sure how if white can
stop that I agree with you but I don't
see how white does and here is the
opportunity to play and he's played it
so we're gonna find out
Jordan vanfur is going for Eduardo
terizaga's King but time is often
off well because with all the Strategic
trumps that white has including those
two Bishops the bishop are Advantage
black has to go for the kill right here
right now H4 a great start if white
tries to keep the position blocked on
the king side advancing the G Pawn can
we expect a sacrifice I would love to
see G4 David brought the analysis before
we could even say we gotta show why
that's a bad idea I'm assuming Bishop
takes there has to be a bishop takes
followed by Knight and F2 Falls and
and with it the house right
um so I so I don't think we're gonna see
G4 as fun as it is to to show
um yeah you see a position like this and
you just stop calculating with white you
just think okay I'm getting checkmated
if not I'll probably just lose material
so G4 I think would be short-sighted but
Danny mentioned another resource that
white could try just taking this one and
sliding across with the Rook a bit later
on what could be the downside here I
think it's going to be Knight H5 right
away right Tanya nodding her head next
to me I think she already saw it before
I did it and it not only because it it
goes to F4 but it holds G3 right so the
Rook can't come to G3 which makes
everything start to feel dysfunctional
so I love it 985 you're also threatening
slacks on the H3 Square Bishop H3 always
in the air opening up the F5 with impact
this could be super dangerous but with
all these lines that we're talking about
how then does white keep things solid on
the king side or is it just going to be
explosion if I if I had to guess no
engine in front of me some move like
Rook G1 something that sits on the
position because here's the thing if you
if you play Knight H5 before then I'll
have G4 or at least I'll have a chance
to get G4 you might you might still sack
actually and if you take G3 before the
Knight comes in maybe I can take back no
the computer doesn't like it either it's
yeah it's it's getting it's getting more
and more concrete which I guess shows
our modern chest similar to to Simon
kind of yesterday commenting that the
bishop pair must be good for black and I
I happen to know that position so I was
like no this is good for aronian here
this is like me looking at the bishop
here and the computer's like no no that
doesn't matter the f file the double
pawns are actually killing white here on
e45 and here comes Full Steam so so
Simon it's a position after your own
heart yeah certainly I mean uh you know
the most important thing always is King
safety yeah um when both sides are
developed and that is the the key thing
here uh Black's King is very safe black
has more pieces on that area of the
board and this last move I love it it's
like a little lever it's just tickling
away a White's position little tickle
tickle open up open up the king and then
bang the black pieces will come through
and uh it's very hard for black uh sorry
for white to to keep his Kings safe now
and uh also I think a position that
Jordan really thrives in Jordan loves
attacking he loves these exciting
positions and he and
um it's getting dangerous and white now
I feel
yeah I'm in the clock situation as well
it's incredibly dangerous now for to
rizaga just uh one more long thinking
him otherwise uh I think we might see
catastrophe over the next few moves
David you wanted white a couple of moves
ago are you still sticking to that I I
did mention it was not with confidence I
think I was swinging him I was looking
at the at the at the big picture not
seeing the tree that was falling on me
so sometimes we say look at the forest
through the trees sometimes you gotta
look at what's right in front of you and
the concrete aspects of this position
were that were the white can't really
coordinate and the more I look at it the
more I'm like duh duh Danny uh and also
by the way how have we not commented on
Jordan's shirt
what is going on that's so great the
Hawaiian shirt and daddy however
needs to defend this position with less
than three minutes on the clock yeah
it's it's getting worse and worse for
each series August so I was wrong white
is in trouble
I'm sorry we're all wrong sometimes
honey I'm wrong I'm wrong more than
right that's the truth it's like what
are you guys talking about
I'm always right this Ginger knows how
to attack who knows I get lucky
occasionally and um well we're gonna I
mean that that night move you mentioned
wasn't played but this also seems quite
it's quite blunt isn't it he just wants
to take that pawn and attack I'm not
closing the book on each other yet for
the right I mean I think Jordan
accurately if accurately played puts
this away but this is a double-edged
position we can be biased by the eval
the dark Square Bishop is gone if black
screws this up the floodgates could
switch and that's one of the things you
always have to be worried about yeah I
think it's just the fact that all of
Black's five pieces will be I mean
contributing to the attack and maybe
white start Square Bishop is the one
that cannot defend yeah so just gonna be
outnumbered simply yeah and I love it
can slow burn this attack Rook H7 eight
minutes against under two minutes now
this is an uphill struggle I don't see
any obvious defensive moves and uh two
minutes is fine if your moves are
natural this is far from that type of
position right now and we've got to
remember it's only two games isn't it
that these guys play in the losers
bracket so losing with white in the
first game we've got your moving Danny
better late than never they say you did
get it yeah and by the way if the C file
opens up that is another line of attack
so you know I think the biggest problem
right now and as Tanya point out maybe
the biggest blunder is just on the clock
right right now the truth Saga
regardless of the Dynamics on the board
is is getting himself in trouble off the
board I don't know if that was the
biggest blunder because right after he
played the move C5 it is either had a
bit of a reaction there David as if he's
just made a mistake what happened there
yeah he could have looked up and winced
visibly and uh he does not look happy
maybe it's just the way the game's been
going I think this last move is probably
as good as any he's trying to cause the
distraction switch uh Jordan's Focus to
the fake amount sometimes you give your
opponent a Juke no maybe maybe he saw
his clock for the first time yeah Mind
Games maybe maybe Wesley's cat bit him
under the table videos speaking of
Wesley by the way another we have to go
there that game looks like it's holding
out but I'm just I'm giving Wesley the
nod and the evil bar we can see on
screen that despite being worse he's
holding on and maybe gonna find his form
slowly
I think this is the game we want to
stick to I agree Eduardo just under two
minutes and a difficult position to
defend he's trying to create a bit of
chaos on the queen side a distraction on
the queen side but with all of Jordan's
forces directed towards the king it's
hotter Martin Jordan getting uh
distracted from that big goal of
checkmating White's King does he simply
go on to pick up that H Pawn open the
h-line what's going on there yeah yeah
why not just be consistent normally once
you find a plan if you're confident it's
a good one just stick to it don't get
distracted don't kind of play Move by
move I think the only thing that's maybe
pausing uh or causing Jordan to pause
here is that he might trade one set of
Pawns on the queen side I'm not sure who
that helps I think he's not sure sure
who that helps but yeah I think I would
just be too tempted to pick up but I I I
disagree about why he was thinking I
think Jordan was giving a very good
example for all the youngsters or chess
improvers watching of managing your time
versus taking your time what happened
here was he had gained an edge on the
clock and rather than blitzing as your
opponent gets under time pressure he
paused took a couple minutes because he
wants it because what's going to happen
now is Jordan wants to commit to the
winning line or at least the line that
he thinks is good but 40 turizaga knows
which line is coming so that your
opponent can't react in a forceful
manner right we've all all of us here
have heard it from coaches at different
times in our careers right I being the
weakest player Among Us so maybe I
stopped hearing it earlier but you know
what I'm talking about David can you say
that one more time I'm the weakest
player here I see one more time how many
times
the point is the point is you manage
your time when you have an edge on the
clock and that allows you to to put your
opponent in an impossible spot right so
now they're trying to like look at this
E3 Jordan already calculated E3 before
he played Rook takes H4 that's my point
and so he's gonna make it harder for
eturizaga to not just solve the problems
but do so with no time on the clock yeah
and that's often a very good strategy
against someone who is in time pressure
uh you kind of change the pace at
tourism he's kind of building up the
adrenaline he's like come on move move
that's uh up the speed but so Jordan's
like slowing it down keeping him
guessing and okay he's thrown away a
poor Newton there must be a concrete
idea here he can give a night check this
must be the idea to drag White's Queen
onto a skirt it's going to be forked
attacked by Black Knight but some
complications there it's still very
messy it's actually quite messy I mean
it's one of those positions you see
White's dark Square Bishop if that can
ever come to life it could be white who
uh grabs the initiative I mean I think
Jordan's still doing okay I mean does he
dive in with a knight and grab some
material in the position I mean it
reminds me what Danny was saying there
very quickly this fantastic book called
uh chess for tigers and um uh if you
haven't got the book as well worth
getting and there was a little bit of
advice there that if you've got a better
position then you should not play
quickly you really shouldn't because why
what's the point you're only going to go
wrong if your opponent's sure to time if
your opponent's short of time and you're
worse then you can maybe try some
hustling techniques but
um in in this case there's yeah I agree
with Danny no reason to uh move quick
but yeah how did you evaluate this David
this position it's hard black has won
the exchange he did throw in that night
check forcing work to give up a rook and
due to the pin on the H file white
cannot regain the material but now I'm
looking at Queen slides I'm not sure to
G3 or G5 which one is more attractive
initially I thought G5 you attack this
Rook attack this Pawn but Black's idea
must be to maybe swing the queen across
and uh some breakthroughs against the H3
pawn it looks like everything's covered
here for black and meanwhile Queen g3 at
least holds everything together forces
this black Rook back
maybe it just Retreats maybe this is uh
this is the issue I'm not sure which
Square again but looks like Jordan's got
everything covered and material up
that's for the pawn trade and you might
go in with the queen move you're
pointing out also let's update everyone
that the other game has in fact ended
peacefully in a draw Federate versus
Wesley so it starts with the draw it's
the best of two so only one more rapid
game remains for those two players but
it's all eyes on this wild position that
we have and the last move by Eduardo
dirizaga with under 30 seconds on the
clock is it still tricky for black to
convert this and Jordan just found it
Rook H5 because again he earned his Edge
on the clock and now for the last
several moves he's been managing his
time well to Simon's point he's in a
better position so he's making sure that
he uh he lets his opponent suffer I mean
I think he's playing phenomenal like
I'll just like I think that maybe
initially we were a little worried about
this Knight G4 thing but the more we
look at it I think Jordan had calculated
it he managed his time appropriately I
think he's going to win with black and
uh and put it Tori Saga on on edge and
we saw a feature chapter with praise for
Jordan's move of getting the Rook the
queen side Rook into the attack on the
F9 I think that's a great point because
you really want to bring all the toys to
the nursery ring the whole party get the
attack going and that Rook on the F line
is a dangerous piece
I love it and Rook H5 by the way that
was a phenomenal move right this this
pin and now and now after Queen G3 he'll
I'm assuming Play Bishop F5 but maybe he
can
go funky maybe he can take H3 like I
don't know because if it takes F2 and
queen takes H3 yeah I mean there's some
crazy idea the reason I would say no is
because the queen takes G6 check but but
maybe that doesn't work maybe the black
queen just slides some blocks and you
have to Queens oh yeah
boom and uh yeah the other line you were
showing Danny after all the white Bishop
takes place yeah enough for which order
rotates F2 maybe the king moves back uh
oh it is out of danger maybe you go the
other order Rook takes Bishop first ah
okay and you win the queen okay you win
the queen uh here you force the white
king away deflect it and everything
falls the house it's so much easier to
suggest lines when I'm not in control of
The Mouse and the highlighter it's easy
to just focus on on these tactics and if
I make a mistake then you'll cover it up
it's no big deal
I'll try we've got each other's backs
here but uh okay he didn't go for that
it's only delayed it though maybe he can
go for it again this time Danny your
idea Bishop takes H3 it looks like uh he
did throw a rook in the way but White's
Rook now is off on a limb not
contributing to the defense it feels
like there's a breakthrough this so many
pieces just hovering around White's King
I mean when you've got a situation like
this you know with your P you can kind
of feel the the you know the position is
ready to you know to to flop for your
opponent and um that's why a move like
Bishop H3 should be high on the radar
but he hasn't played it yeah he didn't
find it he's he's still playing much
Karma here but I guess from a maturity
perspective we should applaud the fact
that if he didn't see a win he didn't go
for it because his opponent only has 15
seconds so he's continuing to grind it
out and again sorry I'm just I'm
applying Jordan's player overall I just
feel like he's handled this in a very
disciplined manner even if there was
objectively a better computer win yeah
that's the last move King H7 just
getting tucking the black king to safety
that is really mature really five four
he needs to make a move David he might
get flagged and he finally plays Rook C6
with just three seconds on the clock and
the King side falls apart it's over
Bishop G4
what's going to be the final blow I like
Bishop D1 because it looks stupid
and I love stupid looking loose but I
mean again the the black Rooks I love
how they've got to the H file I mean
it's really pretty and quite unique that
they're sort of way over there and um by
the way I love this feature where the
engine suggests the move I'm just seeing
it for the first time because I don't
I'm not looking at that that's awesome
just to quickly see what the engine says
is best yeah we can see the more the
engine thinks the more it thinks black
is winning and a similar idea to yours
Simon the black Bishop got out the way
for the black Rook to attack White's
Queen some counter-attacks against the
black queen but it's not enough look at
the perfect coordination of Black's
pieces uh everything on light squares
everything protecting each other and
White's Queen is gonna fall or it's
gonna be Checkmate this is a beautiful
game this is actually one of the one of
my favorite games I love the king's into
defense I mean it's favored by Kasparov
by Bobby Fisher some of the most
aggressive most fun players out there
and uh I love seeing people play it
nowadays because the computer kind of
eats it but that's it he resigns as you
were saying what a game this has been by
Jordan Von Forest killing it on the king
side literally there with his attack at
the end then he takes his lead which
means that Eduardo etrizaga will have to
win the next game on demand to force a
playoff that's the lead for Jordan the
other match ended in a draw that was a
tactical Masterpiece David what was the
big moment in that one yeah just a
really well-controlled game by Jordan
van forest and the way he ended it was
really instructive here as Danny was uh
pointing out Jordan had a big time
Advantage but finding the killer blue is
the hardest thing in chess and he had
calculated in advance that pawn to E3
wins material and this is the safest the
surest way of banking the advantage it
drags the White Queen to the E3 Square
where it gets forked by the Black Knight
and this check cost white material you
had to give up the exchange and as we
saw a bit later on black was able to
coordinate everything later bringing
this Rook into the attack as well and
eventually it was the white king that
was in Peril and uh yeah beautiful
technique from Jordan brand Forest
amazing technique amazing finish and an
amazing attacking game that by Jordan
can he keep up the pace in the final
round of the losers round one and there
we have our score line Wesley so
Vladimir fantasy of keep it even one
rapid game remaining another draw means
an Armageddon in Eduardo terizaga it is
who has to win on demand to take it to
the Armageddon it's going to be quite a
match that's coming up and we will be
back with round two action in just a few
thank you
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
[Music]
foreign
want to improve your game click the link
in the chess.com navigation bar to try
aim chest today and increase your rating
31 faster than standard tactics puzzles
when you sign up for aim chess our
powerful AI breaks down your latest
games and provides actionable insights
to immediately improve your game you
will also receive personalized lessons
created from your game history to help
you learn from your mistakes in a custom
made study plan to help you reach your
goals learn chess your way with aim
chess your digital chess coach
[Music]
unlock your up attention right now with
the aim chess analytics and lessons and
you can get your first month free with
code CCT
go.chess.com aim chess David how cool is
it and how important is it that you can
get targeted training to improve your
chess yeah Tanya I've got to say I love
aim chess these days I'm pretty busy I
do a lot of things and aim chess is just
a quick and effective way of pinpointing
weaknesses telling you what to work on
and just tailoring uh personalizing uh
all of that information it's uh it's
something I definitely recommend
especially for the busy players out
there I've tried it it's really cool you
definitely have to check it out and
right now Eduardo terzaga who has to
check out what he needs to do in this
final round because he has to find a way
to beat Jordan a van forest in a
must-win situation to keep his chances
alive in the aim chest rapid but it
really felt that that game was an all
Jordan show yeah it's hard because
Jordan also won with black right and so
at this level getting the first move is
so huge in terms of their ability to
dictate the opening that will be played
and then therefore the types of middle
games and whether the game is going to
have any fights so also Jordan played
pretty darn good chess there so right
now my money would be on Jordan we saw
crazier things happened yesterday when
notreca do satorophone with black on
command but uh I think I think
ichirizaga has an uphill fight yeah he's
got to pick a very sharp opening uh and
he's got to Hope Jordan is not playing
as well as he did in that last game as
well so being
yeah it's gonna be exciting and I'm also
looking forward to seeing uh Wesley so
back uh back at the table it feels like
he's stemmed the bleeding in that last
one and better save maybe a mistake to
swap Queens off he could have maybe
sensed a bit of weakness there sense
that so was a bit uncertain but yeah I
was gonna say though it's hard to hard
to say who that game was a win for right
when it comes to a draw we sometimes
debate well who won right uh better say
of Drew with black so you got to be
happy about that but Wesley so has been
on tilt and was so much worse in the
game that I would argue Wesley has got
to be taking a sigh of relief and saying
okay here we go
I can do this it's not going to be
enough because he needs to create his
own chances in the next game and he will
play with the black pieces we see
phariseev is the first one in waiting
for Wesley to arrive on camera there a
new room today a new day there will we
see some new openings by Wesley with
black
uh but Wesley plays loads of openings
and uh again we see the the best named
opening being played here clearly uh the
English opening uh I'm sure we're gonna
get along
Annie Danny you know women's chessable
course on the English yeah
um but it's it's a nice uh it's a nice
actually opening to get a not such a
theoretical game uh nowadays I mean a
lot of E4 stuff is worked out maybe it's
a bit more positional the English and
where's Wesley gone though is he hiding
in the cupboard or something Wesley
hello and um oh there he is running
Wesley he did look at that he's happy it
happened yesterday too remember that he
was uh Heidi was out about hiding and uh
although yesterday there was some sort
of miscommunication that had happened
and so they restarted I'm not sure if
today Wesley was just late but here he
is now
huh where are those cats yeah it feels
like uh Something's Happened there but
okay a minute down he starts this game
Wesley so and he plays the move E6 and
the English opening I think the reason
we love it not just the name is because
it keeps lots of pieces on the board uh
no direct draws no uh early kind of
release of tension here and a fiancato
from G3 how will Wesley react now I see
so he won the global Chess Championship
right he's been on fire in so many of
the online events but Vladimir
Fellowship the big fish we've seen him
win events after events his phenomenal
performance in the protest League he was
the MVP of the League this year if this
match was to go down to the Armageddon
and we're talking about Mouse skills
who's faster there
wow um
Captain Mouse it's Wesley yeah cat and
mouse I I would still give the nod to
Wesley um and again there's a reason his
class is what you know his reputation
there is what precedes him right um even
if there's been a been a few bumpy
moments over the last couple days so I
would still say Wesley is the favorite
but um but given what happened yesterday
right they're given that there's got to
be a little bit of a hangover in terms
of how he lost to Notre Beck I don't
think Wesley wants that so
you know I I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna plead
the fifth and say a coin flip giving
Wesley would normally have the edge but
right now Federal save has been playing
a little better
yeah so you think Wesley would want this
match decided in the rapid I I mean
right now he's black right so I think
what he wants is just to play a good
chess game and probably not lose
um but uh
but yeah I mean I I really do believe
there's something to the mindset that
they're in which is I just want to play
a good game right now because that's all
I can possible yeah exactly so far
and meanwhile Wesley took a pause there
and played the move C5 he wants to get
his Queen side developed uh White has
very uh kind of quick easy moves here
white just puts up on D3 we're gonna see
White's king castle to safety uh black
often has issues on the long diagonal
you look at white slight Square Bush one
G2 there are always tricks uh it's a bit
uh difficult here for Wesley so to
develop so
um yeah he's got to be careful I've seen
this go wrong several times even for
very strong Grand masters from the black
side
looks like a decent opening Choice from
fantasy of at least forcing Wesley to
think at this early stage
yeah I mean Black's pieces look a bit
funny here I mean the you look at the
the knight in front of the queen uh that
that night is just on a weird Square I
mean when you're developing when you're
doing stuff at the start of the game you
want to control the center you want to
get your king safe but you want to put
your pieces on good squares right and
that Knight is probably gonna have to
re-route because it gets in the way of
the bishop gets in the way of the queen
it doesn't have any effect on the center
as well so just looking at the pieces uh
White's pieces are a bit more harmonious
at the moment so uh yeah I think feather
Sev will be happy so far with the way
things have gone
about to say I'm happy in this opening
and one player who's happy in the other
match is Jordan van forest and their
final rapid game is about to lift off we
see iterizaga there he plays with the
black pieces the first game going down
to Jordan in quite a destructive manner
that was and Jordan starts with the
Queen spawn opening does he want to keep
things solid in this one yeah definitely
but um it's not also Jordan's style to
keep things solid so you gotta you gotta
be careful because you don't want to say
to yourself okay I've got to be so solid
then playing a really different style to
what you're used to playing it's
actually better to play your normal way
and Jordan's normal ways to play a
little bit crazy so so um yeah I'm
actually changing my mind here quite
quickly I agree and I think Lavon
aronian spoke on this right during his
interview yesterday and it's it's really
something we should underestimate that
it's it's also hard to be in the spot
where it feels like you can go no wrong
right because now you're double you're
double guessing yourself on everything
and whether I should have played the
position I normally would and so I I
think Jordan will be okay and and you
know here he's playing a classical ninja
with the with the queens of C2 but um
but yeah it's difficult to be in a spot
where you feel like anything anything is
good for you but then maybe that
backfires what do you think David is
playing for a draw the worst way to play
for a draw
myself trust me too many times playing
negative chess passive chess especially
against the top guys in the world and
they do punish you uh if you take
negative decisions and uh Jordan I must
admit I've very rarely seen him play
this queen C2 move but he does choose to
plant all of his Pawns in the center and
actually that has a very Jewish
reputation in that line and uh tourism
has been forced to choose a variation
that doesn't allow anything I was going
to say the very drawish line is the line
with D5 and so itiri Saga doesn't go for
that as someone who plays this system
for black there are a lot of very deep
theoretical lines if you have D5 and E5
and 94 so a good I think an interesting
call there by Jordan to play something
that's aggressive but also is a bit
baiting in terms of whether iterizaga
wants to play the best lines which may
be a draw so now look now look black
doesn't have the best lines but that
means white has an edge white has a big
Center and this is going to be a fun
game for him this move I'm quite
surprised about I mean this is a very
aggressive move from Jordan I mean it is
it's obviously quite a natural move
gaining space attacking Black's knife
but he had a safe Advantage without
pushing that pawn and the pawn I mean is
the E Pawn the pawn in front of White's
king
um because you can overextend yourself
as well you know if you put a pawn into
your opponent's side of the board it can
become weak on the other hand white has
some attacking chances and here he goes
straight towards Black's King I guess
this may still be theory that I'm not
aware of I guess yeah at least until uh
White captured that pawn on D6 so I was
still familiar with the position now
after Bishop to D3 like you said Simon
Just threats against the black king side
I think Jordan's just happy to develop
whether it's Theory or not he's just
happy to get that white king to safety
and
he's done nothing wrong he's got no
reason to be worse here with white uh
still lots of pieces on the board though
and wow a tourism doesn't react to a
threat against that black H7 Pawn he
just tries to break in the center while
White's King is still stranded I like
that move I don't even care what happens
I like that move that that is an
aggressive move if white takes H7 with
check we are going to be in for a fight
and uh interesting one to kind of invite
your opponent to go for when when you're
kind of playing at their psychological
whatever heartstrings brain brain teas
right what do you want to do
yeah and uh
the last move by three Saga is that more
determined because of the math situation
going completely all out all in inviting
white to take a very key King Side Pawn
I mean I I think it looks like it also
kind of works though because there's a
lot of tactics here the white king is in
the center the C4 Pawn is hanging in a
lot of lines so David you've got the
analysis Board of what do you see here
yeah first he has to decide how to take
in the center usually you might want to
take with the pawn uh but now I think it
is just a clear sacrifice after Bishop
takes Pawn the black king has to move
and white does have time to evacuate
this bishop I'm not sure where you slide
back but even this is actually
complicated Black's Knight is going to
jump into the center White's King is
just one move too far away and if you do
castle in the position like this you
have to wonder what happens if black
tries to trap your Bishop so this is
mightily complicated and instead he
chooses to take with a knight the more
Dynamic option playing with pieces
rather than Pawns in the center and yeah
I would be too terrified I think to
capture this Pawn on H7 uh it just feels
like you losing too much time especially
with this one I was thinking of because
at the end of it now F3 is hanging
Knight D4 is coming if that trade
happens C4 is hanging
you're doing much better than me Danny
at the moment with the jokes but um yeah
I really like the way that um uh black
has played this I think he's played it
you know perfectly with the match
situation he's played in a very
aggressive way as well and Jordan now
has has to really think as well I mean
does he grab that pawn or does he I
think I think Jordan would normally want
to grab that pawn knowing Jordan but
maybe it's just a bad move maybe it's
just uh he can't maybe it's just
impossible too slow you choose not to
Jordan he's just castled his King so now
it's black to move he didn't take up the
challenge uh maybe influenced by the
match situation and now firstly you can
play F5 to block this diagonal you can
also plant your knight into the center
in D4 uh it just looks like big success
this opening for black I loved F5 he
didn't go for it he played 94 first but
it may not matter maybe he follows with
the same idea but
no when you saw E5 you felt like it was
uh it was the right the right call to
the the challenge right he was up for
the challenge that being a teary Saga
knowing he has to win it's winner go
home literally for him in his aim chess
rapid campaign so uh so here we go this
is going to be a fun a fun game and uh
he's already up on the clock definitely
feeling confident there we see head in
hand that's a pose we see from eternity
Saga time to time so
here we go I'm excited for this one I
want to see him cheer again because uh
if you've been watching the show from
start we obviously had a video of how he
qualified for this event which which was
fantastic he got so emotional and it's
nice to see a bit of emotion in chess
because we don't always see it you know
chess players are supposed to be very
you know statue-like aren't they and not
give much away so I love it when a chess
player shows any kind of emotion you
know they're not you know inside chess
players are going bonkers so I I'd love
to see some more cheering at the board
is that something we want more of in
general do we want more cheering
cheerleaders
or celebrations we want to see all of
that and I think this is also such a big
moment for iterizaga to have made it to
division one because very often we we
know all these Grand Masters but again
and again we keep saying they're not
these big household names they don't get
invitations to these top level
tournaments and then when you got a
division two or you go to planes you've
got these opportunities to actually
fight to play against the big boys in
division one it means so much and I
think that celebration was exactly a
reflection of that it rizaga one of the
strong Grand Masters finally getting a
chance to fight it out with the best in
the world 100 I mean it's been cases in
the past where uh some players have
actually turned up with cheerleaders
have you seen that I think there was I
can't remember the Russian player who
did it but he turned up a long time ago
is that something I thought you were
talking about Phil Hellmuth recently at
the World Series
no but should we get I agree with what
both of you said I think the emotion was
real this opportunity means so much to
him but also I would say that there's
something about the online format that
in this modern sort of evolution of the
game has been fun because we probably
wouldn't see players pump their fist and
scream in a quiet Hotel Ballroom
somewhere right the opportunity for
these guys to really Express their
emotions kind of comes out in the
comfort of their own home whether it's
Magnus put his leg up and whatever
whatever was going on yesterday the
Netflix and chill what's that or whether
it's the emotion and again obviously
we're in the we're in the business of
online chess and we're excited to see
where the game is going and growing but
I really believe that that there's
something really special about what we
get to see here because you don't see
those emotions every day you don't get
to know them in this way and when they
react it's like oh that chess player
he's not just a quiet guy yeah he really
cares absolutely and do you think that's
also because the players are so
unguarded when they're just they're sort
of playing in their own Solitude they've
got a camera in front of them but no one
around and then you forget chess players
who are so guarded usually about their
emotions not really expressing what's
going on internally but you tend to
forget in that moment and really let it
out yeah I mean they're guarded on the
outside but in the inside they're going
absolutely crazy you know it's like
there's roller coasters going on there
they're sitting there like this but if
you could get a glimpse into their mind
it would be an explosion explosion I
keep saying that I'm like I don't know
man you don't know okay maybe that's
just my mind maybe I'm just freaking
some people out here but uh but Danny if
you I was thinking I don't know why but
the cheerleading aspect I could see you
being a cheerleader but I was just
wondering who who would you who would
you be a champion for you I'll tell you
that you're there for anybody anyone who
needs a cheerleader I'm there I'm there
just call me call me um all right back
to some of the chefs here we've got
Knight B5 we're cheering for tactics
David I see you working hard over there
maybe maybe you got a thought about the
uh the nature of this position Knight to
B5 I still like black C4 is hanging
isn't it yeah it looks like Jordan's
trying to bail out I think he's just
trying to trade off as many pieces as
possible maybe uh the match situation
too much in his mind and uh black does
have some tasty options as you mentioned
Danny uh first of all we can see a pawn
being grabbed uh there's also the kind
of simple old man option that I might
choose just Knight takes Knight and play
with a slightly better Pawn structure
here with black here white has doubled B
pawns and uh black has a king side
majority thanks to this e-born maybe for
example you can play a move like Bishop
C5 and you have this long-term Advantage
you can try and grind down but uh yeah
the key move
Bishop takes C4 here I think the idea is
to play Knight takes Knight and if I'm
not mistaken Bishop takes D4 uh the
whole idea here is a trick if Queen
takes Bishop then the white Bishop
scoots out the way Bishop takes born
check forcing the black king to react
and the black queen Falls of course not
a huge material advantage but a queen
better than blacks pieces so he's
relying on tactics to keep this one
together Jordan right now I like it
critical moment here for Eduardo to take
this decision does he go upon grabbing
or does he trade the knights on the
board now is he he's also as confused as
we are in the studio about what approach
to have and once again it's the math
situation that determines so much of
what's going on on the board then what
is objectively perhaps what's the best
move
totally agree I think that's why he's
giving pause as you said he's giving a
big thing because this is your
opportunity to either continue to fight
or allow a massive simplification and we
know which one he wants which one he has
to go for so
the uh yeah yeah big moment big moment
and while uh Eduardo has a thing to
decide which direction he wants to go in
let's quickly check in with a fat assiev
against Wesley still Queens have been
traded off an end game there but there's
some tension on the king side David yeah
some tension on the king side white has
a slightly better Pawn structure black
has doubled F pawns and feather saves
last movie saying okay let's lock things
down long term my night might be
superior to your bishop or at least more
flexible when attacking uh weak pawns
and big question for Wesley so is
whether he allows things to lock up or
whether he trades Bishop for Knight
that's the only kind of peace and
balance right now and it's always a big
decision any capture especially in end
game system what do you think Bishop
takes Knight or keep the tension
uh that night looks quite nice actually
I mean I I would be tempted to to take
it off and just try to simplify the
position we we well is that saying that
all Rook endings are drawn and you do
remove some of the danger by capturing a
knight uh okay exchanging one pair of
Pawns first seems okay
um I I would capture it I mean Danny
would you would you take it or would you
keep it okay because I I was going to
steal the old Rook endings were drawn
line you stole my thunder but you're
right I think that if Wesley is playing
for a draw even if objectively uh
there's there's good things for white
when you take the Knight I think it
makes sense to get that off the board
also those doubled isolated pawns scare
me those just don't look good they don't
look fun to defend and I feel like more
pieces on the board makes it a little
harder to to do so so
I would take C4 no he doesn't Wesley
wants to kick the bishop it's
interesting because the one thing we
will say is
Wesley hasn't been on grade four maybe
we're thinking he's nervous and wants to
draw the bishop is a better piece than
the Knight as long as there are
opponents on both sides of the board and
the one thing that doesn't immediately
meet the eye is white has this three on
two majority right you have these three
pawns versus two so I'm wondering if you
can safely push B5 and open up the
bishop as long as C5 doesn't become too
tender maybe Wesley thinks there's a
little more to play for here yeah still
that decision persists to take or not to
take it feels like white tonight's gonna
be super strong though on the move on a
square like E5
so yeah I think I would uh I think I
would take it right after all those
things I said I'm like I I don't want to
let that Knight live I uh I think my
king could get in trouble on F6 if the
Knight comes to E5 so I agree Bishop
takes E4 seems what to be what the
doctor ordered yeah this is dangerous
though isn't it it's certainly I think
dangerous to Wesley I mean just the pawn
structure uh I mean pieces okay both
sides have got some Brooks which could
do some damage here but if you just look
at the pawns it's clear to see that
white has the better Pawn structure
um you have better Pawns in the center
blacks pawns on the king side make me
feel a little bit sick and um you know
it's a bit dangerous for Wesley here he
could if he loses this he is out let's
just remind everyone of that you know
this is a really tense game there's no
more Second Chances now you lose now you
go home
um and what is already home isn't he but
you know you get you get the idea you
get it he can play with his cats you've
got a comfy holder I think he's flexing
the chess.com Global championship trophy
in the background if I can by making out
one of those things clearly so um
plays 95 and note that the bishop can't
take A2 because of B3 trapping it so
just a quick visualization there
um and uh so I really like 95 yeah now
we can show it also there's a falcon C6
there's a fork on C6 yep so you got
double problems here maybe he should
have taken that I think he should have
taken the Knight
yeah it's too late now that black uh
Bishop just sitting pretty in the middle
of the board but it's thinner white
tonight just looks uh glorious and it's
white who's playing for two results here
it feels like there's no risk at all for
fedisev okay King E6 nice move getting
ready to kick away that white knight by
pushing upon to F6 but it does allow
White's Rook to enter the seventh rank
maybe root to G7 uh comes to mind I
think it looks like a great thing to
come to mind Rook G7 is calling our name
not my name in particular
Big Fish well that's nature's name get
that Rook into G7 but then other ideas
for black to try to create some
contemplary of his own a David try and
challenge that Rook on the G line it's
the open only open Line in the position
you really want to be the one that grabs
it and yes you're giving up a Pawn on 87
but you want your rook in
for example Tanya if I take this Pawn
now you come in and it's a bit scary I'm
not sure where the white king goes front
of the pawn or back of the pawn maybe
you jump forward and try and hide on D2
and yeah counter play you can play a
move like F6 it's not one-way traffic
here that's for sure I like it often you
just have to go
G7 yeah will he go passive defending he
pushes the Knight first
yep okay
and the question do you have to step
back with the Knights but at least the
bishop can take uh again if it needs to
has another chance yeah another option
will be to block the seventh rank maybe
you can put the Rook on D7 and challenge
uh the piece that's infiltrated there in
G7
board it was nice C4 but still your idea
of Rook D7 that's a that was a nice kind
of calm sometimes you have to be calm in
the face of danger and knights can scare
you right it looks like the Knight is
forking everything but actually there's
nothing to it here black is holding yeah
holding solid we shouldn't doubt Wesley
too much this is his type of position uh
where it's simple where it's just about
two three move ideas at a time
and uh it's very good with the Strategic
uh decision so I'm not gonna blame him
for not taking that night earlier it
looks like he's got another chance over
the next few moves
and if the Rooks come off the board
prediction time is this heading to an
Armageddon yes or no
Wesley is head in hand he's focused I
know we're talking about the moves on
the board and and being a little
critical but you can see how much he
wants it and cares I think he's going to
send this to overtime I think he's going
to hold this and we get free chess
yeah I agree with Danny we are agree and
far too much from my liking but scary I
do agree with Danny I think it is uh
heading that way I mean Wesley is so far
defending excellently it's not over yet
I mean maybe I'm basing this a bit on
the players because if Magnus was white
here I'd be like oh I'd be thinking no
way just resign just reside that's it
yeah just resign and actually even here
there's a lot of play left right because
I mean if the Rooks come off the board
it's probably still a draw but I don't
know I I would not be comfortable being
black here uh Black's probably all right
but those pawns are still weak on the
king side so it's it's not over yeah
what do you reckon I mean you take
weights every time here right just
because uh it feels like black is the
one fighting for his life black doesn't
have too many active winning ideas but
yeah I still trust Wesley I still
believe
despite being slightly off form that
he's got this one under lock and key
anyway
didn't hang the a pawn there I was just
about to say will you challenge The Rook
trade before the a pawn is defended
because you actually could have done it
because A2 would have traded for F5 so
anyway that was a a big decision I think
it's a decision that says again fedo
save also still playing for a win here
like you said David that you would you
would choose white uh but Wesley quickly
responded A5 and look there's no there's
no serious time disadvantage here yes
it's a minute but both of these players
are going to enter time pressure at the
same time so um
this game this game is exciting yeah it
just feels like a winning plan it's the
hardest thing for both players just so
blocked right now Tanya
absolutely David it is photos here but
with the slight advantage in the
position the better night and the better
Pawn structure will it be enough for him
to take this in the rapid potion
meanwhile in the other game action is on
Eduardo durzaga has he managed to create
chances for his comeback I see the eval
Bar says that black is indeed slightly
better hair piece activity David peace
activity better Pawn structure it's a
few small things that do add up and if
we do see a trade of Bishops we could
see something called the Irish pawns
where white has tripled Pawn stacked up
on the B file and yeah black has a poor
majority the danger here for iterizaga
is that too many pieces get traded it
comes down to a rook end game and as
you've all pointed out Rook end games
have that drawish tendency but yeah it
feels like now or never for a tourism he
needs something on the next few moves
maybe turning it into something more
tangible like a pawn game uh all he
needs to get into an end game that he
can guarantee there's still life left
Advantage objectively but is it enough
I'm not 100 sure
I think not a huge margin for error here
I mean he's done a great job though just
to get this position with the black
pieces I mean I I don't oh there we go
it is pretty that one I mean I wish
there was another Pawn just behind that
but uh three pawns is enough right and
uh it is called the Irish pawns and uh I
think it's because uh it happened in
Olympiad and uh an Irish player had the
free pawns and then he played against uh
someone who also had the free pawns and
he lost both times so it didn't really
work very well for him
um but I'm not sure I'd be I think
that's is that why they're called the
Irish pause I think it was Eamon Keon an
Irish player who had it but he might
have to fact check that at home but uh
they look pretty can we just sit back
and enjoy them for a moment yeah just
have a little glass of water and you
know look at those pawns Simon you're
saying pretty to me they look pretty
ugly yeah well that's what I mean yeah
pretty ugly yeah they don't look pretty
it's only a mother could love as they
say uh the the beespre pawn is hanging
but iterizaga played Queen C7 it's kind
of a disciplined move there you he wants
to guard E5 guard d8 and guard the
seventh rank that was the only thing the
queen wasn't doing there right and and
so now the question is can white go for
Rook D5 laugh in the face of the back
ring Checkmate we know that that can get
you in trouble sometimes
uh or does white find another move so I
I actually really like Queen G7 I agree
with Tanya the pawns are so ugly that
iterizaga can play this game out and at
some point have have very good practical
chances we'll likely win all three of
those pawns maybe even for just the A7
Bond so we'll see
I mean actually Queen end games look
very dangerous here for white king of
poor nine games at dead loss Rook end
games might be the only uh Solace here
but getting the Queen's off is not going
to be easy until you mentioned it uh
Danny White's King needed some breathing
space so Milton's given it some lift but
Harry to the rescue always
always and that was the right Advance
too because that was more than just free
the free the back rank that was actually
H5 and H6 and I really like that idea
because it's it's the alpha zero plan
for the win and that's how Jordan
creates chances for his opponent to
blunder right you put the opponent H5
and H6 and now in the time Scramble with
only four minutes left eterizaga down on
the clock again that I really like this
move H4 I love it too and if black gets
greedy captures on B3 then suddenly you
could see the Contours of a mating
attack against the black king if there's
one lands on H6 serious counter play so
again I like what it's it's done he's
pushed his Harry Pawn uh to block this
always seems like a very good first
reaction I mean if anyone pushes their
uh their Harry Pawn towards you just
block it just block it you know I I try
this all the time I like move one two 50
30 70. I'm almost pushing Harry and if
my opponent ever blocks it I'm like okay
back to the drawing board but it it it
is if you're at home and you're
wondering how to deal with Harry which
probably not a lot of people do wonder
about but just block it and uh good move
right this is a good move here at least
I think yeah yeah
I agree Simon you talked about Harry
what do you call uh triplets those bee
pawns right now oh that's a good
question yeah famous triplets the free
Musketeers because they're a bit Mucky
just made that up I don't know uh help
me bucket deers
yeah the free birdie tears
um we need some help there hello Barney
and birdie yeah Billy Barney but that's
not bad not bad all right well we are we
are clearly deliberate some high level
chess analysis but we didn't have
history you just made up a new Pond name
with the Musketeers if we go with it
um I think we need chat to chip in with
some better suggestions I think so yeah
yeah chat let us know help us out but uh
meanwhile yeah it's one-way traffic it's
a tourism here uh playing for the win
and minimal risk so dream scenario but
still you wouldn't in it and the big
question will it be enough is always the
burning one here foreign because a draw
will not cut it it will mean the end of
his Road in the aim chest rapid he has
to find a way to get more in this
position we will check back with this
let's go back to the end game that we
had with the Vladimir Fellowship against
Wesley so Vladimir photo save was the
one who was pushing for the advantage is
that still the scenario or has Wesley
made progress I don't think it is
anymore and it's funny because even
though it was a risky decision at the
time keeping the bishop versus the
Knight had ambition to it right and that
this is maybe the the idea Wesley
started long ago when he played team G7
King F6 look at the King on the queen
side there's a three on two majority we
talked about it and there's real chances
here especially when you now add guess
who's up on the clock whoa Wesley was
down a minute and a half now he's up a
minute and I don't know I mean
maybe uh maybe Armageddon isn't all that
Wesley's looking for here yeah so Wesley
type of position we've said it and uh
there's also this idiom that even the
worst Bishop is as good as the best
Knight and Black's Bishop controlling
the White Knight right now oh risky
decision from FedEx to put a Pawn on a
light Square to block Black's King's
path towards the queen side
feels like yeah Wesley's been making the
progress It's just again whether there's
a breakthrough or not Black's Bishop is
slightly tied down so can't go Pawn
hunting yet
do we see any breaks
the drama here it's funny because we had
a stat coming into this into this
matchup shockingly to all of us Wesley
so and Vladimir Fido save have never
played in Rapid In classical rapid but I
pulled up because I know I've seen these
faces play each other before and my
memory was right that they both took
turns knocking each other out and
official random World Chess Championship
on chess.com over the last few years in
2019 it was Wesley so who sent fedo save
home and everyone remembers he went on
to win actually here in Oslo beat Magnus
Carlson to become the first ever
fisherman and World Champion and then in
2022 a lot of people forgot that Federal
save was the one who sent him home and
so these two guys have a little bit of a
history maybe it wasn't in classical
traditional chess but these two guys
have a history of knocking each other
out so let's go as much it's fun yeah it
makes sense why the first one ended in a
draw and this looks like it very well
could be headed that way a really nice
Point made there that even though white
on the queen side has a Pawn on the
light Square it's difficult for blacks
Bishop to get there because of the
doubled pawns that black has on the F
line on the file with whitesnite is it
still a game though for two results with
Photoshop always having these two pawns
on the F line and the Knight jumping to
C4 as a resource oh
it's time to Simon and game expert yeah
we all have to play endings I mean I I
kind of think there's free results now
right I mean uh yeah just because if you
look at the left-hand side of the board
the Queen side uh that that move that
whites had to play okay maybe they're
gonna go for a draw here could be could
be heading that way the game ends yeah I
mean well we're going to see how
ambitious feathersev is I guess now
um is FedEx going to keep trying to push
this one okay well my question is
whether Wesley is going to play Rook G6
that would be the one try for him
because if the trade happens the H Pawn
helps but we also have we have
excitement everywhere here yeah we let's
just wait to see if federalism decides
to actually repeat this position because
that means this game ends I agree if you
guys can't you do it's a big critical
moment here
yeah I think it's going to oh he's going
for a win oh okay well he doesn't want
the draw look at Wesley he kind of
perked up there and smiled a little bit
maybe that was good by him too he's like
all right you want more let's do this
thing does he want to bring the Rook
around to the queen side I mean that's
the only thing I can see here but this
check makes a lot of sense right wow so
uh we might have a draw another way
though yeah yeah yeah huge spawn Under
Fire Fantasy of making his intentions
very clear he wants to go for the win in
this end game and the other player who
needs to go for the win is Eduardo
teruzaga we're getting big updates from
our other game Let's quickly jump to
that one this is going to go on for a
while and here we are can Eduardo do it
in this queen Pawn end game oh I'm not
so sure the queen side pawns still ugly
they still exist those uh bee pawns for
white but they are canceled out by
Black's Queen side pawns if you just
assume that they all cancel each other
out then it would be a draw three versus
two on the king side is actually a very
simple draw in a uh Queen and Paul name
game so it's all about whether iterizaga
can combine play on both sides of the
board can he slowly pick up those weak
white pawns while maybe uh going for
some checks against the white king
creating a passport on the king side
I'm a bit skeptical I've got to say I I
am too I think that whatever chances had
whatever chances etori Saga had I think
left him when he actually traded traded
the Rooks earlier just because the they
needed to keep as many pieces on the
board as he could I mean we're about to
see a repetition in front of us and not
the kind he tirizaga wants because he
doesn't get another chance in Armageddon
if this one's a draw
I absolutely hate Queen endings I really
don't like him they're far too
complicated for my small mind I mean
whatever I get in them I'm never sure
where to put the Queen the king there's
so many checks only possibilities and
actually if you look at computers
computers are so good compared to the
best humans and that's where they really
show their dominance in in one aspect
over humans and queen endings and I mean
Magnus nepo are famous for their Queen
endings but they're really tricky to
play and obviously black has to try
everything here and here he goes he's
gonna try I do like that he's he's
trying he's got to try to get a some
kind of past pawn and uh the white
King's very exposed so it's always going
to be loose to a check there's a threat
of that Harry pawn it would be kind of
poetic if Harry came in and won the game
I feel in every game of chess so biased
you're always rooting for the age Pawn
to have the last say but Queen C4 was a
very good move by Jordan just holding
the fort literally like an invisible
force field and electric fence across
the fourth rank you shall not pass
now the downside for black is what as
well is that he's made his own King
slightly Weak by trading off those pawns
the black king is also susceptible to
some checks later on nothing yet I like
this move from maturizago when in doubt
just stop the opponent's checks just
centralize your queen but uh yeah still
the winning technique the winning uh
strategy here remains a mystery Queen
back to C2 Jordan just yo-yoing back and
forth waiting with the White Queen this
could go on forever it's probably got to
get his King in I guess at some point
black uh he doesn't want to move his
King Force he's going to try everything
else but I'd imagine he's got to get his
King and I mean let's remember if the
Queens just come off the board this is a
good way to evaluate things you should
be trying to do if you remove the Queens
from the board I think black is just
quite easily winning because
um black
um will get a passport on the king side
so uh so that's that's something to
worry about yeah something to worry
about meanwhile ituruzaga may be setting
up some check mating ideas against the
white king which has sidelined itself on
H3 a bit strange here this one is going
to be a long long
still two result game but needs the win
at all costs
Queen D3 just stopping any checks
Jordan's still in control three seconds
on the clock for Eduardo durizaga he
needs to find a way to win this one
there is also a big action and big
update on the other board as the
durazaga continues to fight in the
screen and pawn end game should we
quickly just check into yeah we we
should because there may have been a
moment that could have sent one of the
players home that wasn't played David if
we if we can quickly pull up analysis
because now we are truly deadlocked we
see a 50 50 result but a few moments ago
Wesley actually blundered with the move
Rook G7 check and for some reason
fedosev in this moment chose to retreat
rather than bring the king to H4 and the
reason is that once the king advances
there's threats of Rook D5 attacking
both of the pawns and it's actually not
possible for Wesley to deal with all of
those threats maybe he calculated rookie
seven and sort of panicked on the on the
pawn trade but this position had winning
chances
yeah this has big winning Chances with
that King activating and for some reason
the big fish in the big moment went
backwards it's pretty strange you've got
a usual King I mean it's the Forrest
Gump King yeah run run for us run yeah
the game Sorry front forest Run is the
other game
oh yeah you're just too quick today I'm
too slow today but yeah you've got to
use the king and the King's gotta run
into an opponent's position so
surprising he didn't consider this when
he's trying to win most of the game it's
funny because if we depending on what
happens maybe we'll get to ask him what
he calculated there if he ultimately
goes on to win but I think now we will
see a draw so that means that means we
should probably go back to the game that
is likely to send a player home but
indeed there was a big moment here we're
gonna get Armageddon I think between
these two and uh and there we have it
yeah just when in doubt go forward with
the King just go active I think is a
good rule in all end games if you have a
choice
but this is uh the other game I think
we've been here before this is the
second time we've seen this position
like I said when in doubt go forward
with the King but is he John is there a
Checkmate is there some ideas
okay he moved he made a move okay
where's the trackmates where's it's
Queen H3
I I don't see it we're playing Guess the
Movie or maybe you can force the Queens
off when the king Retreats Queen G4 and
the Queens will come off Simon you're
getting your king and Portland game and
the King opponent is winning look at
iterizaga knows it he's perked up yeah
wow can you say double the Armageddon
double the fun not just
about Jordan
completely winning shaking his head in
disbelief
absolutely wild that Jordan played it's
funny by the way King H4 on both boards
for one of them it was correct for one
of them it was losing lol I literally
just said always push your king forward
if in doubts
the commentators curse look at this
everyone the reason the king upon ending
is winning as Tanya said is black is
basically just up a free Pawn here it's
two on one and the double beep sorry
Triple B pawns excuse me are useless
yeah they mean nothing at all right now
they're completely neutralized
results incoming wow and we already have
result on the other game that one ended
in a draw so that's one Armageddon
confirmed and with this big blunder by
Jordan in a position that was he was so
in control we're heading for two armor
Gardens
bit disappointed though Edward is he
gonna do a crazy celebration come on I
want to see the chair I want to see the
chair at the end are we going to get it
it almost happened already with the the
way his body perked up I don't know that
he'll celebrate yet if he wins it or
again I'm gonna guess we see a big a big
fish yeah he's shaking right now he's
and he knows it and he's just advancing
the bond white spawns are too slow on
the queen side he's gonna Queen is
Jordan gonna resign
never resigned but uh
now would be a good moment yeah those
players know it but uh wow this is a
good time to resolve wow I mean the bee
pawns are triple but they're not going
to become free Queens are they you know
they're not going anywhere I mean maybe
if that pawn was one square further for
us it'd be a little bit tricky but even
then it's probably still losing isn't it
I think he'll Chuck and take B4 and then
we'll see Jordan resign indeedy does
with Queen D2 I think after it takes B4
yeah we will see the towel no okay now
yeah yeah fun will also decide the game
there's one more gone alive for black
and that's it Jordan resigns we are in
for double the fun as both these matches
go into Armageddon there we have the
bottle sip by iterizaga he survived the
scare he managed to win the game what a
comeback this was Jordan walking into
that one move blunder that David what
was the highlight for you well we have
to go through an action replay of that
blunder it was a commentator's curse
just as we were saying King H4 was the
winning move in the other Clash King H4
was the losing move in this one here it
was uh Jordan's move white to play and
any logical move any safe move such as
for example Queen to C3 check would have
kept the game alive it would have been a
long grind but King H4 was the losing
blunder walking onto a unfortunate
circuit here with the white king a check
forced It Forward another check forced
the king to sidestep but maybe this was
the check that Jordan had missed Queen
H3 forcing the white king away if you
step back when she thought is a killer
next move this Pawn drops with a check
so King E4 was forced and as we saw this
check was fatal anyway after the Queens
came off the board it was a simple case
of black much in the king forward and
winning the end game
King H4 being a decisive move in both
games Dani as you call that what are the
odds of that chances of that right and
we literally saw it in real time we were
following it it was one of those moments
where everyone had to be following it at
chess.com events because we couldn't
possibly keep up with the drama but King
H4 would have won for big fish and it
loses
for Jordan and we have uh we have double
art and get Armageddon I can't even say
it and I think exact same moment it's
gonna be double the fun let's take a
look at our score line what a turnaround
it has been completely unexpected that
Wesley saw Vladimir photos keeping it
peaceful two draws solid results there
goes into Armageddon but the big fight
on the Jordan board Jordan wins the
first one Eduardo wins the second one
manages to equalize the score and now we
will have the bids which will be coming
in soon and we're gonna have two
armageddon's the fun is on in the losers
around round one but not just here it
was also a lot of fun when Magnus
Carlsen and David Howell took on each
other in an earthings challenge take a
look
yeah that really just looks like you're
moving upon like a knight
does this actually work
you tell me
I'm guessing I know you're guessing just
sometimes your guess is all right
no problem
oh I just saw a nice way to list again
spotted my trap yeah which is D4 nice
he sees everything one thing is like the
play just this way but the watch this
must be
full disclosure here David hasn't even
revealed off camera what was the result
of that game David that looks like a lot
of fun it was a lot of fun uh yeah
Magnus yeah I think he's better at
normal chess than he was with ething's
chess but yeah I won't reveal anything
yet you have to stay tuned
Aldo gives a little bit away but you
will find out what
today has been
built video but right now it is all
about the Armageddon that's coming up
and we will come back with all the aim
chess action on the other side of this
break
[Music]
thank you
tonight
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Meetup community and your local group on
meetup.com chess and get the chess
growing hashtag grow the game caddy
we've been having so much fun in
division one we've set ourselves up for
two Armageddon and I believe you've got
a lot of fun updates from the other two
divisions as well that's right Tanya
earlier you asked me if we're gonna have
more night sacrifices and I came here
with a chess game in the division two we
can see here amitabhatabai leads against
Jose Martinez Jose Martinez had such an
incredible chance to win this second
game now we can pull it the board on the
screen and you can check out that game
where he had a chance and probably there
was his chance as we can say now he's
losing the match fourth game is now in
progress so let's take a look now
can't wait to see what you have with us
Cathy this is the position take us
through yeah so here it is white to move
and the move that we're looking for is
Knight takes H6 it's a great sacrifice
but then when Pawn takes this night you
take the Rook F6
Queen text stroke and now the work on a
fade is not protected and white has way
too many pawns and it is winning
position however Jose decided not to
sacrifice the Knight here and instead of
this he played Knight to D6 and next he
gave the check and he decided to
sacrifice on H6 Bishop
so he changed a little bit strategy now
but this was a bad move now black takes
denied and white is again sacrificing
the bishop on G7 and this is even worse
move after Queen D4 check this is very
as we're waiting for the Armageddon bids
by the players and of course the burning
question always is how low can you go
and how important is that going to be
for the players to try to get the black
pieces that's the big question David I'm
going to start with you how low can you
go no lower than around eight and a half
minutes we saw it yesterday around eight
minutes might be the golden number but
anything less than that it's just too
low it's too dangerous
so we saw yesterday not the best
Armageddon bid against Wesley so that's
The Sweet Spot you want to keep it
between eight and eight and a half
minutes that seems to be the sweet spot
and um I'm an important thing to
remember about Armageddon is that you
don't get any added time so in all the
other games As Time added on each move
but in Armageddon the time goes very
very quickly so losing on time is a real
possibility I think one of the twists is
considering what color you might want to
play I think for some players there's
also a bit of the gamesmanship which is
it's a must win game and maybe I won't
wait and more time right and so I think
that I think that for some players they
might actually even be considering
whether they want the first move just
depending on the openings or the prep
they might have
and big reveal we are getting the bids
in for one of the matches and Vladimir
fellowship with 11 minute 24 seconds
goes down to Wesley's those bid within
eight minutes 27 seconds Wesley wins the
bid will start with 8 minutes 27 seconds
on the clock and the black pieces which
means with the white pieces Federal CF
has to win on demand Wesley gets the
draws but that's a big big margin there
I was gonna say like maybe that's a bid
that suggests Pharaoh save was ready to
play white I mean he must have seen
Wesley bid eight minutes and 12 seconds
yesterday so he knew Wesley was gonna do
something in that range 11 minutes and
24 seconds says I'm okay playing white
with a Time match yeah he's confident
isn't he very confident there because uh
that's much higher than we've seen so
far uh so this is going to be yeah it's
really exciting is he going to play the
English again don't we think I hopefully
I hope so as well yeah I think it's just
a confident man he just packs himself
better say if he's been here before he's
done it before and uh he's probably
confident the way the games have been
going he has had the better of Wesley
for a lot of the first two games and he
just needs to put it together into a win
in this uh all decisive one now
with an aggressive bid to try to get the
white pieces he said I'll be fine if I
get black if I have 11 minutes and 27
seconds when he wanted and it does
reflect that he's happy to start with
the with the white pieces regardless and
we're also getting the bits for the
second match and a similar storyline
here Eduardo edruzaga 12 minutes 12
seconds that looks like a one two one
two random number but uh you're in round
for us with 11 minutes and three seconds
this one also reflects that both players
fine with white again it's funny not
nearly as low as the bids we saw
yesterday or the one bit I guess we saw
yesterday
um I wanted to say maybe federal Savage
did to Wesley when Wesley was black and
he wanted a he wanted to maybe repeat
that so that's one thing to just quickly
say about Federal save but in this other
matchup there again two very high bits
and David we've been seeing so many
Armageddon throughout the Champions
Chester we've never seen these kind of
bids where the players are bidding over
11 minutes
I'm really surprised maybe that's just a
trend players more confident in their
white openings also with uh The
ituruzaga Clash against Jordan
specifically both players one with black
but both players were happy to have
white in the Armageddon
strange Mind Games there and we bought
moves on the board as the Vladimir
photos here vastly saw Armageddon does a
kick off and it starts with one Knight
F3 no English this time
yeah I'm a bit surprised there I mean
like uh you're very confident with white
pieces then you play this load of boring
junk hey this is this is the Hikaru
title Tuesday special speaking of title
Tuesday shout out to everyone playing it
today yeah I mean I don't know I mean
this stuff is tricky it's designed to
get weird positions and also it makes
your opponent think a little bit which
when they don't have a lot of time on
the clock maybe it's not the worst idea
maybe it is just very clever against
Wesley right because Wesley loves what
he knows his theory so well but uh he's
trying to get out of it quickly yeah
there's kind of plus points and negative
points the negative here is as Danny
says Hikaru plays this all the time in
Blitz and Wesley knows Hikaru really
well they've played each other countless
time so he will be aware of what he
should be doing Black's Bishop doing a
bit of a dance here uh the positive side
is it will cost Wesley a bit of time a
lot of pieces left on the board and then
Armageddon that tends to help so reverse
trumpowski here anyone who plays the
trumpowski you get these crazy lines
where the Knight comes to E4 and G5 so
not exactly the same and I I kind of
like wait a little better here than
normally where black gets but a funny a
funny and weird position yeah it's
basically if you do a comparison white
just has this extra move B3 yeah and uh
it looks like it should be useful but
yeah interesting comparison there Danny
useful to try and get that Queen side
Bishop to develop on the long diagonal
also a really nice approach with no
increment on the clock it's sort of
getting Wesley into a zone that he might
not be super familiar with get him to
think early on so that the seconds run
by but Wesley so far keeping a close eye
on his clock and making moves quickly
and that's exactly what he needs to do
but this is getting quite crazy and
Harry the H1 as well Simon's celebrating
in the studio it's always a good move
right always
um it makes a lot of sense here because
uh there is a big threat now you're
threatening to just trap uh the bishop
on G6 and black only has one option
Black's got to fight that night there
he's gotta ask the question to the White
Knight what are you gonna do trying to
and now obviously when you see that B3
move coming into into good use and yeah
it's a very interesting position the
more I'm looking at this more I'm like
uh yeah I'm actually glad they they kind
of went out of Mainline Theory to get
something a little bit more funky funky
chess uh non-theoretical yeah fresh
territory for both players and for
Fighters have he has to win with the
white pieces the other Armageddon is
about to start in just a few moments
Eduardo there is I got the English in
this one against Jordan Barn forest and
once again for Eduardo terzaga with
white he has to win the game on demand
did you guys did you guys as the English
gentleman here did you tell everybody it
was time to play play the opening named
after your countrymen I I don't know I
mean but another King's Indian is going
to be on the board even though Jordan
Jordan did some good things in that
first game in this exact same line
although now we're getting a little
different we'll see nope same line same
I'm surprised that white keeps pushing
his pawn and Center actually uh I have
to say David after that game did mention
to me that uh there's a move that I'd be
scared of for eyes black just take the
pawn off keep it simple because you're
giving kind of black what he wants here
uh maybe it's the the computer's Top
Choice maybe it's the best move but just
black should be I you know Black's
getting everything he wants in this
position I'm really wondering why Jerry
Saga went for the same line I can't wait
to see the Improvement because the only
thing that justify is going for an
approach where you you know you got your
bleep kicked in in the first the first
time that you had this position if
you're just joining us Jordan won a
really great game appreciating the bleep
there is
more often than I should admit but I
bleeped myself out and now we're getting
the same line what does eturizaga have
in store that's going to be an
improvement on the first game he lost
that's a big question right because that
felt like a Jordan van for a show that
attack was run forest run and that's
exactly what he did there David are we
seeing any any deviations from game one
there's been a small move order
deviation and uh it's not sure how much
of a difference it's going to make we
will see very similar ideas of black
playing on the king side a bit later on
white trying to cause some distraction
on the queen side here we go just again
slow build up but uh yeah odd to see a
tourism surely the scars of that
previous game uh will have a
psychological impact but he looks
confident he's played quite quick up to
this point both players have burned
around one minute and we will see when
white eventually decides to break on the
queen side there we go and featured chat
coming in hot with the making sure
ichirizaga has turned off auto Queen
just in case yesterday repeat itself if
you see the position on our board here
in the studio whoa we have a different
line and a different move order
yeah and whoa means something different
here uh oh Jordan leans in he knows he
messed that up
great I'm scared for that night at the
edge of the board there's no way home
for that black knight and you mentioned
look at it to rizaga he suddenly leaned
in Jordan head in hands is Jordan in
trouble yeah suddenly tourizaga kind of
perked up he was like flexing he was
like yeah I caught you I've tricked you
and uh it feels like in the break
between the previous games and this one
he's done a bit of homework and he's set
a trap suddenly like you say Tanya it's
all about this Black Knight on A4 it's
trapped there's no way home and that
might have been brilliant yeah it might
have simply been brilliant maybe uh
either uh Eduardo or maybe someone he
knows said okay you can repeat this line
but here's a great idea just attack that
Knight quickly and come in with this
idea uh because he could have done
something very similar in in the game
that he he actually lost and the the
problem is Dave is pointing out here is
that the Black Knight is just stranded
um you know it's a very simple idea
switch to Rook take the Knight go a
piece up and wow I mean that that could
be it simply it could be the end of
Jordan we could just see a walk over in
this game almost I don't see any way to
get this night out to uh uh kind of just
extra extricate this night from A4 if
the pawn pushes forward then firstly
what can take this Pawn secondly you
could just capture here maybe and go
after the Knight anyway and okay the
evaluation bar goes down slightly but
still winning for white Jordan has to
try this and there we go he does play
the move C6 I also mentioned this Pawn
is up for grabs if he needs to uh if he
wants to play it safe and just go up
material into razaga huge success in the
opening fascinating I've been I've been
sitting here just speedily going through
the variations comparing this game in
Armageddon to the first game they had
and really a very tricky little move
order Changed by ichirizaga you're right
he did hit the prep when he played H3 in
King H2 just to throw off Jordan there
anyway we we obviously have other games
to get to we have two very exciting
games but really impressed with the
aturi's August Choice gutsy move and one
that looks like it might be about to pay
off yeah that's move number 18 and
Eduardo durizaga in driver seat has
managed to trap Jordan's Knight at the
edge of the board he's going to end up
winning material in this position we'll
come back and check in how he manages to
convert Dan Jordan saved this one let's
jump over to the other Armageddon as
action and hot action is on in this one
that's a crazy opening David yeah a
crazy opening and it almost looks like a
mirror image of the previous Gamers
another closed blocked Pawn structure in
the center here White's night on C4
looks nice and pretty but might get
kicked around as well uh we do have
white with the bishop pair but that
tends to count for Less when the center
is closed and I'm struggling to choose a
side I love this last move from FedEx
open up the position for your Bishops
and Simon's he still has a four or five
minute Advantage here yeah and that that
is massive you know if uh if one side in
Armageddon gets under like three minutes
it's time to panic because they don't
get any extra time and uh Wesley is
getting very close to to to that point
uh White's breaking out here I mean I
still think Wesley has an okay position
he's got a good hold with his Knights
his Knight now attacking the bishop is
ready to come into the Central Square so
it's seems just very finely balanced at
the moment could go either way this one
I think it's an interesting strategy
right now because you see that Federal
saves plan of playing something that
Wesley wouldn't be prepared for is
paying off on the clock but on the board
you also objectively would say that
Wesley's doing okay right it's a
fighting game and he's got plenty of
chances so the gamble is in full is in
full swing here and um I think you
called it Simon if something doesn't
happen good for Wesley in the next few
or four minutes now you're in trouble
because you're getting under that three
minute Mark it's an Armageddon this is
Casino style chess uh Danny right here
with the bishop Baron open position and
Wesley saw with five and a half minutes
on the clock I'm gonna say it this is
gonna be flagging penetrating Bishops
there going across the board aren't they
the white Bishops they're just really
stopping Black from getting the king
safe as well this is maybe an issue
right yeah could well be an issue for
the black king FedEx just uh moves his
Queen Ford he's hinting that he might
Castle on the queen side a bit dangerous
over there as well but keeping his shot
his options open and yeah Tanya you said
flagging in a blocked Pawn structure
that's the perfect scenario he's going
to take the opponent so long to break
through so long to trade everything off
uh we could get well get to that point
later but uh Wesley dealing with the
issue that Simon mentioned blocking the
light squared Bishop so that the black
king can run over to safety later on on
C8
still very tense so far Philadelphia's
gamble of fighting for the white pieces
seems to be paying off it's uh it's
paying off he's up on the clock he's
he's also doing fine on the board
um this exchange here if both Kings end
up castling long
um I think actually both they make the
players feel better with what's on the
board but maybe it makes Wesley feel
worse with with the clock because
because now he's uh he's just down on
time and there isn't a lot of fight in
this position
there's a lot of fight in this position
and we want to jump back to this but
let's get a quick look at the other
board we left it feeling thinking that
three Saga completely in driver's seat
trapping a knight on the board but David
it's still alive it's it's still alive
and it's actually just given up its life
in order to just give white some
beautiful tactics right now I think a
tourism is calculated perfectly we look
at the evaluation bar it says totally
winning white right now is a piece for
two pawns down but look at this next
move bang E5 the white light Square
Bishop has opened up and the black queen
has run but both of blacks Knights look
a bit loose or it feels like this one is
hanging by a thread maybe white can just
play a quiet move here and it feels like
so many threats black surely won't be
able to survive all of them so I mean
we're seeing the same momentum of
yesterday
the person who has to win wins with
black gets the white pieces in
Armageddon and right now is getting the
job done yeah I mean very impressive
play from white I mean especially uh I
think you mentioned this Danny that he
lost horribly with the same opening a
couple of games ago but he repeats it he
finds a nice way to change things up and
gets a dominating position and the only
thing he's got to do here is just put
the ball in the back of the net and uh
how does he do that does he grab the
Rook here is that a good idea I mean
that weakens his King a little bit it's
a bit risky going for that or or you
know just you still got to be accurate
in this position yeah I would lose this
obviously
I don't think so Simon I think you would
clean this up and I think white should
take the Rook why not yeah free material
and uh right now the material balance is
rook and two pawns for white versus two
nights but Black's problems do lie with
those Knights for example I'm wondering
how black extricates this one it looks
like it's falling off the board next if
the problem for black is you'd love to
go on an attack against the white king
you'd love to land your knight in G4 but
as soon as the black queen moves away
there's no more pin along the e-file and
suddenly this Knight drops off too and
yeah I just don't see how you can hold
this together you can push a pawn
forward maybe keep this Knight alive by
retreating but this looks hopeless just
trade off these Rooks bring the White
Queen forward this looks over
like just uh yeah never put a knight in
the corner of the board just no
coordination at all in Black's Army he
has taken oh no he hasn't taken the Rook
yet I mean David if knights in the room
are dim what are knights in the corner
what are they they're just really stupid
aren't they I mean there's that
expression nights on the rim of the
board as we see black snipe there is dim
but that night is just another night
it's not a night it's a very bad night I
mean uh very very bad night what's the
definition of this when is a knight a
pony when is it a unicorn and when is it
a dragon what is it a donkey when is it
a donkey that's a donkey that is
definitely a donkey nothing against
donkeys lovely animals but that is a
donkey of a night but they're slow and
yeah they're not the the speediest of
steeds
true edge of the board it's about to
fall off the world right there and we
see he hasn't yet taken a decision
taking his time here thinking about this
moment he probably does feel that it's
critical calculates a few lines and it's
in the bag will we see the classic fist
bump
I think we will and I think now
ichirisaga is doing what Jordan did to
him in the game we were applauding right
he's managing his clock because normally
when you have the edge on time in these
Armageddon battles you want to flex it
but if your opponent gives you a winning
position you're still playing chess
right you just want to win the game on
the board so he tirizaga taking a beat
he's going to calculate it through
um I just saw the eval bar swing wildly
and so is favor so I'm not gonna lie I'm
I'm my eye caught the fact that black is
maybe winning in the other board but uh
iterizaga looks like he should be
getting the job done here
let's take a look at that uh let's bring
up a Fantasia versus Wesley saw as we do
see a wild swing there and wow David
white is down in exchange what's going
on here I see a Pawn on G6 this is crazy
yeah this is crazy fedisev did blunder
he did uh initially let this one get out
of her hand just giving up a Pawn on the
queen side allowing The Black Queen in
but suddenly things have switched things
have turned potentially because he's
trapped that black queen and given up
some material this one the evaluation
bar the computer says black is winning
but it's a key moment now there's some
huge threats and look at this beautiful
move I was about to say maybe this is
the only winning move giving away a pawn
uh actually White Queen didn't go and
grab this Pawn
first taking some other points with
track there's a queen a queen coming to
H1 if you're not checking an H2 Pawn
that um you're a wizard Harry
yeah he found the key move he's just
trying to deflect away the White Queen
from any attacks and then the Blackford
will enter the action and I think
White's King will be doomed
and the problem is why I can't even get
a draw here
um because that's not enough white has
to win uh to go through because it's
Armageddon and that means Perpetual
checks you know they don't count you
know that's I didn't even realize that
Simon you just you called it right there
this queen D4 Queen D5 it's over at this
point the eval bar is almost irrelevant
because White's only chance to stop a
queen is to take a perpetual
and uh that's not good enough kind of
black ones you can even try for more by
going a king to B8 but instead look at
this black does want more in this
position but we see the eval bar creep
up that last move David was not a big
mistake I think it was a safe move but
not the best one it felt like there was
a win for black I didn't quite see it
but uh yeah retreating with the queen
suddenly the White Knight is coming out
to a really beautiful Square on C4 gosh
suddenly all three results possible
again
listening back in trouble especially
when you remember he has no increment
and he's under three minutes a night is
the worst piece I would want to face in
this scenario
needs a draw
to win this match uh he was close to
winning one inaccuracy and Pharisee back
in the game but still a big clock
Advantage for fedosiev and uh I did just
check Wesley was winning but it wasn't
super easy uh maybe not so natural for a
human to keep the black queen offside so
retreating the black queen was a mistake
and now the game is alive again it's
funny though because I like what Wesley
did the moment he played Rook G7 I I
wanted to applaud it because he said
look I just needed to Raw so let me just
let me just repeat moves here and make
white do something risky with E5 right
make white mess up the position and by
by making sure I don't beat myself on
the clock
both trying to beat each other on the
clock the other one looks like it's
about to finish let's see if we can get
to the finish of that game as iterizaga
he's close to taking this match will
this be one of the biggest comebacks
that we've seen yeah impressive stuff
from ituruzaga he played a move that
wasn't on my radar a beautiful move
actually just two turns ago let's jump
in and show this uh the current position
has changed slightly and it's because if
we backtrack in this position where I
was predicting Bishop takes Rook which
was strong as well he found another
nasty blow Bishop takes H6 instead
jumping out the way so that the Rooks
connect and protect each other meaning
that this Knight is attacked if the
bishop was captured for example then
Pawn takes Knight is now possible and
next move white crashes through uh at
the very least can take this Rook anyway
so Bishop takes Pawn beautiful blow
winning move and after a bishop trade I
think the same thing still winning just
uh take this rook and take it in the
corner and now this Knight will fall
over the next few times still black is
paralyzed yeah I mean I I guess black
can hold on to that Knight by pushing
his Pawn uh in that position so I mean
it's disgusting it's probably losing but
um it's maybe
maybe playable I say that and I don't
really believe what I'm saying uh but
you you can't lose that night and these
these nights are just terrible anyway uh
why is pawns too strong it should be
winning but it's still I'm I'm a bit
surprised your evaluation bar is so high
in this position
um I guess it just reflects the material
balance it's rook and four pawns if I'm
counting correctly it's a lot of points
donkeys have each other's back on the
edge of the board though right those
donkeys got to stick together when
they're they go in the uphill climb
yeah I think the only source of counter
play we should mention is that this Pawn
is hanging yeah and uh black could
launch a mating attack if white isn't
careful so uh still got to keep your eye
on the ball and wow Jordan going for
tactics Knight takes porn uh played
threatens a nasty night Fork but this is
blocked by Queen E4 a double attack and
this could be the death knell for black
yeah how do you defend the Rook the
Knight and the 994 can't
and uh now I think you can just take
this Knight if I'm not mistaken and go
into a very safe position two extra
Pawns
maybe that's better Rook takes Knight
will be met by a nasty night check but
you just take this one off the board as
well and two extra pawns for white this
should be the end psychologically that's
interesting by Jordan because do you
really want to go for this when you know
black has drawing chances and you're
also now down on the clock look at
what's happened in this Armageddon
switcharoo ski if that's a thing to say
I mean I I actually I'm applauding
Jordan for the Practical sort of
decision here because that's a
psychologically difficult thing to do to
invite a major piece ending where you
know there's drawing chances I suppose
white could take the night here couldn't
he as well and just I mean in the middle
and do the same thing as you just said
but yeah you're right I mean it's uh
it's it is two Pawns in the ending
though I mean
um so it's it should be winning for
white but I mean we're component endings
there's always some chances maybe that's
the most practical move Queen takes
Knight and there we go it's on the board
small drawings chances for black but the
problem is white has majorities on both
flanks and what's going to grind this
one out we will check back on this the
other Armageddon I think it's about to
end let's quickly jump over to our other
game Wesley so against feather save
this one it looks like it's about to end
in a draw which means Wesley will go
through and ferocia will be eliminated I
mean on it and Wesley Found A Swindle
they gave up The Rook for the night in
the pawn to get this queen and pawn
ending so first of all huge props to
Wesley for doing that knowing the odds
of the game or that a draw means he wins
um and uh I think I think with that he's
is he pre-moving he borderline can right
that's how easy the position is so
Wesley using the Practical Dynamic of
the arm record of the Armageddon format
to force a draw
the only danger is his clock right and
he's and he should have enough time here
I mean uh let's remember there's no
increment so you know fedexv has got to
not hit the 50 move Rule and win on time
um and it I think I mean of course it's
a draw even if you even if you lose a
pawn here it's probably very close to a
draw which you can't lose what happens
if the 50 move rule gets hit
automatically it'll be automatically
cleaned and I was just about to check on
the moves of that because they're
actually pretty close to it yeah they
actually don't have many more moves for
last porn capture uh was on move 72 so
we're already just a few moves away from
that 50 move rule 37 needs to move upon
or capture a piece in the next five
moves otherwise this game's
automatically a draw
well wow he's going forward with the
King but he's run out of time three more
moves and we're gonna see any result any
second now
[Laughter]
since the game ends in a draw you have
to feel for a feathers here right now it
means it is the end of the road for
Vladimir in the aim chess rapid
Fellowship taking it and he continues
his run action is still on here
I'm still on here Randy it's an Infamous
for component game we'll find out the
truth behind where the aura component
games are drawn but here it looks like
white has
big Advantage pushing that Beast Pawn
forward one more Square will paralyze
the black pieces Black's Rook now is
eternally stuck behind that pass pawn
and the black king will be stuck on this
Square pretty much can white Now
activate his King it looks like it
should be a simple process of just
attacking the black Rook forcing the
black Rook back and the white king
activates white will be able to create a
pass Pawn on the king side you have to
be careful which Pawn you push later but
it feels like this should be winning
I think a matter of time now yeah it
must be winning and of course at this
level uh you know um I I think they know
we're going to know how to convert it
into win the white king getting very
active here it's got some squares it can
jump into on the king side and it's
heading toward those squares and as
David says you just gotta you've got to
be careful what porn uh you use because
to advance as white because in some
situations you you can fall into a draw
position I mean maybe you advance
um you can maybe Advance either the H
Pawn or DF Pawn to win this one as long
as you take with the King but it's you
just have to be a little bit accurate
but we should probably show the
instructor point of why the black king
is frozen there just for people tuning
in saying why can't the black king run
over and help and I think it's an
important tactic that maybe not all of
our viewers know that if black moves
they can go ahead there's this back door
trick where the Rook slides over and now
when when you get a queen you win so
black has to take the pawn and that
allows a skewer so this is a a backdoor
Rook skewer that every every player
that's a mouse slip sorry but every
player must know this one and so that
that Dynamic is exactly why the end game
is winning for white because the black
king is frozen in the corner as as Simon
pointed out that said there there are
some tricky things here because
it's not exactly clear how to force the
king out of the corner either right
white has to advance the right pawns and
make the right exchange and and here
here we see H4 has been played yeah nice
I think what we do you go F5 and G5
right but I mean we're probably gonna
we're probably gonna see this happen and
uh It's tricky because if you didn't
know how to win this ending if you
didn't have the experience then you
could easily still draw this but these
guys are such high level that they know
exactly what to aim for and that's very
important you need to know the positions
to aim for and how to get there and uh
the clock one and a half minutes it's
borderline I would say uh you should
still have enough time but you need to
make the Breakthrough quickly you can't
just wait for 20 moves and then uh push
the pawn so already it's like a big
decision he's trapped his own King as
well you can't move the white Rook you
lose your V Pawn you can't move the king
you'll get checkmated so you have to
commit now the audience defending well
gotta say I think this is just winning
those in it the winning plan as long as
you because you're going to get a past
Pawn very shortly and that's the the key
people and actually forcing to go in the
position that Dany actually pointed out
and uh black will shortly have to move
his King away from the safe Zone I was
going to say earlier when you said if
you don't know this end game
um you're gonna find out because if
you've never seen in a game like this
converted this is really really well
done by uterizaga when that g-pawn
pushes you'll have to take it as black
and then white will sacrifice the F Pawn
forcing the exact same trick that we
showed earlier where the Rook can leave
the B8 square with Tempo so you're about
to see some instructive chests here if
you didn't know this Rook ending you can
add it to your book yeah Freddie the
f-bond that's the passer you want to
invite the back door tactic that you
pointed out earlier with the Rook moving
out of the way clearing the way for the
bee pawn and it seems like Eduardo knows
exactly what he's doing but will 70
seconds be enough to pull it off
at this point yes because I think this
breakthrough is happening next move you
can almost remove G5 don't do it just in
case black takes the white V Pawn but uh
yeah G5 is the Breakthrough and with one
minute left that pawn is going to cost
black as Rook it's just about whether
you can Checkmate later with a rook uh
in time so one minute should be fine but
yeah for very instructive as you
mentioned Tanya Freddy the f porn does
it but if you were left with just a g
Pawn with white Black's king would be
fine perched where it is so now we're
gonna see the Breakthrough G5
and Black's King will be dislodged from
G7 guaranteed over the next move or two
I'm gonna try to fly tiger I was just
gonna ask that question yeah it's not
gonna happen though is it I mean Jordan
doesn't like resigning right too early
and why not you know this is your last
chance you're going to be out of the
competition and uh it's uh it's
Armageddon it's Armageddon you know you
might as well play but he is he's well
aware that he's in a diabolical
situation here there's no way out now
and great great great technique here at
the end we call it technique and I hate
that because it's like you know you see
so many books you see so many videos and
one player just says it's just a matter
of technique when they get a winning
position and I've lost so many games
when it should just be a matter of
technique but the white king now just
has to attack the rook and it's 57
seconds yeah he has managed to create
Freddy the F Pawn as a passer it's all
about well I think Jordan will try to
flag and will it be enough time and now
you can move the Rope the back door
attack as Danny called it in the game
can't pick up the beep on you lose the
Rook will Jordan clear this out
somehow there might you know if the King
goes to G5 Rook H4 is the only way to
travel in a premium I'm serious if he
plays Rook H4 here okay no
I'm waiting for a chance for him to take
advantage of the only move is the is The
pre-move Rook H7
no no I'm trying to get inside Jordan's
head here if if the white king had gone
to F4 black could play where it takes B7
and uh that would have been a draw
one trap oh that's a nice yeah nice
trick David but uh the white King has
gone the whole way around like we'll
lose this rook and turizaga he actually
resigns he's got it already over you're
in one oh sorry wow Jordan
forgotten and look at the relief on him
what a match this has been he's getting
ready right now and we hope he joins us
soon what a match what a comeback by
teresaga we saw it twice right we saw a
player yesterday win with black on
command and then win with white in the
Armageddon this time we saw ichirizaga
win with black and then win with white
on command just absolutely awesome but
no one's done the crazy celebration as
we saw in the in his road to this event
so I did it last time feels like I
shouldn't be doing it again
oh God
that's what the kind of thing we're
thinking too soon because there's still
a lot of jazz to be played by teresaga
but he gets the job done today it was a
topsy-turvy match David take us through
the big moment yeah I just want to recap
that beautiful end game technique from
iterazaga some great tactics earlier on
to get the winning Advantage but the way
he finished it off was textbook and
there was just one trap we mentioned it
here white is checked if you go to the
wrong Square then actually suddenly
black is able to draw Rook takes Pawn
watch out for stalemate resources this
check no longer works because after Rook
takes Rook this is stalemate and a dead
draw instead of course iterusalgo with
great technique marched his King over
towards the black rook and eventually we
saw Jordan resign Rook takes Pawn is met
by a skewer on the seventh Rank and
that's why we need to know our end game
skills
what a win that was precision and a full
board awareness thereby teresaga Jordan
van first did not try and flag him there
sportsmanship and let's take a look at
the bracket as we will be starting with
the winner semi-finals match up in the
losers bracket it is Wesley so and
Eduardo iterizaga who moved forward to
the losers quarterfinals it's end of the
road for feather save and Jordan van
Forest it's been a tough week for Jordan
with the duck Championship losing in the
final in the playoff to Anish yesterday
a tough day against Magnus and today it
was so close but it didn't work out yeah
I know I think I said yesterday it's a
bit of out of The Frying Pan Into the
Fire for Jordan right after losing to a
niche in the Dutch championship and then
getting paired with the world champion
most people go to the losers bracket
when they're paired with Magnus Carlson
and Jordan of course was one of them and
uh so obviously we know Jordan's a great
player he's an exciting player we love
watching him but yeah a tough week right
now for the Dutchman
meanwhile the others of course continue
their run in the aim chess drafted and
Wesley so winning in Armageddon also a
great result in exactly the confidence
boost he needed yeah confidence boost
for Wesley just the fact that he was
able to stay solid and make good
decisions at Key moments but he will
still need to up his game and uh this is
the first step for him
Psy which was the more exciting
Armageddon for you
know they're both great weren't they um
I mean
it's hard to pick I can't really pick I
mean I just love Armageddon because you
never know what's gonna happen and uh
the time's ticking down they've both got
to a minute there I actually liked that
ending I don't normally say that I don't
normally get to the ending so I normally
either sacrifice all my pieces or or
checkmates so it's nice to see an ending
for a change I'll give you the car you
you said you thought a tourizaga was
going to get this one because of the
format for whatever reason and I was
with I was with David I thought that
Jordan would be the favorite but good
call on that eterizaga stuck it out you
did he did really well yeah I mean his
nerves were fantastic and just the way
uh that he did that preparation I think
that was the key thing because he lost
that game and then he found an
improvement as a little little lesson
for everyone there that you know we all
we all lose but we've got to find a way
to improve if we get the same thing
again so uh and it and it worked very
well so yeah perfect got him in the
opening perfect for your bio three zaga
he lost the first
Jordan run for us and then one here's a
second game and then finally taking it
in the Armageddon and we have been
joined by the man himself Eduardo
welcome and congratulations
thanks hi guys how are you we're doing
good how are you doing after this crazy
match that you just played
yesterday was a very tough match against
Favi but then I I try to to forget
everything about yesterday
about the the auto Queen and
some
mistake in the preparation in the second
game with white and then I have to play
and I start today with a with losing
this game with white I don't know but I
think I was playing better with black
than with white
was a very good game I think he missed
Knight B5 and and then everything comes
not easy but they have to calculate
sunlight but it was comfortable I think
you watch Eduardo and we were talking
about that
Improvement is that something that you
prepared between the rounds
yeah yeah I have just five minutes I
checked this H3 uh and yes just to after
before it have the E3 Square for the
bishop
because if not he has an id4 but yeah I
look just one two minutes then my
daughter come the puppy puppy Daddy
Daddy and I have to
to hit chin yeah and then I come back to
the game
that's awesome and you made a big
comeback in the match as well
how are you enjoying your W your first
time in division one of the aim chess
rapid
it's an amazing
um
I was so really nervous now but uh about
the game but it was an amazing
experience for me I
in I played three play-ins and then in
the first two I have some chances to get
at least a match to
to play for the division one but then I
lost always the last round and then I
have to play for the division two and I
always lost this match and I played the
division three but in the last one I
have this match again in parkhan was
amazing
for me and and then I I'm here and I
wanna do well here and I think with this
match uh at least I'm
trying to
to do some some things in division one
uh match against Parham that went down
to the wire and your emotions were out
and it was just such a cool moment to
watch as well and you were waiting for
the fist bump today as well as you made
this big comeback
yeah but the I think the the celebration
against Farhan was is very special and
of course began naturally but because I
won't live with
0.009 seconds it was
uh
but it tense game with sacrifice the
rook and I don't know
I don't I I was thinking in the game I
after most 60 I will have some increment
I don't know why I think this because
these are my head on and then
and there is no rule for for this but I
was thinking because I was playing
another tournament with this Rule and I
was playing slowly in the last uh 20
moves and then I realized I have no
increment and I have to play fast fast
the last five seconds and I think I I
won this game because I I give him two
checks and the checks in with Prem
office
the the trick I think to to have more
seconds than than but it's very was a
very special for me
this tournaments and I wanna thanks of
course all of you for this opportunity
for all of us to have the chance to play
against the super elite players and it
was amazing not only for me I think for
every people in in the tournament
that's really nice to hear and Eduardo
you're putting up such a great fight in
the show here and before we let you go
my final question I think everyone in
chat wants to know have you changed your
auto promotion on chess.com today
yes because yesterday with eight seconds
left in the clock I tried to change but
I don't find and and then I look in
Twitter Danny put it with Alt with Alta
and then promo I can get the the Knight
but okay this is a
alert for me yesterday
uh congratulations for your weekly today
Eduardo and we look forward to having
you back with us tomorrow
thanks thanks guys
with a convincing win in the Armageddon
continues his run at the am chest rapid
it is elimination for fedociev and
Jordan man Forest we've still got big
action coming up as we will be starting
the winner semi-final with some big big
matchups don't go anywhere we'll be back
in just a few
[Music]
the most elite bullet tournament returns
you don't want to miss the fourth ever
bullet Chess Championship featuring
Magnus Carlson for the first time he'll
join reigning champ Hikaru Nakamura 2021
champion alireza ferrugia and more to
fight for their share of the 100 000
prize fund it all kicks off on July 17th
at 9am Pacific
use exclamation point BCC in chat for
all the details
don't miss your chance to win Diamond
membership this Friday
the chess.com Discord server is hosting
an arena with four Diamond memberships
up for grabs
the stake your claim join the Discord at
go.chess.com forward slash Discord and
connect your Discord to your chess.com
account
use exclamation point Discord in chat
now for more
and it's time for the winner semi-finals
two epic matchups a clash of generations
between not the back up to such Rob and
levonaronian and the big one that we've
all been waiting to see Fabiano caruana
taking on Magnus Carlson this is their
head to head score in Rapid with 10 wins
to Fabi 18 wins to Magnus he leads there
but the last time that they played David
it was Fabi who won against Magnus yeah
and those types of things are important
these Trends in head-to-heads Magnus of
course overall he's got the best head to
head against most players in the world
but Fabi he's been upping his game and
like we've been saying uh consistently
now on the tour he's been mightily
impressive
it's always hard to bet against Magnus
whenever he's playing
Head to Head between nodded back up to
such trouble and love on our onion they
haven't played each other as many times
but we see it is Lavon experience here
right now leading against the youth is
this one equally close to call
yeah I think so definitely I mean uh
naughty Beck is just getting better
every single time he plays I mean he won
the last last one of these events so uh
he's he's the youth against the
experienced player so uh yeah too close
to call for me yeah I think Lavon though
if he plays like he did yesterday uh he
he'll he'll be okay although sometimes
you know when you get yourself in
trouble and then it takes Army getting
to win you end up really carrying that
momentum so we'll see how noderbeck is
ultimately we'll get to that in a minute
because the first of our uh of our
winners bracket battles look at this
playing fast
playing on prep no more A6 from Magnus
Carlson yeah we didn't he couldn't get
away with it against this guy but we get
such a cool opening
and more importantly none of the rosly
more that we saw in the world
championship match with between these
two inner Sicilian for a moment there I
thought Fabi was extremely still on the
camera but good to know that
everything's fine the camera is working
and the G4 on the board David yeah
school as they say uh very aggressive
play from Fabiano throwing all pawns
forward now on the king side just
preempting a decision by the black king
now Black's King should not ever get
attempted to Castle kingside because
it's going to be walking straight into
an attack and Magnus still as black has
to decide how to develop his pieces this
is super exciting speaking of
developments Magnus Carlson has added
the Sicilian as a regular part of its
repertoire really since the 2018 World
Championship that he had against against
Fabiano caruana but we didn't
necessarily see this time on off Paulson
system we saw a lot of svenikov for
those who don't who haven't gotten this
memo Fabiano core one is probably the
world's most feared player on the white
side of these English attacking types of
systems he's so well prepared he he you
know MBL avoids the night or against
Fabiano that should tell you right and
MBL doesn't avoid the night over against
anybody so this is gonna be awesome to
see Magnus played H6 which was the first
move to kind of threw Fabi off before he
remembered his prep and uh if this ends
up being a battle that we also see in
game three I just can't wait to see the
prepare operation and the things we're
going to learn I'm like a kid in a candy
store here because I played this
position as white so I can't wait to see
what happens so many opening Dynamics
yeah it was hicaro who said that Fabiano
is one of the best if not the best
prepared player in the world now
apparently that Crown belongs to Anish
Guri according to Hikaru but the opening
battle continues in this one we are also
going to have opening moves in our other
matchup not a backup to satrobe taking
on love on aronia in the players are
ready to start live in San Sebastian in
the room with all the chess books and
the chessboards behind it moves on the
board it's the king spawn opening so
transport opening and wow we'll see what
we call the Four Knights here no Spanish
no Italian game yet we might see a big
decision now from Abdu sator of what's
he going to go for levon's of course
known as one of the world's leading
experts on the black side of these E5
positions Rock Solid and okay crazy
stuff already Knight takes E4 this is a
temporary peace sacrifice based on the
fact that if the white knight had
captured this Black Knight black would
have played D5 four king two minor
pieces uh regaining the material and
after the store of just castles
love it love it
you know I I love a sacrifice and um you
you it's so rare to see see this kind of
Chess at this level because most things
have been worked out I mean at lower
level you can sacrifice a lot more in
the opening uh because uh your opponent
is less likely to know what to do
um so it's quite rare and of course
white gets great compensation here
because of the development he's castled
black hasn't castled whites got more
pieces out so this is also going to be
uh I mean I I'm assuming I don't know
his position but Theory would obviously
say that black is okay here so I'm also
very interested to see what uh White's
got up his sleeve here this is the
classic center fork truck I mean Knight
takes E4 followed by D5 for black this
is something you teach kids when you're
first you're first trying to show them
tactics that can happen in double King
pong games so um obviously you know the
theory for these guys goes deeper than
uh than following for basic Center trick
says David is showing on the board but I
like black as well Simon I agree and I I
wonder it's funny because notary pausing
before Bishop C4 makes me wonder if he's
double checked double checking double
guessing himself we know that he used to
play the scotch before switching to the
Italian so
um maybe getting his lines mixed up a
little bit again this is a fine white
can play this way it's more of a long
form compensation now you're
highlighting one of the potential tricks
on the board Checkmate on F7 but it's
also a good opening for black yeah and
actually uh I think Eric Rosen will be
happy here because it's basically the
Stafford Gambit but what has an extra
Tempo white has uh castled King side
which is playable maybe is playable
actually often the idea there is to push
your H4 forward and attack on the wings
but uh it's interesting white has
gambited the pawn but has great Central
play uh along the e-file along this
diagonal and if we look at nordebec's
time this is the first real time he's
thinking after the move H6 just been
played uh so it does feel like
preparation it feels like he's just uh
wow going for checkmate mate in one
threaten now on F7 yeah he's gambiting
he's Safford Gambit lives okay I'm
sitting here thinking like what's going
on here but now I'm like okay obviously
the kid came prepared for this and I
think from a practical perspective if
you're getting a sharp well-prepared
game of it that's how you rack up W's
right especially in Rapid shots yeah
maybe against weaker opposition than
level neuronian though who looks like
he's defending three
confidently right now I'm expecting him
to play the move D6 and protect his
extra Pawn on E5 this one uh really
tense already and I just want to mention
a bit of symmetry because we've seen a
sacrifice of the E4 Pawn in this game
and in the carowana against Carlson game
both sides white has sacrificed upon and
going on the attack early doors such
exciting game so far really exciting
100 and we do have material deficit
already out of the opening David you
mentioned it there has been a pawn
sacrifice in the Fabi Magnus game as
well let's head over to that one and see
as the opening develops Fabiano caruana
against Magnus Carlson a wild position
out of the opening why it's going on the
king side Black's King is in the center
what on Earth is going on here yeah
white has gampty the pawn just like the
other game in return for Tempe that
means you gain one or two sometimes
three moves even for the sacrifice
material and here white as we see nice
safe King on C1 and uh White's piece is
looking very active it looks like you've
got some Pawn breaks as well if I recall
correctly though Magnus had this
position just last uh just a few days
ago in Zagreb which makes me wonder what
is Fabiano I was gonna say it's funny
because Fabiano is the one who's super
well prepared and these systems is white
but Magnus is the one up two minutes on
the clock and as you put it out yeah he
had this position in Zagreb just a few
days ago so uh fabi's Fabi is sort of
balls in your court right to show what
you prepared you have to know that
Magnus is going for these lines these
days
a very interesting option here as well I
mean uh I I love these positions because
they're so rich full of possibilities
and you know um you know just reminds me
of the games are my favorite player
Michael Tau and uh you know white might
be thinking here I can attack that
Knight but maybe the Knight can jump all
the way into C3 if that happens you know
there's just just these uh possibilities
that are just so uh so crazy and so in
depth here that we could see
um I mean uh it's it's could well just
really come to life it's already a life
and the other thing is like you know
Magnus historically didn't really play
like this right he's only started to
play like this when he's
maybe not you know holding on to that
world championship title as much he's
playing a lot Freer he always used to
play quite safe not taking too many
risks but this is a incredibly risky way
to play right this this kind of setup
interesting would you say because do you
think that's also
also weird to really fight against a
player like Magnus Carlsen you want to
get him into that Mikhail doll Deep Dark
Forest of complications early on where
the path is narrow enough for just one
player to get out is that the kind of
position that you should be aiming for
against Magnus I would have definitely
said yes but then when I've seen Magnus
get into those positions he just crushes
his opponents as well so I'm not really
sure how you beat Magnus but I think if
uh you know I think it is one of the
better ways to try especially your
Fabiana you've got to complicate it
you've got to go there on the attack
you've got to try to make things messy
because he's just so hard to beat in
solid structures it's nearly impossible
and I would argue that I don't know that
Magnus has switched to some of the
sharpest some of the sharpest lines
known to theory in these Sicilians
really has anything to do with him
giving up the world championship title
at all I think he should be applauded
for almost kind of Reinventing his
approach to the opening and I remember
talking to Fabi about this in 2021 and
the comments we made similar comments
about how Magnus plays openings that
aren't that well prepared or kind of
safe and he's like you know I think
people underestimate just how well
prepared you have to be to avoid
everyone's preparation and Magnus not
necessarily being known as a deep
opening theoretician amongst the top
players they all kind of call BS to that
they're like Magnus is actually the
hardest worker most ruthless opening
preparer and it's because he believes in
his skills that he tends to avoid some
of the sharpest prep but I really as I
looked at what Magnus has done with the
black pieces over the last few years I'm
just super impressed David because he
started to embrace some of the sharpest
lines known to man and know them really
well and get points with black as he did
against Fabi where Fabi didn't see this
version of cop coming in 2018 so I don't
know that I'm not trying to say I
disagree but I disagree with you I don't
think there's anything to do with the
world championship I think Magnus just
has really reinvented his approach in
the first stage of things in the last
few years of his career yeah yeah I mean
it feels like he knows everything that
everyone else knows and he knows how to
avoid that and uh some fresh ideas uh to
boot and Tanya you mentioned taking him
into a deep dark Forest I mean Jordan
tried that yesterday he took him into a
deep dark van for us but it didn't work
so LOL yeah right now this one is a
complicated position and Danny you're
right these days he kind of relies on
opening preparation more computers more
and he has a great team around him of
course Magnus he said recently in a
training camp that uh now more than ever
has he relied on these sharp variations
because that's the only way to do it at
the top level and uh meanwhile he's
still pulling up he hasn't been
checkmated yet Black's King is still in
the center but it's up to Fabi to prove
the compensation yeah I mean I I think
it's a great thing that he's done in
general I mean if you look at a lot of
players I mean I've just taken players
who play a lot of Chess on the British
circuit who may be getting a bit older
and they just play the same chess all
the time and they're never trying to
take any risks and they're never getting
better and I think the first thing you
can do if you're stuck in a rut is to
change the style try something different
so if you're a very aggressive player
play some endings if you're playing the
same openings for years on end just try
something else and uh this is this is
great to see Magnus always trying to
improve himself actually you know he's
trying to get better he's trying to try
different things out and uh he he's
obviously very good at all all positions
that's that's wise the best player ever
can we say that anyone agree with that
I'm gonna say it best player ever you'll
get a lot of disagreements I mean yeah
the goat debate across all genres you
know is there for a reason but uh yeah
anyway Magnus is up on a clock for up on
the clock for a reason he's prepared
where's he gonna put the Knight is uh
is the question yeah and big question uh
you don't have too much choice if you
jump to the center uh on D5 you'll
simply get captured and I think white
will regain the pawn with interest white
will be very happy there and so that
rules out the central jump which is
maybe the ideal one uh jumping to the
edge of the board feels like you'll get
pinned maybe it's not the end of the
world you can defend your knight here
uh it's quite stable for now but uh
knowing Magnus I've seen him in similar
positions drop his Knight back and uh
try to bring it round to a nice outpost
on F5 a bit later on it looks like
you're taking Liberties you're
undeveloping your pieces but actually
this Black Brook is pretty much
developed anyway on an open file this
bishop can come out later and if white
doesn't strike now then you will bring
your knight to a better Outpost later he
just makes just look easy like this oh
it's not that hard if you didn't know
Magnus was playing this
and you just saw this random position
what would we guess the ELO here guess
the ELO let's play guess the ELO with
Levy Rosman I have no idea I have no
idea but not not 28
50 bleep whatever he is not one number
one and one number three right black
sort of setting up for the next game all
the pieces retreating but you Retreat to
move forward this one's fire on the
board but the other one is also heating
up let's get a quick look into not the
back of the satro taking on love on our
onion David take it away I can't make
the head or tails of this position wow
just uh wow is my only reaction here I'm
trying to do a quick count white has
sacrificed a bishop a whole piece here
and it's going on the attack Black's
King's still stranded in the center
Abdus look at the clock times he's only
used just over a minute here still deep
in preparation almost double levon's
time on the clock and I think we need to
do an action replay to show how this
piece was sacrificed and wow maybe
you've landed from Level running we see
the evaluation bar shoot up after this
last move I'm not sure what level's got
in mind because it looks like white has
a very strong and simple reply uh so
let's jump in I expected to pause
because it feels like he might be
finally out of his preparation after
this last move but that also means Levon
hasn't played the top computer choice
and uh let's do a rewind we left it here
in this position it looks like black is
just about to Castle to safety but I'm
just a tour of through a spanner in the
works by playing Knight to D4 this
Knight cannot be captured by a pawn due
to a pin on the e-file the Black Knight
retreated but now bang F4 blowing open
the center allowing a fork a double
attack looks again like a guess the ELO
beginner blunder but uh this was all the
calculated risk Pawn takes pawn and
after the queen retreats E6 move of the
day so far giving up the White Queen wow
Pawn takes Queen oh I might hurt that in
your pipe and smoke it is a disposition
what is this position this is the Irish
pawns on Whiskey this is the really
drunk version
but they're not all the same color over
there you've got a white Pawn on D7
where it doesn't belong checkmating the
black king absolutely amazing and the
other thing is we took the other way you
checked me the other way David right so
it's incredible he takes the other way
uh I'm not sure about the chapter oh
sorry
but I think you just take this one yeah
you win the black queen uh so we let's
just catch up with the game we saw
Knight takes porn but this was all part
of the plan sacrificing a bishop now on
C6 spectacular stuff and uh after a few
more moves we saw the black queen was
out to attack this Rook on H1 a nasty
counter threat that this was dealt with
rookie four and Levon he blundered with
Bishop E7 and he's about to get punished
after The Rook slides across to F1 now
attacking black queen we see a few more
moves Knight takes Bishop the black king
is still stuck in the center piece down
but you're about to crash through on D6
amazing preparation this is I was just
going to say all according to playing as
the comment David made a few moves ago
and amazing preparation this is this is
so impressive this is showing up with a
Gambit
walking right into uh the the Stafford
Gambit on drugs shout out to Eric Rosen
there
um but the good kind of whatever
whatever helpful pill you're taking and
just like that Notre back is uh
on a roll
beautiful stuff yeah and incredible I
mean like uh this is this is the way to
do things nowadays you know I mean
I totally agree it's we might just have
resignation right now I've never seen
this crushed like that oh my God we have
a result Levon Blanca Rook resigns on
the spot but the position was already
busted not about taking a lead in just
21 moves in his game
Masterpiece uh demolition job I just
want to let I'm sitting here Frozen I
want to let you finish your thoughts
Simon because we've been cutting you off
and the game ended so abruptly but yeah
this is insane no I mean I I just uh
brilliant preparation I mean I I was
about to say I think this is the way
that you should do things nowadays I
mean don't play main lines try to find
some Sidelines that people forget you
know this is I mean I don't know when
the last time this Gambit was played run
them on your computer do your own
research okay if your opponent plays
perfectly maybe it's a draw okay but
that's fine you know you can trick them
out if they don't play perfectly you can
have these brilliances and uh when was
the last time aronian got I I never say
this aronian absolutely destroyed he got
completely smashed in that game and
never seen it before yeah so I don't
remember it and Lavon feeling it he
hasn't moved he's checking what went
wrong there he hasn't left his computer
screen I think he's in as much disbelief
as all of us in the studio right now 21
moves that's a miniature the last time I
checked under 25 moves I think was the
official whatever
Guinness I'm getting called out by my
world record attempts these days so
we'll get it we'll get someone to check
on that whether 25 moves is still a
miniature but uh that was awesome Notre
back Abdul Saturn for the win he is the
world rapid Champion we need to stop
talking about this kid like he's a
rising star he's he's currently the last
person to win a championship Tour event
he might be on the way to uh to doing
the same thing here
now it's reminiscent of Magnus
calculated risks this opening for sure
is not sound objectively black has
probably multiple ways to get to a
playable position but you're testing
your opponent and it's rapid chests and
that's the way to rack up those wins
just uh push your opponent to the brink
give them problems that they don't
normally have to face and uh yeah wow
more action ahead
what a great start to the to this this
is going to be the matchup of the day
sorry Simon go ahead no no I mean
they're brilliant both games are so so
fascinating I mean uh well you know that
last one but look at this what's
happening here this is this is
completely Bonkers as well right
completely mad just a weird position
white is down a whole pawn and still has
the luxury to slow play it fabiana's
last move he did Grimace slightly there
but uh just pushing his Pawn to B3 maybe
creating an Escape Route for the white
Bishop to retreat from the center of the
board and yeah black needs to catch up
on development we should probably show
why Rook takes F4 maybe isn't as good as
it first looks um just because
there is a battery on the C file and C2
is hanging with checks so when you kind
of laugh in the face of danger we should
show what's going on with Rook takes F4
deflecting the queen queen takes C2
check but it's one of those funny
Sicilian positions where you gotta
calculate to the end because just
because you get a scary check may not
actually mean you have anything left in
the tank and this is reminiscent of a
lot of night or type positions why does
it actually happen here of the exchange
so anyway so that's why Magnus didn't go
for that
[Music]
um
you just played 97 yeah uh nice to take
that Danny and that's going to be on the
radar for the next few moves right uh
that type of tactic might not work now
but it might work a bit later on you've
got to watch out and I think that's why
Fabi as well pushed his Pawn forward
because there might be some background
checkmates against the white king uh if
you're not too careful uh so now first
of all you have to deal with this Black
Knight coming out we see the evaluation
bus slightly on black side means there's
nothing immediate for white and if you
don't have a breakthrough you might just
find yourself a pawn down later on feels
like a very successful opening for black
I've got to say at least at this early
stage
on a superficial level looks like a
clear point to the good yeah
it it does now yeah I mean I I don't
think white has managed to generate
enough threats in the position I mean
how does white even generate a fret in
this position and if black can get his
Knight and Bishop into the game okay his
King's always going to be in the middle
but it doesn't seem to be in too much
trouble there Black's got enough counter
play against White's King as well so
this is uh this is starting a field to
go in magnus's favor how many cheers
does it take for a former world champion
to win as Black versus Fabiano caruana
that was a mouthful but he's got a lot
of you added another chair since
yesterday
he's got another car
he's got three four if you include the
one he's sitting on it's just dominating
with those chairs I mean someone buy
Fabby some chairs just put them in the
background you know stack them up I mean
his chair game is very strong and his
leg game was strong yesterday as well so
he's uh he's got the game and David
we've seen you on one of those chairs
and Magnus is streaming you were often
in that room what's that like what's it
like to stream with Magnus yeah they
call me the patter in the background and
uh yeah it's fun often I'm just
observing admiring the play but uh yeah
magnusi likes the support whether the
chairs are empty whether they're full I
think it really motivates him and uh
these days he's obsessed with playing
online plays nearly every title Tuesday
event plays all these Champions chest
door events uh that's kind of his happy
place right now where we see him and
it's really showing on the board must be
fun to be in a room where you're
a weaker chess player okay
I'm in those rooms a lot so how does
that feel I think that's why I moved to
Norway I was getting too big for my
boots in the UK keeps me grounded here
surrounded by genius like uh like Magnus
yeah
five he's just put his pieces on good
squares that black knight is immovable
almost that black Rook on H4 gives
really annoying pressure and Black's
other pieces look like they're covering
some key squares Fabi needs another
night he needs a light squared Bishop
but he lacks those pieces to create an
attack with does one of those chairs
actually have your name on David does is
it the howl chair oh you know right it
should tell when I get a close-up of
those chairs maybe I'll add another
chair I'll add in a fifth or sixth chair
yeah
I wanted to analyze a little bit of
Chess here if that's okay I wanted I
wanted to look at whether
whether fobby what is the plan here for
white right it's it's not black is
better and Magnus has certainly won the
battle to this point but I wonder if
there's a way to go for 95. if you could
land the Knight on E5 right now
obviously that would be a good thing
forking the queen in the D7 Pawn so how
is Knight D3 met is what I was wondering
and if you if you play D6
yeah this is this is kind of what I was
hoping for the B4 Pawn would fall so you
can't meet E5 with that
sorry you can't defendify with that so I
was sitting here like what exactly is
magnus's move here I don't think he's
taking a free with the queen because
again I think 95 would be two would be
too much although it's funny the
computer says maybe that so I was
analyzing this in my head and couldn't
figure out maybe it is Queen takes F3
and black maintains The Edge laughing in
the face of danger what a weird move but
anyway I expect fobby to play Knight D3
and if you if you can't play Queen takes
up three
maybe this isn't so easy so but as we
just saw maybe maybe Magnus can take on
a three taking on F3 looks so scary I
mean only Mad Men or genius has taken F3
here but uh yeah if you survive
unfortunately white just can't get the
Knight out of the way quickly enough
yeah Magnus might be both
that's true and your call on the board
Danny Knight to D3 I think the only safe
way to uh kind of stop 95 might be to
play Bishop to D6
to kind of trade off at night if it ever
lands on the Square and this was going
to be my last idea was to say If you
defend this way now is Rook H1 possible
because even though F3 is hanging with
the bishop developed I'm threatening
things like Rook h8 at the end of these
lines so
I know I'm the international master in
the room my job here isn't to analyze
chess but my brain feels so free with
you controlling the mouse that I think
that this is maybe what we're gonna see
I think Knight D3 is the strongest move
it was played by Fabi and now Magnus is
gonna is gonna use his time to make sure
he takes the right approach because
this this is the the big moment to keep
his advantage or not
it's true it feels like a key moment if
Magnus plays the right way we think
maybe take you on F3 then he keeps the
advantage but it will take notes of
steal and okay he Dodges any
complications he plays Bishop to D6 and
I think Danny your move might well just
appear on the board you need to get rid
of this active Rook if you want to break
through
um black stuff we want to show the full
line we got the analysis I was looking
at Rook H1 takes takes Queen takes F3
shake and bake on h8 and after Bishop f8
I have Queen takes B4 this was my uh
utilizer it doesn't work thank you oh
Queen D1 I forgot C2 is hanging at the
end yeah counter attack Okay so
so maybe in this position at least
you've created this pin maybe you can uh
go for the Slow Burn attack I don't
quite see it yet
how to break through what a weird
position weird weird stuff evaluation
Bar says it's roughly level here yeah
that's frustrating AF as fobby as the
kids say that's frustrating AF
I'm pretty sure that's what AF stands
for I've been using it a lot around the
house these days I hope that's okay
yeah especially what it stands for
sounds good to me 5
yeah Hobbies maybe you just jump into
the center attack the queen again I'm
gonna go back to B7 complicated stuff
and here at least you haven't
maybe tricks Danny with projects yes yes
I only saw it when the evaluation button
came up okay and again it's so easy
looking at these positions with the
evaluation bar but it's not easy but it
it makes it you get an indication when a
move goes wrong but imagine you're
sitting there trying to calculate these
out you don't know if the moves good or
bad are set by calculator it brings in a
whole different dimension and uh you
know this is it's an incredible position
I think we're seeing the father maybe
should have gone for that whole line we
were just showing and I know that we
don't dive into that deep or complicated
of analysis that often but I think in
this case it's appropriate because we're
sort of setting the table here for just
how important that position was and how
deep maybe kefabi needed to calculate in
order to keep the pressure he doesn't go
for Rook H1 he settles on 95 and now
this position looks easy for black
because where's the threat I'm up a pawn
I've got a dominant Knight on F5 you've
got a dark squared Bishop that can't
touch it so I think that that position
was the critical one and I think Magnus
is going to get the first game yeah you
can grab a second Pawn if he wants to be
greedy here we talked about Queen takes
F3 earlier it looks like a decent moment
to do that and uh yeah we often see
these top games these top players
they're all so good they're often uh
games like this are decided on just uh
just one or two moves critical moments
here and then I think you're right Danny
that might have been the one
where it slipped away from Fabiana and
One That Got Away you know
yeah the knight's just too strong here
right and uh Black's already material up
and I think black's Frets are probably
as strong as white threats as well so uh
I I I think Fabi has missed his chance
doesn't need to complicate uh the
position just shows you how good Magnus
is though right as well because uh you
know he's playing this fearsome attacker
in these positions and he just
calculates all his way through playing
the perfect moves you know he's he's
good only that guy not bad not many
people go on that Sicilian he's under
four minutes right now though and it
feels like he's been making one accurate
move after another but it's still
complicated magnus's King is still in
the center the players have no idea
about the eval bar they don't know who's
winning who's better who's not and yes
Sabi in the back seat right now but it's
far from over and given the clock
situation we can expect down around here
yeah I totally I think that time
scrambles happen to uh to the best of
them even the world's best but uh
I guess I'm I'm having a hard time
seeing threats for white that's my
problem you know what really kills me is
that night on F5 that 995 is guarding
and controlling everything it is a pain
and you know what
um so what what would you call the night
though is it a it's not quite a unicorn
I don't know because they don't exist
they don't exist although you just
quoted a dragon so now you're the pot
calling the kettle black here
um with uh it could be a dragon knight
okay but our Dragon Bishop but let's get
a vote and chat which is more real a
dragon or a unicorn I mean let's chat
this one I think the best I've seen both
of my student days
haven't you ever haven't you seen that
there's an antelope there's like an
antelope that has a horn on it like in
that there's like a daddy I'm sure I've
seen that before yeah there's like a
real animal with that looks like a
unicorn I think that's David says it
this is Misty this is a stallion on the
board right now that night on F5 not
only a great defensive piece but also an
attacking piece controlling so many
squares and Sonic trying to create
threats here it's exactly what he's
doing touching the one minute Mark any
chances so far be here
it's tough to say uh there's going to be
chances for Fabi look at what Magnus has
done so cool Karma collected here just
putting his King on D7 we saw him do it
actually against Jordan yesterday and uh
here it looks like the king is just well
guarded by this wall of Pawns in front
of it and those pawns supported by that
black knight yeah we have this Ryan
Knights on F5 with right this Black
Knight is uh just controlling everything
and I think Tony was right to call out
that okay both sides are getting under
time pressure it's not over like
magnus's team in the center but I agree
the reason why it's hard is because it's
one of those positions that's even worse
than the math says it is because white
has no threats here The Rook on bh4
guards B4 the queen is guarding
everything I'm like what is Fabi gonna
do now he's under I guess he's he's
under a minute
so uh
hmm I'm having a hard time seeing it I'm
just I'm just so impressed with Magnus
diving into Where Angels Fear To Tread
right the white side of the Sicilian is
where Fabiano caruana usually gets a lot
of wins Magnus is like I got you here we
go into the prep he hasn't got any
squares to move his pieces I mean like
try to find a square where white can
move a piece to without exchanging
something off uh there's not really any
squares you know I mean his pieces are
huddling in Middle uh you don't want to
exchange pieces off with your white hair
because any ending is just even easier
for Magnus to win and your Bishop is
useless it's just uh fighting against a
brick wall and that diagonal
um so it just seems like there's there's
not really anything white can do I mean
that that is a a major problem here I
mean he can't create Frets I mean the
only thing he might try is you know his
move is one square to the right but
that's just a mini mini idea that's not
going to work back can get the Queens
off at some point it looks pretty
hopeless to me yeah you know I'm I mean
I just can't see anything white can do
the one thing that Wade has going for
him is that the Queens are still on the
board
yeah the Queens come off you know you
can resign so as long as as long as
there's pressure on the D file and
there's a king in the center there's
chances Magnus could make a blunder
right because he is human
yeah um the one thing I would do here I
mean Magnus he'll find us more
sophisticated uh move for sure but the
one thing I would do is just defend
everything just put a rook on C6 and say
you shall not pass and just cover all of
these pawns and uh I don't see anything
ever going wrong there but he finds a uh
maybe even stronger move trying to force
those Rooks off the board Simon you said
any trades help and that seems to be the
case and unfortunately it's hard to keep
this Rook on the board because if you
slide it across attack that black queen
the other move you mentioned now a queen
trade is guaranteed and that will end
the game two extra points for black yeah
okay he plays Rook H2 at least the White
Queen has more squares to flee to if you
try to trade off now that's desperation
his only chance is to keep keep their
pieces on the board and I hope the
Magnus does something wrong uh but it's
it's quite rare and Magnus starts saying
wrong
um and you know uh as you know Magnus
can even try exchanging Queens here I
like your move David just moving The
Rook up two squares that's a class move
that's the kind of move I probably
wouldn't play because I just don't have
that class I'm kind of looking at
forcing the issue but just if your
opponent can't do anything as well as
white can't white can't really do
anything then just uh improve everything
as much as you can defend things before
you before you go into overdrive and
finishing the game off so uh but yeah
there's many options here time though
yeah okay let's take in but yeah they're
both about to be under a minute so let's
uh let's hold the phone yeah for a
minute yeah we have seen Magnus over the
last 12 months occasionally
uncharacteristically make one with
blunders and of course their mouth slips
there's other ways that Fabio can get
back into this game and okay D5 looks
fine planting a Pawn on a very safe
Square still lacking ideas here for Fabi
to break through that White Queen it
just needs to land somewhere on the
queen side somewhere Behind Enemy Lines
to give black a check but still how to
break through that I think D5 has a
concrete thread he wants to play 93 and
Bobby didn't stop it because the Knight
was guarding D6 and so now you can go to
E3 without Queen taking which Forks the
D1 rook and the C2 Pawn it's funny he
didn't look strong maybe he'll land it
now you couldn't even take that pawn
with a bishop because Rook D4 was just
game over immediately so uh you know he
he's he's dropping in there like I drop
ELO points and uh and they're looking
finishing it off in style oh take C2
beautiful dress here I'm going to take
support the white King has to move
and you can just go You Can Do Magic
meetings yeah rookie one is coming it's
too many tempting options aren't they I
mean like you can probably resigned what
a finish and with that Fabiano Carolina
goes down in game one Magnus Carlsen
continues his heart feisty Farm what a
week he's had winning the grand Chester
takes his match against Jordan in three
games and today it takes the first game
with the black pieces no idea who can
stop this guy that game was phenomenal
David start to finish too many moments
to pick from but what stood out to you
yeah I just want to show one quick
maneuver an instruction maneuver and
then want to show that checkmate at the
end that Magnus finished off with and it
was here most uh Immortals would be
wanting to put the Knight on an active
square but Magnus realized sometimes you
have to go back in order to go forward
and uh for me 98 was the star move of
the game just reread this Knight to E7
and later to F5 where we saw it was just
an incredibly strong piece and we did
see this Knight do the damage later on
as well it was this position if we fast
forward towards the end where that black
knight did jump into the white uh Camp
here and it just destroyed everything by
sacrificing itself on C2 after Queen
takes Pawn Fabiana resigned after Rook
takes Rook due to the fact that Queen
takes Rook is met by a nasty check the
King has to step forward and this is
Checkmate just from start to finish a
really clean game from Magnus
what a game that was and what a journey
that night had
us went to retreat goes by goes back to
be the finishing piece finally with that
final move that David just showed us and
with that round one is in the books
Let's Take a look at our storyline so
far in the winners semi-finals two
decisive games two big wins there and a
dominating style not a back up to such a
crushing Levon aronian out of the
opening and the same narrative in Magnus
Carlsen taking the big win against
Fabiano caruana and the Fight Continues
with three more rapid games remaining we
will be back after this break
foreign
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
it's a big game coming up but right now
it's the big moment that we've all been
waiting for finally we find out what
happened when Magnus Carlson and David
Howell took the air things challenge
let's go
Magnus and myself are going to be taking
on the air things challenge we're going
to play chess but with a Twist all of
the pieces are air things devices what
air things devices here black Air things
devices and we don't know what the
pieces are so we might be able to rely
on patent recognition in the first few
moves but we will definitely lose our
way somewhere along the lines we also
have a big crowd here so I'm feeling the
pressure
he's too calm I don't like it
did not expect that one it's not a very
good move
okay now this is nice you can see on the
other side that it's upon I thought that
was my queen good to know
yeah that really just looks like you're
moving upon like a night
is this actually work
you tell me I'm guessing I know you're
guessing just sometimes your guesses are
right that's the problem oh I just saw a
nice way to list again
spotted my trap yeah I wish it's day
four you know
he sees everything
yeah I missed that one I can't play it
safe
[Music]
one thing is like they play just this
way but to watch this must be
good
I was hoping for 92 queen of one oh my
God that was me yeah okay the game goes
on
Queen F4 was over there oh no that's
true okay
both missing stuff now 20 seconds
against nine seconds what do you mean
queen of four you mean air things to add
seconds oh
foreign
[Music]
this is a new Queen
if you say so
just for the final position
[Music]
Queen hopefully and the rest are pawns
yeah that's my queen but it's not doing
much the position is very open I think
that helped a lot like if we played a
closer game it would have been a lot
harder
ah there that looks like a lot of fun
but did you get flagged there in the end
dirty flag Magnus dirty player no but it
was a lot of fun actually and we managed
to keep track of the pieces better than
I thought we would I'm just annoyed that
I actually won the second game but they
cut that out what happened there
wow we will get an update on what
happened in that second game between
Magnus and David in the air things
challenge now it might be difficult to
play chess with atings but it's the
easiest to keep a track on your air
quality with earthings and this is your
chance to get 35 off on the air things
weight plus all you gotta do is go on
go.chess.com
that 35 off and we've still got action
on as only one game is done in division
one we saw phenomenal results attacking
chess there and we're getting an update
from catty but that's exactly the
storyline that we had in the other two
divisions aggressive play of
been too much to be honest to see
another night Sacrifice from Martinez at
this time it was really bad but it
turned out that it worked well for him
he won that fourth game so these two
went to the Armageddon game and in the
Armageddon I'm in Tabata by it was with
white pieces he had 15 minutes versus
seven and he won the game starting from
the beginning until the end he dominated
Amin Tabata by continues to fight for
the qualification in the first Division
and he's on the way to win 10 000 USA
dollars oh and I saw Dan last there as
well with the 3-0 wins or some big wins
coming up there Kathy this kid is
Unstoppable he's just 16 years old and
he's beating everyone on the way today
with 3-0 he beat Grandmaster David para
fian and yesterday he knocked down
Grandmaster for him we know he's not
easy to knock down with three two one so
Dennis is also Unstoppable I mean with
the chest airplane you can't even call
them kids anymore the
no they're seeing in division two honest
Eduardo terzaga mentioned this is such a
big opportunity for the players to make
it to division one by winning division
two because it really is a breakout
moment in their career and Katie also
some breakout performances in division
three that's right in division three
Tanya we have to get ready for this look
at this drama here Christian needed to
win this game with extra two queens but
you know what he flocked himself here he
could not win he was trying to remove
all the bees he had extra two quiz two
times in this game but
with one king and more time on the clock
Rao momentov is the one who will fight
to get five thousand dollars that's the
first prize in the third division oh wow
and Alexander Grisha he's the former
World Blitz Champion he's one who comes
under so much time pressure but we never
actually see him getting flagged that
was shocking we're two queens
yeah that's brutal oh my God the
surprises and the shocks continue and
Katie also you Yankee there with a great
result and we see right now the talk is
all about not to back up the satrobe and
Magnus Carlson winning their first game
and look at those aim just stats that we
have David opening accuracy 100 and we
saw some impressive prep by him today
yeah impressive stuff opening accuracy
means he never makes a mistake or at
least a mistake that the computer would
judge as a blunder in the opening and
Advantage capitalization I think this is
where not back is really world class
winning 93 of games where he has an
advantage of over plus one and a half
which is incredible you've got to say
resourceful to and in general just a
dangerous player you see the end game
stats there as well comparable with
Magnus Carlson himself yeah very good
and let's just remind everyone you can
all check out your stats as well just by
going to aim chess and running them on
your own games but uh incredibly
impressive there I'd be afraid to see
how my stats compare to any of those
stats yeah um so that but that was
insanely impressive and exciting to see
and yeah awesome to see the MGs view of
how the player profile breaks down an
accuracy of 90 just insane stuff
yeah just super consistent and that's
the key at this top level just uh never
blunders
but wait there is more action coming up
and we have got a head-to-head between
Magnus Carlton and Fabiano caruana
talking about stats decisive games 99
100 there what do you make of these
stats Danny wow I'm looking at this for
the first time and I'm I'm excited it's
interesting to see that the uh the way
that it breaks down from an average
centipun loss my my brain jumps to that
just to see in terms of their move
accuracy and the average centipone loss
that they might have there obviously as
far as how many games are in the end
game if I'm reading that right that
means Bobby's playing 68 of his of his
games were reaching the end game and for
for Magnus is 59 it's an interesting
stat I almost would have thought it
would be the opposite Magnus so well
known for taking people into the end
game and then getting the job done but
uh there you go and the clocks are
ticking again Fabiano strike back after
what happened in game one it's not just
about the score line but the style in
which a Magnus crushed with the black
pieces and of course don't forget to get
your own aim chess stats to get that
targeted training and your analytics in
right now for Magnus Carlton and there's
joy in the studio as we have another
English it's the day of the English so
what is going on if this keeps up I'm
gonna bust in my English accent and I
know a couple of guys from England can
you give us a little time when someone
can you just give us a little taster you
want me give you a little taste just a
little taste such a bad accident such a
bad accent I love it but I love it it's
so love it one two three times Simon
anyway
I I wasn't prepared to do that you never
put a man on the spot for an accent that
he doesn't voluntarily bring forward
I feel better but all right we've got an
English um not the same King's Indian
transposition we saw in your urine's
battle versus uh itarizaga this is a
this is an even more obscure line with
this E5 being met by D4 yeah it's
interesting to me it shows that Fabi
wanted to maybe play for a win or at
least get a very complex position uh
from the start just the way black is set
up on his first two moves but this is
thrown a spanner in the works what
Magnus has done very direct he's willing
to bring his Queen up uh even at the
cost of a couple of Tempe in order to
open up the center and white might well
just let be left with extra space Simon
uh you're a resident English opening
expert uh you've got accessible courses
on this what do you think uh magnus's
Choice yeah I mean it's actually known
as D4 move quite well I mean it was
actually a game where also casparov
played this way I think with the black
pieces and destroyed uh uh maybe guko
um in something like 20 moves but
generally the structure is quite good
for white
um because white can get this hold in
the center but Black's pieces are quite
active at the moment so if white can
stabilize this position get his King
side developed then I feel he should
have a small advantage
um because yeah Black's just a bit
cramped
we are in 20 moves it was Magnus Carlson
in this last game that we saw
psychologically how difficult is that
for Fabi
well the the uh the game where Magnus
one is black yeah I mean this is hard to
overcome and and uh now fobby has black
and by the way look look at the first
game we had Magnus winning in the
theoretical so Sicilian now Magnus is
avoiding Theory with this sort of
obscure game as white but once again up
on the clock so Magnus bringing out the
Full Slate of preparation and uh and
tricks here to throw fobby off his game
and another player who in round one
bought out and all the prep and a great
gameplay was not about Lebanon is
getting ready to fight it out in round
two we did see Levon not move from his
screen after what happened in game one
checking what went wrong so it doesn't
happen again but once again similar
psychological battles the players are
fighting a king spawn opening we've got
moves on the board we have moves on the
board and wow Petrov defense Abdus tour
of seems to have so many bows towards
during these days choosing one of the
most solid openings in chess as black
but no surprise to level of ronin we see
a trade of Pawns in the center
total symmetry right now both sides will
Castle over the next couple of moves and
can live on a roni and create something
from this position tends to end up quite
sterile unless you can find uh find
something some fireworks yeah I don't
think noribbeck is winning this one in
20 moves but now that he's on the black
side of a Petrov where uh Lavon will
know his stuff here so this might be a
dub that goes the other way and this
match stays close even if it's in an
opposite fashion where where Lavon takes
it into a long symmetrical battle but
we'll see now it's going to be one of
those open sharp pet drops these aren't
the uh the tamus positions looks like
he's playing copycat chess sir here
Danny just copying every move that
levonaronian makes uh when in doubt just
copy the opponent copy your opponent
that is actually not advice not try that
at home or maybe only try that at home a
lot of tension there in the center
perhaps for not a bag it's just about
keeping it solid with the black pieces
he doesn't want the game to get too
chaotic and I want to get the body
language expert in on this because I
like how Danny's pointing to Psy
not a back right is a beast on the board
but on camera often looks
fidgety and a little nervous what's
going on there Psy am I actually the
expert to you that means it's you when
did that happen right now
um yeah I mean I I think naughty bake's
just very confident you've got to be
confident uh to get to this level you
know you can't have too many doubts and
uh he normally has this pose the same
thing I don't think he gives too much
away
um on the other hand aronian stretch
that's what it is it's the Iranian
stretch when he stretches ah he's like a
gorilla isn't he not calling him that he
actually looks like a gorilla but you
know he's like ah
this is going the wrong way why did you
ask me to be the body
I love it I will point out that Levon is
uh is kind of relaxed here lean back a
little bit
um and uh he's he's an experienced Pro
so I don't think he carries over any
feelings of the previous loss here I
know that you know everyone's human and
they do a little bit but I don't know
that he lets it bother him too much so
uh probably probably off to a good start
here and I will mention that a little
bit of nuts not too much can be useful
it helps you stay in the moment it helps
you stay alert to tactics tricks and the
kind of ever-changing nature of the game
uh so I think I'm too sort of he's just
clearly got a good balance here and
nothing seems to fluster him too much
but meanwhile we do see almost a
symmetrical position but now slightly
different white tonight
still in the center of the board black
snake has been forced to retreat and I'm
loving the position of White's Bishops
white start Square Bishop pins one of
the Black Knights whites light squared
Bishop points towards the black king
side so it feels like Abdul sotorov is
facing some pressure it also almost uh
looks like the central pawns the white
porn 25 the black Pawn on D4 it's like
they're the wrong way round which is a
bit of a uh kind of optical illusion
here but uh rinton's position Danny I'm
looking at him wondering who will blink
first right a bit of a staring contest
there on the D file I mean
G5 is possible to take D5 that's not a
move I would recommend because I would
anticipate the position to open up and
ultimately favor white
um but uh yeah and the computer says
yeah that's not a pawn you want to take
there we go concrete concrete problems
are happening here very quickly even on
King G7 I'm sure there's more wow look
at that
I had calculated zero of this just
instinctively thought G5 would probably
not be not be the safest decision
um but your instincts are right there
instincts are right so this wouldn't
work so then if we go back to the light
position all right Bishop B7 there's a
safe way to unpin the Knight create the
threat of Knight takes D5 you say safe
but the evolvar just creeped up what
happened there is this an inaccuracy by
notabeck at least according to the uh
evaluation bar I couldn't the computer
here Bishop E7 it looks natural to a
human to break this pin and you looks
like you're going after this Pawn as
well but wow iron reacts instantly it's
this opening preparation he's only spent
just over a minute he's hoping to line
up on this diagonal and creep in later
with a Checkmate I think he's trying to
get his revenge you know like after the
last game it's like naughty Beck you
crush me now let me have a go a little
boy and uh he's like and he could well
just be crushing here I mean just look
at WISE pieces wise pieces are fantastic
and that that idea you're showing on the
ball there David the queen coming in
it's one of the first ideas and chess
that I ever learned well well worth
remembering at home get the double power
going and just trying to fire it in
towards your opponent's king but wise
pieces are just so good here yeah
they're they're just flooding the board
in on great positions and maybe naughty
Beckett maybe he's just losing it's
possible whenever I play Bishop C2 to
make an obvious threat of Checkmate it's
not as good as it is right here when
when Lavon aronian does it because this
actually is a very simple move and
you're threatening the most obvious
threat on the board Queen D3 and a
battery for checkmate but there actually
doesn't seem to be an easy solution to
this especially because in so many of
those lines the Knight on E5 will
sacrifice on G6 and blow things open so
it's horrible I mean you can try Knight
A6 I'm thinking but I mean it it's it it
looks really scary if I was black here
I'd be uh doing something in my pants
yeah and thanks for that mental image
Simon leave that to the imagination kids
oh don't think about it anyway just
leave it there I think we need to uh
utilize the tool that Danny mentioned
earlier I think we need to check with
the computer how fine is the margin for
error here for Abdul sotorov to me it
Feels Like Only move territory already
otherwise you might well just get
checkmated on that diagonal so maybe we
can see what the engine suggests wow it
says only one move to minimize the
damage anything else gives white an
advantage of over plus two which is
significant at this level and we see the
most logical move or the best move for
black here is to capture whites Pawn on
D5 with the knight in the center there
anything else I'm going to say the
second move there unnatural playing the
pawn to D3 it looks like you're just
asking what to take a pawn for free and
land on a very nice Square the third
move also maybe one of the most natural
in the position but
dangerous and objectively already
powerful for aronian we could see
Revenge immediately here Tanya
in big trouble right out of the opening
he's taking this moment to think he of
course realizes just how big a moment he
is this is for him one bad move and it
could be all over we've been talking
about different options apart from that
night jumping onto D5 which are which is
our engine suggestions and I think David
you have to show us what the problem is
if black was to make a move like that
Knight jumping to A6 can white actually
build an attack by first picking up the
defender yeah I think you're right Tanya
if you find the right move order there
for white if you for example remove that
Defender as you mentioned and then set
up the threat this is just simply deadly
black can block this diagonal with a
pawn but there will always be sacrifices
for example Knight takes upon here and
this will end I'm pretty sure on a
Checkmate I don't see it yet but it
feels like this black king won't survive
much longer feels like yeah maybe this
one yeah yeah slide in I'm wondering
where the Checkmate is after this
beautiful beautiful stuff there's lots
of checks there but uh instructive
nonetheless instead okay he did find the
second best move there Abdus according
to the computer not the best Knight
takes porn I think the idea here was to
block this diagonal with the F Pawn but
this doesn't look human this just looks
too weakening yeah it didn't go for this
instead uh yeah okay putting the pawn on
D3 I thought this wasn't human either
inviting the queen to D3 uh with a gain
of time but his whole idea was to offer
this queen trade and of course this
kid's not human it's actually
fascinating that he found that I I I
agree with you Simon what a great find
and when you see it on the board it
makes a lot of sense you bring the queen
to D3 so that when you take back the
pawn you get to offer a queen trade but
that's not an easy move to play when
your opponent wanted to bring their
Queen to D3 you give up the pawn and
invite danger but uh what an interesting
find of course white is still better
here as long as uh
aronian finds the right move would you
say that this the way he's played the
last few moves not about D3 Queen D3 and
queen D5 this sort of a resource it's
sort of like a glimpse into his genius
I mean he's the guy is as as Simon said
he's not human I mean he is human
um and and he's not cheating um you know
I can I can share because I get to share
funny stories like this and and I I
shared a story during the candidates
that I remember the first time a super
GM who will go unnamed accused all the
Rosa farouzia of cheating and I had to
be like no he's not cheating like he's
just gonna be one of the best players in
the world someday and I will say I
remember the first time that we were
running in-depth reports on a youngster
who was coming out of Uzbekistan and
getting accused by people as a cheater
and they will go unnamed and we didn't
want to try their own reports and uh and
we said no this guy's clean he's just
very very good and at 11 years old now
Notre back abdusa turov has uh has
become a world rapid Champion so he's
he's uh he's a talented kid no longer a
kid I was just wondering how many times
those reports are being run how many
people how many times you've been
questioning not many people have accused
you of Jews okay just just clarifying
yeah okay
I will say that I wonder why that is
yeah nobody it's interesting and again I
don't even say that to disparage the
super GMS who've done that because they
care a lot and they're playing in in
high stakes online chess and they they
worry and they Wonder but we do a lot of
things there and uh and yeah Notre back
was clean we knew it when he was young
and he continues to deliver
so plan what you're saying is when
you're clean and if you're accused of
cheating that's a sign of how good you
are that's what I'm saying people are
talking about the fact that you can't
play like this like it's inhuman chess
and that's the kind of stuff that we're
seeing by uh this genius in front of us
not about he became a world rapid
Champion when he was just 17 years old
he is an Olympic gold medalist already
he's already won a Champions chess Tour
event does he have all the makings and
all the ingredients to be a future world
I I definitely think so I think
coming out of India who might have
something to say about that but if I had
to BET right now as far as the Next
Generation I mean you might be looking
at at one right there and and yeah I
mean these uh this guy didn't have a lot
of chances to prove just how talented he
was you had a global pandemic you had
all kinds of things happening where you
don't get over the board invites and so
I'm not gonna lie me and the entire
chess.com cheat detection team we're
sitting there silently nodding and proud
when he went and won the world rapid
Championship because we're like oh now
he's winning over the board against all
of you guys now what do you think right
because this is a guy who didn't have an
opportunity to say like no I'm a monster
and here he is delivering in the highest
stage and now they know that he's uh he
might be one of the one of the futures
definitely one of the future uh
potential world champions out there so
not a backup disorder and in this
tournament as well the man to beat right
now can love on our Indians strike back
we will check back in with this game now
that this has calmed down let's take
this moment to go back to the other big
matchup Fabiano against Magnus Fabi
after being destroyed in game two how do
you assess his chances in this one David
yeah looks like a very tense middle game
a kind of uh just on a first look here I
prefer white just because it looks like
you have a beautiful night in the center
White's Queen Rook centralized White's
fiancated Bishops pointing at uh some
really nice diagonals butts black is
solid no significant weaknesses and
Simon you must be happy to see the black
H Pawn on H5 maybe the makings of a
attack against the white king a bit
later on yeah I mean even though saying
that I mean I I think black's done
everything he can he's got his Rook on
the open file he's got the H Pawn like
trying to nibble but just in general I
mean I used to play these kind of
positions all the time when I was a kid
as white and just in general they were
always very uncomfortable to play uh
that Rook is on a very weird Square Now
isn't it the first question I mean it's
like can you trap that rook and I think
fabby's doing the right things he's got
to play a bit tactically here he can't
go passive because if he goes passive
white can easily uh take over the
position here but uh what about that
Rook move interesting huh it's a
mysterious provocative yeah he's asking
Magnus to go and hit this rook and did
you see Magnus lean in for a minute he
was like wait is that legal you can
actually do this and now Magnus is
leaning back realizing that uh Fabi has
done some great calculation uh of course
one of fabi's strong points and the
reason I was surprised by it it's not
just because it's a weird Square it's
because also it's inviting the pawn to
C5 using this pin along the D file
Black's Pawn cannot go and grab this
Pawn because uh your queen falls behind
and you lose a rook in the process after
this trade
the idea here for Fabiano it must be
Rook B5 just giving up opponent and now
I'm not sure I see it but it must be
something to do with this Knight you've
given up a pawn
where is the compensation White's pieces
are a bit loose a bit clumsy here
especially this piece on B4
do you guys see anything here it's one
of those long-term compensation
positions I think because B3 is is
tender and not going anywhere right so
maybe there's a simple move like Bishop
E6 again don't quote me if the engine
yells okay the engine yells but maybe
not that loud I mean the point is I'm
I'm looking at the same thing right
white is up a pawn but the knight's
awkward the B3 Pawn's awkward White's
black snide is centralized well there so
Queen B6 as well
maybe that's the move okay it's the
night in the pawn but yeah similar maybe
it is it's really complicated isn't it
actually I mean yeah too many pieces on
the board for me at the moment to
calculate too many pieces on the board
with it we let uh we let Carlson and
Corona yeah I guess yeah one thing I
will notice is the clock has now evened
up when we first joined this this game a
few moments ago Magnus had a two minute
time Edge and so
good sign for carwana there yeah it
feels like Magnus is not quite all in
but if he doesn't go for the C5 push
then his Knight on B4 is Clumsy anyway
so it feels like if you're being
consistent you've said a you might as
well say B this was the whole idea
behind magnus's play but uh yeah let's
leave him with that dilemma David if you
were to pass also move here to Black is
there a direct threat that Fabi has in
the position
ooh have you spotted something Tanya
maybe it feels like something's loose
for white so I wouldn't be surprised if
there's a tactical shot
just be born hanging and the strange
Rook Cliff by Fabiano very creative play
right there uh putting that rook in the
strange spot to create his chances we
saw a feature chat there earlier saying
is there a nicer guy than Fabi I think I
saw it too I wanted to call it out but
Bobby is is a knight is a nice guy and I
agree he's a a likable guy and uh
and yeah not just uh not just for the
catchers that he wears I love that I
love he's got a great wardrobe probably
has an underrated wardrobe can we just
call that out yeah and I do love his
podcast
is great if you told me two three years
ago that Fabi would start the podcast
I'd be like nah nah come on but it's
great I love it c squared podcast go
check it out Google it right now if you
didn't know Fabiano caruana had a
podcast just Google Bobby on a car wanna
chess podcast you'll get it it's the
best big question here to be world
number one to become world champion do
you need to have a little bit of that
Killer Instinct that bad guy is freaking
you definitely you're saying fobby's too
nice
seems like you're setting that one out
Tanya I think it helps right I mean if
you look at the world champions of the
past they're all a bit like mean aren't
they like Gary Kasparov you know he he
could like
yeah yeah you're right yeah he might be
the exception to the rule Fisher he had
a bit of a bit of a streak didn't he so
I think I think matches is a bit of an
underrated competitor not I mean Magnus
doesn't have the same reputation for
intimidating his opponents like Gary did
at the board but Magnus I mean I think
part of what drove Magnus is he wanted
to be the best in the world and uh and
he went after it yeah he lets the trust
he did he sure does most the time most
of the time are we going to go there are
we I like it we have a big move here
David what's going on yeah let's sell
out the chest to speak for itself in
this one Magnus is just stayed Magnus
has just played a really ambitious move
but then look at magnus's reaction he
looked away for a second
wow and all the pieces suddenly
disappear blink and you miss it we have
to go for an action replay there there
are some crazy tactics Magnus didn't
elect the most ambitious move if we
backtrack uh to this position he didn't
play C5 instead Bishop D4 and both
players had calculated this mess it
looks on the face of things that black
can Fork these two pieces but remember
after Bishop takes Pawn there is still
this pin along the D file white would be
winning here so uh Fabiano found a
really nice resource Knight takes Pawn
attacking the White Queen and after a
trade of Bishops it turns out that if
Queen takes Bishop this Knight is simply
hanging and uh let's quickly catch up
instead Magnus got rid of this Knight
Knight takes Pawn gaining time against
the black queen throwing itself on the
fire and uh after this trade we see C5
the White Queen Retreats and Fabi
activates level pawns level material but
I think if anyone I would choose black
big threats now Rook B2 and some Targets
on the second rank maybe the idea of H4
Simon and uh yeah Magnus is a bit
passive here
I really like what fabby's done in this
game I mean it's it's really positive
play with the black piece is against you
know uh one of the well the best player
in the world and uh it's not easy to get
anything and uh you know if anyone's
better here it's black right Black's got
the more active pieces he's got more
things he can do that white Pawn on the
explosive Square C4 is uh is is weakened
yeah it's just a little bit scary for
the Magnus here so and I so far we do
the do the shift in his seat and again
Bobby likes to call us out when we read
too much into body language but there
was a confident at the end of the
forcing combo you know when you kind of
check yourself and you're happy that you
didn't blunder anything you kind of did
one of these and looked at the clock and
all right like I think he's feeling like
this might be an opportunity he's now
got an almost in fact he does have a two
minute Edge on the clock
so uh we'll see if Bobby can return the
favor and get a win with black
check yourself before you wreck yourself
that's what they say I'm just trying to
think what that's from but anyway
um yeah it's it's it's looking looking
like a chance at least uh uh for Fabiano
though but saying that white really
doesn't have too many weaknesses here I
mean he's only got that pawn on the
left-hand side on C4 which is a real
weakness so Black's gonna have to create
another uh another area to attack on and
maybe that's where the H Pawn does come
in maybe now is a great time to push the
H Pawn and just open up the the white
king a little bit more this normal kind
of lever you play uh to do that
what do you think David is this the
moment to go for the attack on the king
side trying to create a bit of uh
tactics there with H4 yeah I would be
extremely tempted uh very interested in
it and there we go Fabi uh before great
call yeah before it's too late before
white gets to maybe look up that side of
the board he says okay come forward
create some dark Square weaknesses
Black's Bishop now is going to take a
step into the center removing white
Bishop which is actually White's blue
right now holding everything together
and yeah it feels like things are
turning in fabby's favor still some
serious pressure Magnus needs to be
accurate now I like that move because it
was a very ensure that I get to play for
two results kind of move right he wasn't
keeping anything dynamic or spicy not
going to let that light score Bishop
stay yes The Rook ending might have
drawing chances for Magnus but only one
player could possibly win that and
that's funny right so that's a very like
I'm gonna grind this out and make sure
that you have no winning chances and if
anyone can win it's me Bobby playing a
Flawless game so far can he make more of
this position we're going to take this
moment to jump into the other board it
was one where we thought love on our own
and will strike right back out of the
opening but a lot of Trades have
happened and how do you evaluate this
position David Wow Let's do a quick
count white has won two points white has
a pawn majority on both sides of the
board on both flanks but black has
compensation in the bishop pair and
blacks Rook on the second rank stands
very actively and big decision now what
to do with the threat against blacks
bishop and B4 you can Retreat that dark
Square Bishop you can trade it off for
white tonight but it feels like
exchanges will benefit aronia and it
feels like that will just guide him
closer to the winner I I agree exchanges
will benefit irony and I think I think
Notre back will play Bishop A5 but if we
can I want to quickly bring up the
analysis board and show a move where
even though the computer called it a
mistake I actually agree with Notre
Beck's decision given the Practical
pressure he was facing if you back up to
where he played Bishop F5 on move 20
David just following the game over here
Bishop F5 was called a mistake because
it concretely lose is a pond but let's
see what happened in the game it allowed
Rook F3 and the F6 Pawn to fall but if
you if you back up before Bishop 5 and
assess what would black do otherwise
you're facing the double the e-file
Brooks rookie seven is coming the F7
Pawn is going to be under Fire he took
his time here and recognized his best
chance was to give up a second Pawn to
make sure he got the bishop here and got
the Rook active and if we go over the
next few moves it's exactly what he did
the next few moves were blitzed out very
quickly he played King G7 and Rook D2
and I again I think Levon is pushing but
if you're defending a bad position and
only down one Pawn versus this position
here
and oh wait did he take let's see oh he
didn't now okay interesting he's also
chosen to get the Rooks on the second
rank I thought he would play Bishop A5
to Bishop B6 to hit the F2 pawn and keep
the bishop here I think that might have
been actually better but um okay either
way I think he took an active approach
even if he loses the game I think it was
a solid defensive decision yeah it makes
a lot of sense Danny and the top players
they're very well versed in the fact
that it's actually going active even at
the cost of material uh is often the way
forward and yeah at least in Practical
terms it looks difficult for everyone to
try and convert this he plays the move
root to A6 and wondering what he has in
store uh if the Rook does come down to
B2
I mean there's also ideas maybe like
Rook C8 trying to win this Pawn if the
whole Quinto disappears if these two
white pawns are full at the cost of
Black's A7 Pawn then you think uh most
likely it's going to be a draw with just
the king side uh so some uh hope here
for Abdul satorov to hold this game
despite the two-point deficit silent
yeah no I agreed I mean I I think he
he's so tough to beat uh this naughty
Beck I mean I've seen him play so many
games now here and elsewhere and he's
just such a fighter and you know we're
talking about future world champions and
there's so many of them right I mean
we've got the whole of India now pretty
much is coming from the entire country
you could be like one of those one of
those million you know kids who are who
are just phenomenally good and work so
hard but and there's something about
nordie Beck which is quite special as
there are many other kids and I it would
not surprise me at all if he if he kept
going kept improving and proving like
that more moves on the board here though
and aronian keeping his to pawn
advantage
keeping the pressure there but not a bag
with his aim just start of a 65 accuracy
in end games can you hold this one is
this closer to a draw or a Levon win
Danny I I'm thinking it's closer to a
draw because my first thought was Rook
A2 could have been met by Rook E3 but
actually no Rook C1 would have been a
big problem so actually yeah so now that
now that I know that uh white White's
Rooks can't really work together
I feel like there must be some way for
black to Corral that a pawn I admit I
don't I don't see it but David already
pointed out and we always have to see
the the forest through the trees the big
picture if the apone disappears that
three on two is likely not going to win
not just because it's hard to win only
one Pawn that Bishop is the wrong color
corner of of of the pawn structure over
there so very good drawing chances for
black
um and and I like this move here I think
I think Notre Beck has actively defended
the game shout out to diberetsky right
taking taking the leaf out of the book
He's actively defended oh we're the kind
of endgame player that we've seen by
notderberg in this game that aim chest
start from 65 we might even see that go
up higher and right now let's take this
moment to jump back to our other game
Magnus versus Fabi and it's a it's only
the heavy pieces on the board and Magnus
picking up a pawn there but the king
feeling slightly unsafe wow yeah more
than slightly after this Lost Queen jump
maybe Magnus missed this one some severe
threats now on the third rank Black's
Queen Black's Rooker lined up Ma massive
threats on the board how does Magnus
defend he's a pull-up but okay he gives
a check and there we go and queen is
going to come back and hold everything
together only 90 seconds as well I guess
a minute 39 but I'm
looking at that C4 will fall F4 will
fall
a will the king fall will the king fall
who's King white does have threats as
well
d8 and queen h8 mates and Black's King
suddenly for the first time in this game
not feeling comfortable
yeah if white gets G5 and queen H6 and
Rook d8 I mean that's Checkmate yeah I
mean these kind of complicated positions
Simon how much do those extra seconds on
the clock matter they matter a lot right
and Fabiano has those extra seconds at
the moment so he I mean this is in chess
essentially you can move quite quickly a
lot of the time and generally you only
get like let's say three critical
moments and in those moments you have to
spend more time because you need to
calculate through them but other times
some of the moves can be pretty obvious
and this is certainly a critical moment
here because uh there's pawns on pre the
queen can come in with a check there's
so many possibilities that black can
play in
um if Fabi picks the right one I'm
expecting keep the pressure on I mean
again having the evaluation bar there
sometimes I wish it would just go away
because if I was looking at this now I'd
be like black must be doing well right
if I was playing I'd be thinking black
must be doing well because I can take
pawns I can do stuff but the evaluation
bar I should say no
nothing to worry about right he took the
pawn on H4 and he's like I'm holding the
whole fort down yeah break this down for
us why does up two pawns but the eval
Bar says level what does that actually
mean well I think that black can't black
can't win back those pawns and maintain
the pressure that that Bobby has on the
third rank so yes you could take like
those two pawns but by the way if we do
account white has five of them right now
so if you win back two pawns the count
is even if you keep the pressure
optically it looks dangerous but where's
the beef right where's The Knockout blow
as David is showing on the board so I
think that it's yeah it's it's hard
sometimes when the computers make chess
look easy and and and we we hate them
but uh but the truth is I think you know
in some ways they give some clarity
through the smoke which is white can't
well I'm sorry black can't do everything
you can't keep the pressure and when all
the pawns back and I love what you're
highlighting David you also don't want
to blunder because maybe maybe Magnus
plays Rook what happens if Queen AJ is
coming over yeah I think the Saving
Grace is that Queen takes H3 I was like
what happened okay why was white was
about to win but no Queen takes H3 yeah
stopping Queen to h8 Checkmate because
the black queen protects a bit of an
x-ray there and this will lead to uh
what's gonna be it's actually a slightly
difficult endgame for white so maybe
still some pressure here looks like this
is on the board what does Magnus try
instead uh if he goes for that variation
just to show it again then uh black is
going to win a pawn black is going to go
up one maybe still a draw but okay this
is incoming it's on the board and from
being two pawns done Fabiano caruana
goes into a rook Pawn ending upon up oh
you better say I think it's yeah King G2
games a Tempo then you can guard the G4
Pawn I think F3 is the move and you give
up the C4 Pawn yeah he goes no he
doesn't that's the analysis board yeah
and we'll reach an endgame such as this
one where Magnus is the one fighting for
his life fighting for the draw so still
some hard work ahead and he only has 45
seconds Bobby's trying to Magnus Magnus
up a double stamp void so if Magnus was
black would you be like winning for
black just resign tough would be yeah
yeah it's really funny how you sort of
Judge it on the players somehow and uh
Magnus porn up just resigned I would
resign I'd resign against both of them
basically I mean I'd just be like yeah
I've had enough I mean I hate defending
these Grim endings
um and again the evaluation bar is just
annoying me it's a pawn but the
evaluation Bar says no it's not a pawn
it's equal why why we're almost in the
territory as humans where the computers
have taken their dominance one step
further with the table base win which is
for those who don't speak table based
fluently it is currently trying to solve
chess backwards to forward and I think
we're at eight pieces now eight total
pieces so nine will be next you're
solving you know billions of possible
positions so you'll look at this
position and just have a result it'll
just tell you it's not there yet but I
mean we're getting there Simon so more
lack of fun coming
wow we are getting an update that in the
other game the fun does continue as it's
not only Fabi who's uh upon up but Lavon
aronian has also managed to snatch up
some material we will get back to this
as Magnus is playing on seconds but
David let's get a quick update from you
what are the chances of 11 striking back
in this one I think pretty decent
chances uh he has this past April one
white apron survived somehow we weren't
so sure about that he has had to give
back a Pawn on the king side but having
one extra Pawn is better than nothing
the one downside here for 11 aronian is
that his Bishop for now is a bit stuck
protecting uh the white king so I'm
gonna say it's gonna be 50 50 between a
draw and a win for Iranian that's really
putting it on the fence isn't it you
know it's like I'm gonna take zero
professionals I'm not committing to
anything you know zero percentage future
politician right there yeah politically
correct answer very good answer I love
this move kg6 by the way because he
might play F5 and if you take King G5
maybe just kind of putting the the
freeze on the position to take away the
rook's x-ray vision or or dominance of
the fifth Rank and just a fun idea to
show okay but even so the Eva bar creeps
up because of the pawn but like what do
you do next and this is black is holding
the second rank your Rook is frozen to
guarding both the A and F pawns so
anyway we'll see oh Notre break does
play F5 although he just makes the trade
it's on the board simple idea wow and
lemon is pushing in this one but it's
gonna be a longer game Let's head back
to Magnus playing on seconds can he hold
that end game David
oh it looks like Magnus has built a nice
formation here just caging the black
king black is still a pawn up but if you
can't bring your king into the game
then it won't be enough it shouldn't be
enough here the black rook and pawn
alone cannot do the damage and white
king is just about holding uh the pawns
together so Fabi he might try something
similar to what ituruzaga tried uh early
against Jordan vanfur is just putting
the BlackRock down to the first Rank and
pushing the black C Pawn but I think
when with you're kind of playing without
this King now shouldn't be enough
agreed yeah I mean I I think you know
Magnus one of the best well the best end
game player ever and he knows what kind
of positions to head towards and the
King just coming over to take that pawn
more pawns get in exchange well that's
much more likely to become a drawer as
well
uh draw looking very lightly now I was
about to say that we came here thinking
Magnus was down to seconds Fabiano down
to eight seconds as well so don't don't
let this get away from you Fabi that
would be the worst thing possible if
Magnus found a way to do a Time scramble
swindle
um again with his hands up in the air he
it looked like something was not quite
all right I I think he was I think he
thought there was there was lag but
there wasn't I think he was like oh
that's Fabiana moved I think sometimes
the players get nervous in those cases
where they're they're worried that uh
the moves aren't registering but
repetition coming up on the this one
ends in a draw Magna is shaking his head
in relief uh Fabiano caruana
disappointed it was his chance to get
this one he did push maximum as much as
he could but it was never enough and of
course the end game touched the end game
Maestro Magnus Carlton holds this we've
got action still on on the other board
let's jump straight to that live on here
still fighting for the win still
fighting and uh there are Bishops on the
board this time so not a pure Rook end
game that increases levon's chances of
winning uh having an extra combination
of pieces there however Black's Bishop
is so well placed in the center of the
board keeps an eye on the promotion
square of the white porn and okay the
black King's coming in something similar
to what you mentioned Danny yeah trying
to close a meeting that's around the
white king potentially I was going to
say with Lavon under time pressure here
you know stranger things have happened
than than a weird result like that so
Lavon should push but be careful because
now look Rook A1 has a concrete threat
potentially a bishop D3 the king gets
out and Notre brick says yeah but I'm
going to check you back for a draw we
might even just liter oh no Lavon wants
more
wow so Bishop D3 doesn't Force the a
pawn to be lost all because of A8 Queen
so you lose the bishop I was Bishop D3
would not work here because white would
sacrifice the queen in order to win the
minor piece so Notre break doesn't fall
for that trick backs up yeah permanence
the white Bishop is just immobilized
right now so uh you need to somehow work
some magic to get the white king out of
the second rank without just uh without
it being checked and yeah it's lucky
there because white does have a H Pawn
and it promotes on a dark Square on h8
so even if you win a piece if you win
the black Bishop if the Rooks disappear
Black's King is going to run to h8 and
uh we call it opposite color bishop and
Wrongs Rooks Pawn there uh and yeah it's
just not going to be enough I think this
one's going to be a drop they're both
very short on time now as well so I mean
Lev can obviously rely on some tricks
but I think they're just repeating draw
draw looking very lightly now and uh
this would be a great save from lordy
Beck I mean just uh being under this
much pressure it's not just about
crushing like it in the last game it's
about defending when things are tough
and that's something I've just never
capable of doing you know I just get
very despondent when I get in a bad
position as I'm sure a lot of people do
11 left still trying here and of course
he's got to but
um he's got to be a little bit careful
this is a nice trip I love too again
pointing out if the Rook makes the
mistake of holding the second rank white
will sacrifice The Rook for the bishop
and then get a queen so so Notre brick
rightfully lets the king out of its cage
Lev's not giving up and I think love is
an underrated tricky I know he's not
known as the online Bullet or time
Scrambler but I've seen him pull a few a
few tricks so let's see let's see what
happens here in this time scramble you
managed to untangle himself get his
pieces active the king is coming out
this is far from over
I agree and uh he's not gonna give up
right he's going to push everything to
the Limit here I still think Notre
breaks defense has been awesome and and
I love the moment earlier we talked
about where he chose the active defense
to kind of get out but but now you gotta
hold you gotta hold with seconds on the
clock seconds for Lavon 14 seconds for
not to back what's going to happen here
what are our predictions in this end
game will not back hold this
yes because material is disappearing he
now has counter play for the first time
in a while at least in terms of Pawns
there we go one drops and it might
become a race at the very very maximum
here it feels like Levon he's going to
get rook and Bishop versus Rook where
Black's Bishop will sacrifice itself for
that far Advanced White a pawn and uh
that one
it's a hard defense but it should be a
draw so uh we'll see if we get that far
Levon meanwhile he's achieved step one
God is pieces three but is it enough
still no clear path to promotion for
that white apron and Black's got counter
play it's a race you made a good point
that you can't even offer the trade of
Bishops here because if you trade
Bishops black can sacrifice The Rook for
the pawn and now you have a Quarter Pawn
so I think I think Notre back has seen
the worst of it I think he's holding and
Levon is sort of checking for good
measure but
I think we're gonna have a rook Bishop
what's this do not trade drugs wait I'll
tell you not wait why can't you just
change huh I'd have you just stick
Bishop A6 Bishop oh yeah but he's too
slow now but I I also had a mini
eval preemptive panic attack but it
didn't happen I just think it's so
impressive how he's held this game yeah
you know let's let's remember he was
he's going to hold it now I mean it's uh
Queen's gonna be Queens at the same time
but it's uh you know he's two pawns down
against uh such a brilliant in-game
player and uh it just uh impresses me
more and more the more I see him play
yeah and just Kings on the board and the
same storyline love on our onion here
disappointed that he did not get the win
he was the one pushing throughout the
game with amazing defense resourceful
play there by not a back he's relieved
with the outcome it ends in a king
versus King which means that Magnus
Carlsen and not about keep their lead
love on our onion he did stop the
bleeding after round one you know it's
funny I think he made a great point that
uh Lavon was pushing and so is fobby in
the other game and it's funny both of
those players would be feeling better
than Levon looks on camera if not for
the previous result right Bobby was
pushing as black against Magnus Carlsen
the entire game just came up just short
that's that's something you normally
feel good about Lavon almost one is
white and put the kid Under Pressure but
again because they both lost in the
first round neither of them went away
from that feeling good yeah I was a
fighting Chester by the players in the
winners semi-finals David what was the
moment that stood out for you yeah I
Just Want To Praise In general the high
quality of that round in both of the
matchups and actually the one moment
that made a big impression on me was
here Levon aronian keeping the game
going after some great active defense
from Abdul sotorov and after Rook C2 it
looks like black is ganging up on the
second rank if you push this Pawn
forward now the trick that Abdul satorab
had in mind was really really nice the
bishop to D3 would have been the move
sacrificing and deflecting away the
white Bishop on F1 and we would have
seen a Perpetual check here instead
lebronian found a way to keep the game
going he pushed his Pawn forward brought
his Rook the whole way around and the
whole way back to keep the fight alive
but eventually Abdul zitorov with great
tenacious defense holding the fort just
really high level game yeah I think both
players played um incredibly high level
in both of those matches and you know it
keeps the lead for Magnus and for nordie
Beck and you know how did you beat them
you know if you can't win those
positions you know what what you need to
win and and it's going to be it's going
to be tough to to break down their
defenses that's the big question and the
question that right now Fabi and love
have to find a way to answer we just do
rapid games remaining this is where we
stand in the winner semi-finals NADA
back and Magnus keep their lead but it
could have been a very different
narrative with the chest that we saw in
game two it's clear now we're in for a
big game three and we will be back with
all the game chess a rapid action in
just a few moments
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
click the link in the chess.com
navigation bar to try aim chest today
and increase your rating 31 faster than
standard tactics puzzles
when you sign up for aim chess our
powerful AI breaks down your latest
games and provides actionable insights
to immediately improve your game you
also receive personalized lessons
created from your game history to help
you learn from your mistakes in a custom
made study plan to help you reach your
goals learn chess your way with aim
chess your digital chess coach
[Music]
this is your moment to get that targeted
training in unlock your potential with
the aim chess analytics and lessons and
we also have some great stats on the
players by aim chess let's take a look
at all that's Trends and weaknesses and
there we have it opening accuracy of a
100 Pine nutty backup Decatur some
incredible prep there and end game
accuracy of 65 great end gameplay by
another bag in that previous round to
defending and holding a difficult end
game and in it I'm just thinking with
aim chess all these stats that we get
the weaknesses and the strengths you can
use it to improve your own game but you
can also use it to prepare against your
opponent that's right aim chess is
really cool in the fact that you can
enter your opponent's games you can
enter their online usernames and you see
exactly their openings exactly their
style their preferences and especially
at this Elite level gives a real boost
but I think Club level even beginners
it's just a shortcut just a it's like
having a personal trainer in a way and
yeah
right it reminds me of top trumps you
ever play that yeah where you see their
scores and you've got to try to work out
which score they're going to be weak at
and trying to Target that area and um
well it's very hard to Target these guys
and I need to uh I need to work out
myself uh what my scores are when I get
back I don't do you think they'll be as
good as that Tanya or up there somewhere
it's very close
you're such a great politician I love it
both of you are fantastic let me try it
wow but you can get your aim chess uh
stats to start that targeted training
and improve your chance in ninja speed
right now it is Fast and Furious chess
in the aim chess rapid as we go into
round three that's coming up Lavon
aronian Fabiano caruana have to win a
game to level their match and we've got
moves on the board Fabi once again
starting with the King spawn opening a
sicilian and this time a repeat of the
2018 World Championship Match David wow
Deja Vu but Magnus didn't employ this
move in the 2018 World Championship
Match it's only become fashionable
recently actually thanks to the efforts
of Mr Carlson himself but yeah
interesting Tanya that uh we're back
there five whole years later and they're
still debating this exact opening
I remember that one it was so close I'm
not sure who won the opening debate it
felt like Fabi was always putting
pressure as white uh in that world
championship match but this time it
looks like Magnus is confident looks
like he's ready to put his leg up again
just like yesterday is that his tail do
we think when he gets his leg over
leg goes up
[Laughter]
Magnus the teapot and then he's
confident yes so uh he's got he's got
the teapot arm right he's just ready to
pour and get his leg out and then he's
going to be doing well yeah he's up a
point in the match she's saying bring me
the tea yes yeah bring me the money show
me the money this is we saw this
yesterday with this opening it is quite
a peculiar position uh because uh you
know this bishop of blacks in front of
the pawn I mean you know again if you
had to do guess the ELO here I mean uh I
I wouldn't be convinced it was uh Magnus
Carlson uh to be honest and um okay he's
unraveling now but you look at his time
on the clock and he's uh he's more than
well prepared right he's been here
before I'm also just fascinated by the
fact that Favi is the first one to
change his approach in the opening in
this battle of heavyweights right
Bobby's not interested in another open
Sicilian decides to go back to this
bishop B5 rosalimo thing that he's tried
before so always just kind of looking at
the game within the game there and uh
again a point for Magnus Carlson in
terms of the prep that he brought to
this match
yeah and interesting because a few years
ago the conventional wisdom was don't
Place slower positions against Magnus
he'll slowly work his magic slowly
outplay you but these days Magnus is so
good at the direct type of Chess when
it's just a battle of knowledge that
Fabi has been forced to resort to this
type of slow
Slow Burn just maneuvering pieces it's
almost reminiscent of a King's Pawn
opening E4 E5 where it is just about
Pawn breaks where you maneuver your
pieces and here we go Fabi trying to
undermine Black's Queen side there's
some pressure there's a threat on the
a-file and uh Simon who do you think is
going to thrive in this type of closed
middle game
I am what are both very good at these
kind of positions I mean I you know it's
very hard to beat Magnus in such a
structure but maybe this is uh fabi's
last chance I mean this is at last white
unless he wins you know otherwise if he
doesn't win this game he's gonna have to
win uh with the black pieces and that's
going to be really tough because Magnus
as we've seen can really dictate the
game and send it in a direction he wants
to send it especially when he's got the
white pieces so I think you know Fabby
has to push here as much as he can and
he he does have better squares he can
move his pieces into so I'd prefer to be
white if I had to pick a side here ah
Fabiano caruana with his final weight of
the match this is round three he has to
level the score by winning at least one
game in the match he needs to do it in
this one if he can because he plays
Black in the fourth round it's the same
storyline here as Levon aronian playing
Black has to try to level the score or
at least make sure things don't go out
of control if not a back takes a win
with white that's much over for Lev do
you think not a back is he going to try
to push hard will he take extra risks
here
I don't think he needs to I think he
just you know there he won't try that
same opening again I really you know
he's got a victory from it maybe he'll
go D4 just go back to his normal play uh
okay if Lev gets equality and it's a
draw still okay he's half point up
there's no no reason to risk it here at
all yeah but at the same time I would
say don't change your style yet right I
mean there's two full games left in the
match right and uh you shouldn't be
neglectful of the fact that you're up
again but you shouldn't do anything
crazy either right stick with your style
stick with the stick with the game plan
so wow so sell for the kill David yeah
some Mind Games here Levon rarely
switches it up usually he's very
consistent with uh E4 E5 as black and
Abdul satorov meets it very quickly with
this modern trendy line of bringing your
queen out just again disobeying all
chess wisdom and losing to Tempe with
your queen in order to get this Pawn
structure with white having slightly
more space in the center so again it
feels like left slightly out of his
comfort zone he's paused here just for
uh what is it around 20 seconds so far
as he tries to get to grips with this
new position is this the Carlson
variation is it something that Magnus
first first came up with I think with
the white putting the queen here the
bishop here like you said it looks
clumsy but it has has a lot of point
right so yeah it's similar to the
constant Sicilian I think is Magnus uh
bring his Queen out to D4 and then back
to D2 and often trying to thinkato on
the queen side but same idea is just to
get this maroxy binder I think we'll see
now and uh or the next couple of moves
of white just controlling as much space
as possible and yes clumsy development
but you have a grip on the position and
I'm not sure who this will face but look
at the clock times both players super
Speedy up to this point I love that
we're calling it The Carlson Sicilian
here the Innovations are happening more
and more by by top players not
necessarily they're not getting move one
named after them anymore right because
all those are taken
um but you are seeing with preparation
David a lot of players get creative
right because here's what happens you're
you're at home
with the neural Nets and the lilas and
the stock fishes and they're like look
at this position this is equal and
you're like well why are more people
playing this like who cares about the
fact that it says I couldn't bring my
queen out or this isn't the most trendy
variation of the open Sicilian it's an
equal position where there's surely a
ton of resources for both sides and it's
just it's exciting because I think again
for all of us 20 years ago computers
were sort of putting the nail in the
coffin and announcing the death of the
game because people were afraid to make
mistakes now I think you have players
playing more creatively and and looking
for more chances like this than ever
before because the computers are like
you can play any position any position
is playable any position is playable and
we saw earlier the aim chess start for
not a bag opening accuracy of a hundred
percent
crazy opening preparation the kids these
days David how do you handle that what
is anti-young player chess that's why I
want to retire these kids are too good
in the opening uh Magnus Carlson coined
this uh term kind of old man chess just
anti-young player Chess at least it's
just getting a position where all the
pieces are on the board you can slowly
strategically outmaneuver them and it's
often just taking a position that the
computer does say is worse and yeah
nowadays just like Danny said a computer
says everything is equal that's kind of
20 years ago it was like oh everything's
equal now it's like everything's equal
come on let's go and actually Magnus
takes it one step further playing
something that does lead to a
disadvantage objectively but is
provocative I I love that you said that
because Fabiano karawana when he joined
us in 2021 for the World Championship
coverage for Yonder palm nashu versus
Magnus Carlson he he said the same thing
he said that a lot of high-level prep
these days the secret is that you're
looking for a position that is
objectively somewhere between like 0.25
and even like 0.49 like a half a cent
upon worse because your opponent will go
for this and if you went a little bit
deeper maybe there's a resource you
always have this Force draw line but
maybe there's a resource that they don't
understand and that's where your biggest
opportunities come is in players
thinking they have some sort of
comfortable Edge but you understand the
position better so just fascinating to
see how how players are leveraging
modern engines and and new psychology to
take on these positions yeah I think I
think that's also why a lot of people
may be watching this
you shouldn't play like these guys you
know you shouldn't play the same
openings because uh if you you know this
is this is a trend I see that you know
players may be rated around 1200 they're
like you know they watch Magnus casts
and play and they're like oh yeah he's
the world champion I'm going to play
that opening but you shouldn't because
it's it's a totally different game that
they're playing I mean uh you have to go
through the basics first you have to
develop your pieces you have to learn
all those other openings before you can
get the subtleties that they're doing
and uh you know not not copying is not
always good copying the top players in
the opening not always a good plan for
example I wouldn't recommend you play
like this as white
um because you you know you're going
against a lot of principles and uh
unless you really know what you're
trying to achieve in the middle game it
doesn't make any sense basically so yeah
that's a really great point to make uh
Simon because 186 with black is
definitely not something you want to
recommend to the kids out there but with
all these top players and all these
great chess players then is it a better
idea for uh chess fans to actually study
their game more to understand middle
game Concepts and end games rather than
follow them for the opening 100 I mean I
I think they say something like 94 of
all chess books are on the opening and
there's again so many lower rated
players maybe players watching this who
get an opening book an opening course
and they get to move like 8 10 let's say
12 and then they have no idea what
they're doing next and it's so important
to know why are you playing this opening
you've got to ask yourself the whys and
the where's you know why am I playing
this move what am I trying to get in the
middle game where are my pieces going
where are my opponents pieces going and
if you don't know the answers to those
questions uh you're not learning chess
in the right way
um so yeah I would say there was a good
step 94 of books were written on the
opening and 94 of chess players are
wasting their time studying way too many
openings and not nearly enough other
chess Concepts so let's say my books
keep buying them please yeah it's really
cute I think I think players latch onto
that because they feel like the opening
is something that kind of makes you feel
good you can control it because you're
trying a new trick and you're like I'm
learning a new thing but really you know
chess players pay their bills and make
their money on how they maneuver and
coordinate their pieces and so studying
positions like this and then seeing how
Abdul satura might coordinate the white
pieces or how LeBron tackles it or the
things that are really are really uh the
things you need to know yeah it's all
about the why behind the move and then
last move
of that Bishop the black Bishop range
freeing up the beep on to move further
this is going to be a fun strategic
fight let's take this moment to jump
back to our other game three from the
winners semi-finals bracket and wow what
do we have here David quite a fun
position out of the Spanish yeah fun it
was from a sicilian time
it looks like it's Spanish but it does
right yeah just and uh yeah it's just a
weird position I'm looking at Black's
pieces it's like Magnus is playing
Fisher random chess chess 960 all the
Blackness or the back Rank and Fabiano's
saying okay you go back I'm gonna go
forward and he's going for checkmate or
at least uh an attacker Blitz attack
against the black king and uh I can't
blame him it looks dangerous to me
whites Rook as well on the a file don't
forget that side of the board it might
come up to the seventh rank in some
serious threats starting to mount up
that's insane we started with the
swashnikov how do we end up with such
well actually we started with a Rossa
limo which became a special craft
structure that then became a Spanish and
so it gets even weirder you're totally
right and I think it's funny the the
computer if we want to bring up the
analysis board first started to give
black a little bit of an edge when Favi
played the move that all of us would
have played he played Knight G5 a couple
moves ago to start the attack and launch
pieces for the king side and the
computer is like no don't play this way
like I just you know I don't like you no
but I love what Bobby's doing here at
least from the perspective that in the
match he needs to get a win you're gonna
put some pressure you're up a little bit
on the clock Rook a seven watch out
right full board awareness
there's a party there I'm invited let's
let's do it it's not for the first time
it's just too good opportunity not to
say that wasn't it I was so excited to
be invited now I'm back just standing in
the corner I've been there don't worry
anyway but no the pressure there is is
is uh is good and I agree this looks
like a Spanish where white has some
decent chances by the way the Knight
will come to G3 The Rook will come to A7
again it's superficial we're just sort
of pointing out that there's that
there's General energy that is building
toward the king side but it looks like
an easier position for white to play
yeah I'm just super confused that the
engine thinks black is maybe slightly
better there's no obvious moves for
black here that I can see maybe you can
put a bishop on B6 just to stop that one
idea but what next for black and uh
maybe you can push this Pawn at some
point but again super risky to open up
lines squares around the black king
I'm glad it's Magnus here playing not me
and I think we can sense how difficult
it is because he's spending a lot of
time and wow after a long thing there F5
he's breaking out he's uh who's
attacking who on the king side some
awkward tension as well between the
Queens on this diagonal getting sharp
all you need to do is make Bishops jump
here don't you I mean if if white can
move his dark Square bishop and play
Bishop takes pawn it would be just the
end of the game uh and that looks it
looks so scary for black right Black's
just opened his King up more and uh
again we were talking about critical
moments and this is one of the one one
of those moments it's like white if he
finds the right thing well you know
could be very dangerous so many pieces
coming in I get I don't understand how
black can be doing all right here looks
looks but I guess it's one of the
positions where again this this
generation who who grew up using
computers versus the one that that uh
had to learn to adapt I think these guys
have grown up using prep like this I'm
sure that they both know the position is
probably pretty complex and that you
know unless there's a concrete blow like
I can play this position because I agree
with you Simon it looks very dangerous
but I'm sure Magnus is like where's the
money show me the money right there's
nothing here I play F5 and uh my pieces
will come to life who's attacking who
but it's not the tipos anymore Simon
well it kind of is it's the mini t-post
they still got the arm out and I might
need to run to the bathroom in a minute
pose yeah so I've slightly opened my
body language toward the toward the exit
door not that I would know anything
about that
uh but F5 that was a brave move by
Magnus allowing fabi's light Squad
Bishop into the attack taking away his
quest from his own King but Magnus has
ideas of his own what I'm looking at is
magnus's background right now pieces
track stacked over there feels like
setting up for a Fisher random game to
me
quickly as possible
um there might be some threats in the
position as well Black's pawns are
slightly loose uh slightly tender there
I'm expecting magnets at some point to
stop bringing his Bishops out the Black
Knights look like then well placed at
the moment holding a lot of things
together again that tension between the
Queens with that Knight and the weight
I'm not sure who's gonna break it or how
it's going to be broken but again just
in Practical terms I think fabi's
position is so much easier to play uh
ideas of swinging that Rook up the a
file White Knight in the center is
glorious the other night's gonna spring
forward Magnus has no easy moves and
that's why he's burning so much time on
the clock four minute difference almost
I I love that you said it because that
was the point I was just going to jump
on is that the clock is indicative of
who's a little more comfortable when we
can't make sense of it and the engine is
like it's roughly equal which doesn't
mean it's a draw it just means it's
complicated even for an engine the time
says that Magnus is a little
uncomfortable the D6 Pawn is the only
concrete sort of weakness on the board
right it's it's under a little bit of
pressure
I spy with my little night eye right and
and that means that there could be
tactics because that F5 Knight is is has
a job to do so anyway interesting Magnus
does Play Bishop B7
I don't know that there's any concrete
thing to do here the engine also
suggests there isn't otherwise it'd be
going crazy but like Knight G3 I want to
invite a Trader that night because if
you take I get a pawn that also guards
F4 D6 is hanging now like maybe maybe
anyway just those those are ideas go
ahead Tonya question you know the idea
you mentioned you want to get that
Bishop 86 sacrifice in G4 will be
completely crazy here because black has
the option to actually pick up that
Bishop
it's
yeah I mean it's it's kind of the first
move I think you should look at G4 right
because you're trying to force the issue
and you're just trying to um take on H6
so I suppose it's the same as Danny's
idea isn't it bring the Knight out and
get rid of the night I mean it's the
kind of move which I've played far too
often G4 you know I've played it to
force issues yeah then I've then I've
made so many holes around my king I I
immediately regret it but
um it's it's maybe an idea but bring I
mean it's so complex this position right
all the pieces remain on the board
um Black's King looks very weak Black's
got a great Center though and it's so
hard to work out um what's happening
here yeah I'm liking Danny's Knight G3
just solid safe and asks questions at
the same time that's all you can want to
remove pretty much so hey Bobby to think
this time you should keep that pressure
on the clock right it's a big part of
this format the clock is the 17th piece
as they say and uh he's never heard that
before that was genius
I've never heard that I didn't come up
with it I don't know who said it but it
really struck a struck a chord there
because I think in these formats you
really have to pay as much attention to
your time management as you do to your
peace management I I love it like I've
heard of like the 12th man in like in
like football like the fan isn't part of
the game or the stadium but I've never
heard that the clock is the 17th piece
there you go I think we need to steal
that I like that yeah I'm gonna remember
that one guys
oh that's that's true it could play a
big factor later on and that's actually
why I think Magnus and Hikaru have such
a big Edge often in these time formats
just because they're so quick so sharp
and they always have half an eye on the
clock but uh Fabi meanwhile in the tank
for a couple of minutes
feels like put that Knight on G3 pass
the move back to Magnus Magnus now is
for sure going to be calculating what to
do in advance so
um yeah a bit of an odd time to think
unless fabi's calculating A variation
such as G4 or something similar to that
maybe not that move exactly maybe he's
just gonna keep his dark Square Bishop
step it back one square and preserve it
for some sacrifices on each six later
you know it's a key moment now you get
nervous if you're a Fabi fan that he's
overthinking it uh you know you've got
you've got a four minute time Edge on
the clock you had one anyway and uh
and so sometimes you know when you know
that you're better you you can you know
take a lot of time because you don't
want the moment to slip and in the
process you were overestimating your
advantage now you're back to equal on
the clock and not using the 17th piece
as Tanya would say right not using the
clock as a weapon no but it's really
true at this level those edges are the
things that pay off right so the clock
is a weapon you can't yeah you know you
can't make it um an adversary you gotta
you gotta have it on your side yeah
you've got to have it as your friend and
you might not realize it with seven
minutes on the clock but in those
crucial critical moments those extra
seconds they really help finding the
right part and right now with the clocks
getting Level it feels like Magnus has
steered his way out of too much trouble
I feel the same way I still like Knight
fg3 I I still think it's a good move for
for Fabiano but um
but he's he's thinking about it and so
yeah the clock is getting even the clock
is now even
um you know no no 17 feet anymore
well it's still the 17th piece it's just
no longer an advantage yeah he'll wish
he had one or two of these uh minutes
back a bit later on in 10 minutes time
uh yeah four minutes thinking none of my
feeling is that he'll he'll play Knight
fg3 but wish he played it three minutes
ago yeah
I think Magnus said this himself didn't
he said uh you know when when he makes
his worst moves it's when he has his
longest Finks right so he actually when
he when he thinks for over a certain
period of time he's not playing what he
his natural instinct is telling him and
these guys have such great Natural
Instincts you don't really need to doubt
what you're you're you know your inner
self is saying you know and there you go
yeah he did play it but he again he
should have played it faster and I think
again like we're not even guessing it
from the it felt like a natural movement
like because I'm looking at the 1905
which guards D6 and I I think
okay Magnus responds right away and I'm
not you know chess is not easy they're
obviously they would they would be
blindfolded but you just you can you can
observe when there's maybe something
psychological going on and it felt like
Fabi was overthinking the position from
watching it yeah it's like Uncle yasa
who always says same move but faster is
better and uh
for me uh yeah not H4 really nice move
by Magnus but it might have taken him
longer if he hadn't had that four
minutes except Abby was like he was just
sitting there thinking of and again
that's why again a lot of we're just
quoting strong players today but like
you want to think on your opponent's
clock that's one thing that the top
players do super well Magnus thought a
lot and worked hard on his opponent's
clock and uh it's that night H4 blitzed
out Knight H4 he was ready for it so
yeah he was ready for it and with the
Queens off the board the pressure has
gone down on black the clocks are Level
we will jump back to this but let's get
an update on our other match not the
back Abdul satro wow that all things on
the board just a pair of bonds have been
traded off this is big tension and which
is four minutes on the clock that's
going to be a 17th piece for Abdul
satrov can I just say something in honor
of Kaya
[Laughter]
but yeah I mean the bar is going mental
right I mean it it's just saying that
White's winning here and the black's
getting all of uh his pieces pushed back
and there's also a major problem with
that pawn in the middle of the board uh
White's ganging up on it um that last
move okay maybe there's other options
but it seems very pleasant for white
this position doesn't it so beautiful
position and it's no surprise if you
just look at the general kind of outline
of the position all of Black's pieces
are on his first two ranks uh Let's
ignore the pawns for now White's piece
is beautifully centralized beautifully
coordinated and the pawns are stepping
forward and it's going to be a big
attack and the clock says it all uh
again we we say look at the bar and look
at the clock right those two things are
very
you know indicative of what's going on
here when we left it although I'm
sitting here watching the games on on
chess.com's events events portal and I
and I want to point out that there
really haven't been any big Mistakes by
irony which really goes even more toward
notabeck's credit that he's just been
slowly outplaying this position the
space Advantage is just like
like he's just marching forward here and
he's just continuing to increase
um the uh the pressure so you got you
gotta love the way he's playing
yeah this is what they call the Hedgehog
formation as black when you kind of just
line up on your first three ranks and
often it's a bit prickly if you step too
far forward then black can counter
attack but here just looks like black is
passive Knights on the rim we've said uh
just Grim all the time and that Knight
on A7 looks horribly misplaced feels
like white at some point it's going to
combine the kind of central pressure
with a king side attack it's just uh how
to do that for a position he has a five
minute kind of surplus here to uh to
kind of find something Knight of six
though let's not write level off it's a
tricky position for both sides that's
yeah looks like the youngster I'm just
terrific he's done everything right so
far in this game a lot of strategic
trumps in White's position space
Advantage the Rooks lined up D6 a big
weakness for 11 aronian and four minutes
on the clock here if not the back
manages to win this one he actually
wraps up the mat Simon
yeah he does indeed yeah and he just he
seems to be getting stronger and
stronger right I mean like uh his
confidence is growing and he's uh picked
a great opening here just grinding away
bit by bit and uh I wouldn't be
surprised if he just uh puts this in the
you know finishes it off now uh maybe
the only danger is that he over presses
here do we think Danny I I was just
gonna say that you just you know
two peas in the pot down here
or you can just not you can embrace it
no but someone someone pointed out that
one of the other things to not
underestimate I think you're saying is
like this is a hedgehog type of position
and sometimes in those positions the one
things we know about computers is they
they have an equation with which they're
evaluating which is space and black
really has no weaknesses here like right
I mean you can put the Knight on C8 and
you can kind of wait a little bit and if
white does get crazy with moves like G4
in hedgehogs black will strike with D5
or B5 at some point the position becomes
open and and that's when things can get
spicy so I think one of the things we
should be careful about is not the
really the thing I actually hate the
most about Lev's position is on the
clock I hate how much time he's down
that's really his biggest disadvantage
because on the board the space Advantage
is there but where's where's the
concrete knockout black is always a
little worse according to the computers
in a hedgehog structure
um I'm gonna say it again I mean looking
at the cameras and the players in front
it looks like Lev's the one who's got
the lead in the match and not a brick
extra tensed right now
he's a he's uh he's fidgety he but he's
focused he's fidgety but focused you
know there's a lot of kids like that
around around chess halls around the
world you know some of them have to
still sit on phone books while they beat
you through that little baby Focus
Legend another FFL famous
focused
fidgety Legend I was wondering what you
were trying to say I don't even know I
don't even know half the people know
what what the ffls were referring to but
shout out to you gotta
um
and he is playing division two I think
isn't he that's why I said shut up I
don't know how he did today but he was
in division two
and me while he drops back the bishop
Abdul sotorov and still a great position
the one problem is that the onus is on
him with the extra extra space here to
step forward at some point so he will
have to take a few minutes there to
calculate and make sure he steps forward
at the right time and really initiates
that chaos Levon though under four
minutes he should be playing quickly too
he just needs to wrap up into that ball
like a hedgehog would and hope that when
the Breakthrough eventually arrives that
it's mistimed but yeah still liking
White's position okay nice solid move
there holding lots of things together
you know the bar goes up but and then
again I don't have a ninja move I'm kind
of like where what's the reason what's
the reason was the and otherwise I just
think that it's the engines getting
excited about what we taught them to get
excited about which is space yeah and uh
we'll see how they use it I mean this is
where I I often go wrong in a position
like this I just want to play I just
want to finish it off all this
maneuvering Bishop backward and fours
putting a little bit of pressure on my
opponent at some point I just get
impatient and I just want to go F5 you
know I'm just like right and at some
point you do have to play a move like
this right
um if you want to win but
um it's obviously quite anti-positional
something like that because you're
giving a big Square in the center but
still tempted I mean I don't know I mean
David you probably wouldn't go for that
would you you're this is where I've got
to learn I've got to learn from David
I'm a coward Simon not a cowards you you
do things you've got perfect timing I
think the reason I wouldn't play F5
specifically here is just because black
can trade the Queens off and with the
trade of Queens for the pressure lessons
but he plays it anyway wow maybe there
was something stronger that's such a bad
sign wow that's such a bad sign if he's
playing it I actually missed the
exchange of Queens David so I actually
just missed it and uh you're right that
that takes a lot of pressure off left
position doesn't it it's funny because
he's going for The Knockout blow but it
may be the thing that let's let back in
the match right he's maybe sensing the
opportunity to put it away but it's it's
it's exactly the way Hedgehog positions
go wrong for white eventually you play
that overextending pawn move whether
it's a G4 or an F5 and black finally
gets their life and black will have no
weaknesses as the pieces get traded off
but how critical is it for love to find
this queen trade
I think he has to otherwise you might
just get checkmated as Simon says the
queen is coming in somewhere along this
diagonal and you might not get another
opportunity
can you go Rook D4 after I was wondering
about that but anyway and give up the
route anyway sorry I'm carried away now
but yeah this is a normal break right
this move but
yeah this is a big threat and White's
King has shuffled to the corner this is
getting crazy right now uh it's really
exploded white could have taken this
Pawn but this would have led to a nasty
skewer so he scoots out the way with his
King and
what to do now the game mode might pay
off for another book with with seeing
levon's D5 response because now if we
get a spicy position by the way white
has a three minute time Advantage it's
huge especially as we're about to see
fireworks and that Queen's gonna come to
H6 so uh maybe the the intuition there
was right that Lev for whatever reason
would not play Queen C5 and now now the
attack is on yeah the attack is on
whites pieces are poised Lev needs
something with two minutes in this crazy
position you have like three or four
different Pawn captures here where do
you even start calculating with only two
minutes on your clock it's just pure
Instinct but this is a calculation type
of position
oh yeah I feel for black I think just
get the Queen's off and survive that was
her number one priority for black there
and comes down to having those extra
minutes on the clock which right now
left doesn't have and move after move
he's making these inaccuracies
yeah this one feels wrong and looks
wrong just because white now can pick up
a pawn in the center and just set up a
wall of Pawns that block the black
pieces maybe that's even stronger here
for update maybe your knight captures I
say like is it time is it time I mean
just let's go like all in is is there an
opportunity to take with D5 take on D5
with the Knight I think the C Pawn also
is good just to make sure that we keep
things as spicy as possible I actually
wouldn't take with the epon because I
want there to be more trades whites
pieces are more more primarily placed
which chess Theory teaches us that if
the position becomes open the pieces
that are in a better spots should get
better tactics right um and look at
Black's pieces Bishop on a89 A7
if this thing blows open white should be
in a better spot to clean up
need to be accurate here Abdi Satora but
looking very very promising he's
probably got more than one good move
that's the other you know that that can
be a bit of a hindrance I guess uh
sometimes because you you overthink the
position but he's got the time to do
that so I mean which way would you
capture her David Instinct first
instinct told me he takes D5 just
capturing away from the center with
White's uh kind of middle Pawn here just
because I wanted to keep pieces on the
board I just thought actually black is
the one who's cramped to keep business
on but the more I look at it I think uh
more I'm inclined to agree with Danny I
kind of want to open up this white
Bishop on B2 go for the kill go for the
kill yeah watch your 17 piece LeBron
sorry
yeah it's ticking down and we're just
gonna update everyone the the Magnus
Fabi game the third game is uh in all
probability going to end in a draw it is
a very peaceful position we'll stick to
the drama here because all the action
here and they've nodded back wins this
it's actually match over yeah Notre back
could be the first person to punch his
ticket to the next round again he just
won the chess can cut he's uh he's on a
roll here it's not over yet we're about
to see fireworks but uh the kid is on
fire it's on fire we don't see him as
often entitled Tuesdays but he's been
playing Amazing online speed chess it's
funny yeah I mean he used to be a staple
in fact that was where he first got
accused because he was winning Donald
Tuesdays but um he's uh yeah you know
he's he's obviously super focused we
know that he uh I don't know if we're oh
come and take his cup commentators curse
this feels wrong on multiple levels
though it feels like you allow black
various different hits on the White
Queen feels like you've given your
opponent a lot of choice the Black
Knight can jump in the center black can
give away a pawn with D4 open up this
bishop 188 I think in general in chess
if you can give your opponent as minimum
kind of as few options as possible
especially in speed chess that tends to
be a huge benefit I mean if it pays off
then I'll leap my words but just it
feels wrong I haven't calculated things
here like how to satorov has but no one
options how many just basing this on
pure calculation otherwise I mean it's
very anti-positional as you mentioned
you know it just feels wrong but it must
just be you know he's crunching the
position right he's saying I'm attacking
the Knight the Knight has to come here
and now we're going to see what his idea
is but uh
very strange decision though it's also
very risky I was going to say what's the
idea is he prepared to sack The Exchange
it's got something up his sleeve but
he's paused again surely by playing E5
you've got kind of a continuation uh
immediately in mind also he's blocked
this this dark Square Bishop on B2 he's
blocked his own attack Black's Knight on
e4 if it survives it's gonna be a
menacing piece it's also Bishop C5 is is
a big threat now that that movie
mentioned before uh the bishop attacking
White's Queen uh could could could be uh
something which is scary yeah Bishop
coming either way and uh well he he's
given counter play to
um Levon when he just didn't need to you
know this is again a mistake maybe maybe
a little bit of Youth that he could have
played one of the moves that David or
Danny recommended just kept a very nice
structure kept total control but there's
no reason to give your opponent counter
play unless there's something Concrete
in the position and um okay well what on
Earth's going on now this is his idea
it's on the board he wants to line up on
this diagonal maybe creep in here the
White Queen creeping into H6 he needs to
deliver Checkmate though White here
otherwise his Knight on H2 is simply
sidelined and whites are Pawn down so
Stakes are incredibly high right now and
from a practical perspective obviously
we have the benefit of the eval bar and
we can we feel the position has slipped
away probably they do too but he's
looking at the clock he's down two pawns
now Fabi he's dying he's got to go for
the king is it Knight G4 is this his
possible idea just trying to get the
fish pin I can't you know but that is
root no I don't know
Knight G4 wow you know I love the vines
I love playing rubbish moves you know
but I mean what else could it be I mean
but this is really all in now right you
know you're giving Pieces away you're
not liking your pawns or your pieces
anymore and the idea of this moves try
to get your other Bishop in this is the
only idea of it but it's very risky and
very risky under 20 seconds did you see
as well I've just sort of played that
move then he looked off at aronian's
camera he was like deal with that yeah
Bishop takes and now this black king is
not going to survive the white Bishop's
White Queen are going to come in Rook D7
looks powerful here Rook d7's the move
Rook D7 I don't think he saw that as
well isn't it a massive check on it
sacrifice how's he going to kill this
one
all the pieces coming into the attack
that phone just didn't have time on the
clock White's Bishop gives a check the
White Queen is gonna follow in next it's
Queen f4s in something yeah you can just
trade queens and meet on E5 oh that's
beautiful that is beautiful that's it
Lavon is freaking out he's got five
seconds it's over that's
Legend over there he knows he's seconds
away from actually wrapping up the match
Levon and it is much over wow
unbelievable not a backup do such
robotics the second win the inner or in
the Winner's bracket what a stellar
performance this is by the 18 year old
continuing his run he's the man to watch
out for he could very well win his
second title of the Champions Chester
it's amazing because he he it wasn't
clean but he got the job done right and
he felt the moment and kept the pressure
we're obviously checking back now on
Magnus who I don't think is going to get
the Dub here we'll likely have one more
game after this is a draw but I'm just
blown away by by how noterbeck finished
the job there again it was messy but we
have the benefit of it looking messy
because the eval bar really that was an
aggressive and very very fanciful
tactical attack winning game yeah I
think he should be proud of it update to
tour if he played the human approach as
well he went for an attack when maybe
there was a defense but it wasn't easy
for live on Iranian in no time the 17th
piece decided that one Tanya I think
that's the whole point right he played
the position as well as the clock he
might have not calculated the whole
thing but he played it fast you put the
pressure on the clock and that got him
the big win that was the human approach
and it worked to Perfection and in this
one this looks like it will end in a
draw which means Fabi will have to win
with the black pieces
yeah it does look like that black king
is almost checkmated but anytime you hit
it if you ever push the white G Pawn
forward to give a check flux King has an
escape Square so if there's no Checkmate
unfortunately that does mean it's likely
to end in a draw and Black's Rook I
really like this really instructive from
Magnus Carlson he's put it on the fourth
rank cutting off the white king so the
white king can never step forward to hit
those weak black pawns whites Rook as
well if it ever moves away the black
king will just sneak in so I think
Magnus can just wait here just pass with
his Rook
give us a check
that's just too much that is it's so
unnecessary by Magnus but I mean they
say there's no sense humor in chess but
that shows there is sense of humor yeah
that was pretty that would have been
awesome to see it on the board but David
your idea might be coming up the king
sliding on the other side G3 Checkmate
yeah let's just quickly show that again
in action replay Rook to E4 any Rook
move here is pretty much fine Rook B4 is
fine Rook check if you take it with
either king or Rook this is stalemate
and ignore the bar this is stalemate
yeah and it would be a draw I mean while
Fabby has gone for a Checkmate on the
other flank he wants to play G3 trapping
this King but again the Black Brook does
the job of Defender it pins this Pawn
keeps it honest and there's no way
through no route to Checkmate this is
gonna fizzle out to a draw but nice
moment of artistry there from Magnus
yeah
yeah it's nice to see that because I
mean you could have you could have
played other moves as well you did not
have to play the flashy move but we we
all want a bit of uh you know Magnus is
an entertainer right he's uh screaming
in the middle of a Coliseum are you not
entertained right he's uh
bring it in there's a smile right there
before he turns off the camera
and this one goes into the fourth round
with Fabiano caruana still trailing the
match he needs to win to force the
playoff Magnus needs just a draw to
continue in the Winner's bracket and
there we have a Fabi what do you guys
think is he looking at the previous game
or is he preparing for the next one
I think he's probably quickly looking at
the last game sometimes you need
emotional closure you know just so you
can move on with uh with full Focus
looks like he might be quickly looking
at where it got away from him because he
was a little better there he's been
pushing the last two games there Fabiano
caruana but yet to get that big win that
ended peacefully but the not a bad game
was anything but peaceful what an attack
that was what a finish that was David
once again take us through the Highlight
yeah the Highlight has to be those final
few moves when nodded back went for a
practical sacrifice and it paid off due
to erroneous lack of time on the clock
here we were saying oh he's let it slip
he's blown it he sacrificed two pawns
nodded back here and the compensation is
a bit dubious but Knight to G4 a
beautiful move a beautiful sacrifice and
actually it should have been ignored I
really had no time on the clock and
panicked at the thought of a night check
but if you just stayed calm and brought
his Knight to C6 he would have still
been in the game Pawn takes Knight
however was catastrophic and after the
bishop joined the attack this was deadly
the bishop is coming in due to the
crisscross here as well all of White's
pieces are attacking and the killer blow
was Rook to D7 let's just show the final
position after a bishop check as Danny
mentioned King tries to hide in the
corner a simple Queen trade kills the
game and the Bishops do the work
Checkmate and aronian is eliminated from
the winners bracket
Fanning chest there which means that
Levon will go down to the eliminate
Asian bracket let's take a look at our
score line going into the final game for
Fabiano caruana and Magnus Carlson Notre
back up to satro of wrapping up his
match against LaVon aronian in just
three games that's not a score line that
many would have predicted at the start
of the day and we are being joined by
the winner of that match not a bag
congratulations once again
thank you what a match that was wrapping
it up in three games how pleased are you
not only with the scoreline but the
quality of play as well
yeah obviously I didn't expect to win
the match in three games but yeah I
think the first game was pretty much
very important and
yeah I played this on dubious line which
which is objectively just lost
but uh in a practical game it's just I
think it's too too hard and
yeah
I managed to to win him quickly and and
then I just switched to the you know
playing solid chess and it worked out
well wow so not about you knew that you
were walking into a line that should be
lost if your opponent knows how to
respond
that's amazing what a practical choice
and it paid off and then game three that
was also quite an attacking Masterpiece
now there was this moment where you
sacrificed the peace
how can wins for you of that sacrifice
yeah I felt that my advantage is
slipping so I just tried to you know
create a mess
as possible so yeah I just saw this E6
Fe 9g4 with a good uh but it was very
dangerous looking uh threats so yeah he
had to play 96 but it's you know it's
with 20 seconds in his clock it's too
much pressure I think so yeah
um yeah that was a very good game
also
um but yeah I I got a little bit lucky
there
Notre back you continue to play well man
it's it's impressive to watch I had a
question because yesterday you maybe
didn't start out as on form as you seem
to be now does sometimes it help to get
in a little bit of trouble early in an
event where you have to win on command
and go to Armageddon in order to find it
against Wesley today you seemed right on
form and talk a little bit about how
maybe the momentum carried over to today
yeah it's yeah of course uh in
yesterday's match I I
uh I didn't believe like I have a good
chance to beat Wesley on demand
but uh yeah after I manage it just I
just uh I just uh got the confidence and
uh after that and I just
um
just go everything is going smoothly so
far and
yeah it's very
um
very hard to keep the momentum every
every time but
uh in uh in some days you you get the
you know you get the
Victory and and that's that's how I'm
taking the matches
yeah it was really an awesome day of
Chess and you continue in the Winner's
bracket now the back you're gonna face
either Magnus or Fabi tomorrow in the
winners final any preferences of who
you'd like to play
um
um I I played two matches against Fabi
so yeah as so I think I I didn't even
played
uh a single match against Magnus so I
would of course
um
uh we lost him at such a critical moment
just as he was about to answer but I
think he was going to say that he'd like
to play against Magnus because he hasn't
played him yet in the Champions Chester
and that is a Champions mentality right
there we will be back with a round four
action from Magnus versus Fabi on the
other side of this break
[Music]
thank you
move over mittens there's a new Top Dog
in town
G the bernadoodle might be an
international master of fetch but chess
lessons with his dad Gotham chess aren't
really sticking
host of his own Public Access TV show
wish boy knows a thing or two about the
most dramatic moment in chess history
a baller through and through buddy
buckets is moving his game from the
basketball court to the chess board
watch out
pinky practices chess from the inside of
his mom's handbag on wolfstock's law
campus don't judge a dog by its Diamante
caller
panchic learned chess from his dad GM
Levon aronian he has never lost to
another dog at chess and certainly won't
lose to you
this July the possumness is Unleashed on
chess.com
we have one more rapid game coming up in
division one between Magnus Carlson and
Fabiano caruana meanwhile division two
and division three it's a wrap for the
day Kathy give us the big update and
what are we looking ahead right Tanya I
heard you guys were talking about
garakowski Legend and he is fighting to
get his seat in the first division he
will face Sam Sabian tomorrow today
winners semifinals he has Incredible
Journey so far he beat Jeffrey Zhang and
Teresa sahakyan and Tanya I'm looking
forward to see these two matches as well
and that is gonna gonna be a fire for
sure
it's going to be fire reaction in that
one but we also have some big matchups
in the losers round two right all these
players still have chances to come back
they just need to play all the games and
beat their opponents Chef Jeffrey Zhang
Jose Martinez and David paravian
alongside with others they still have
chances to come back
its store points prize money and the
golden ticket to the next division one
of the Champions chess store on the line
for these players who are fighting in
division two right now uh some big names
there big moment for FFL gatakamski can
he do it can he fight his way into
division one and Katie you've got some
updates from division three as well
that's right in division three we do
have two finalists already and there's
gonna be Yankee and mainly those are the
winners in this bracket they gonna fight
tomorrow and is there a favorite in that
one
is for sure the favorite rating favorite
he has been playing so much just lately
but you never know because also mainly
had such an incredible run at this event
yeah not just this event you yangi fresh
from an incredible run in Dubai in the
global chess league as well and he
continues that feisty run in division
three but right now it is back to
division one as we go into that final
round four Magnus Carlsen taking on
Fabiano Carona he needs just a draw Fabi
has to win on the van Fabi plays with
the black pieces boys can he do it
well it's been done before we keep
saying that it's not easy to win with
black and force Armageddon but haven't
we've seen it twice now in the event
yeah so a third time's a charm it's
mathematically possible well
mathematically I like that answer
what about practically Psy when you're
playing against Magnus no chance we said
no chance in Notre back beat Wesley
itarizaga B Jordan
there's a chance thank you Lloyd
Christmas
look it's the new white Black's been
scoring really well actually so far in
the Champions chess tour this season and
in Rapid chess it's all about the
opening if Fabi can get a position
that's really tense he will back himself
to at least post some questions to
Magnus but uh getting out of the opening
with a playable position with winning
chances that's going to be difficult
especially when Magnus starts with one
E4 he always goes this way when he's
happy with just a draw with white
but is it psychologically easier for
Fabi to know that you know draw is as
bad as losing so you just go all out he
doesn't have an option in this one a
draw and a loss is the same result so he
knows that he has to take those complex
decisions when the time comes
well I think as we see he's spending a
lot of time thinking here and he's just
literally trying to work out what move
can I play to give myself chances
because uh but yeah and this is risky he
knows that oh this is really risky I
mean he knows
they're like what's wrong with my
opening
okay it's risky it basically is risky
and but I mean I think this is probably
the white the wise choice right Danny I
mean and David you've got to play
something unconventional you've probably
got to take uh you know some risks but I
like what Magnus is doing here this this
line is known to be uh a bit of a
problem for black
um it's going to be so hard isn't it to
get a playable position and again
someone with so much knowledge that is
straightforward for weight that's part
of the problem too there's not a lot of
places to trick Magnus yeah and the
problem is Magnus employs this opening
quite a lot as himself as black when he
wants to win uh when he wants to keep
the game alive so he knows exactly how
to shut things down from the white side
and wow Fabi is setting up in what we
almost call a hippopotamus uh formation
something you know a lot about Simon
I've played this position as black many
times so there I am saying it's really
dodgy but I play it all the time and uh
what white generally does here is move
the Knight next to the king and this is
a really annoying system actually if you
just Shuffle that night over and it's
actually kind of known to be a bit of a
problem with what we call the
hippopotamus black setup is is meant to
resemble a hippopotamus
not sure I see it but that's what it's
called and
um yeah and it's it's it's maybe what
what Fabiano has to try at least he
keeps all the pieces on the board this
way and that's important but Magnus
knowing exactly how to approach this and
moving the Knight to the right Square
unsurprisingly you mentioned it's called
The Hippopotamus uh science because if
you imagine to be in the C Pawn which
were in the original place it feels like
a hippo sort of Leaning out of the water
you know with the head up but now with
this BNC Pawn Advanced the hippo is
leaped out and it's suddenly a very
active position what kind of animal is
that I mean you got the colors right do
you want to draw an animal here at that
time there's only one game going we're
gonna get into plenty of analysis I'll
draw give me a I don't know I kind of
wish this Pawn was back like a Chinese
dragon you know like uh like on the the
new year yeah there's a little bit of a
snake thing going on here it's more of a
dragon in a hip hop
wow I don't know I have seen them you
know really short chat said dragon do
exist yeah some of those Friday nights
I've had you know so and
um but it's quite risky of black pushing
the pawn to H square but okay I mean
we've got a position haven't we we've
got a position where everything is on
the board and that's that's uh what
black needs to do keep the tension Simon
Harry the h1's made an appearance Magnus
pushing forward ah this is a move I hate
facing because the problem is and I've
had this happen to me so many times
black yeah H6 played on the live board
but you always have to now think about
H5 G5 and then a sacrifice on G5 and
this might not be possible here but it
just lurks for the rest of the game and
whenever this happens white gets two
pawns but also an attack and uh you know
it's just it's just horrible that that's
there forever and that's why I don't
like the system so much I mean the
analysis shows that it's probably
possible for a white to play for right
now oh wow there's not even any any
worse necessarily than the advantage of
the White House on the Whiteboard after
this shows Bishop before so yeah it's um
again I'll say this that if you're
looking for an opportunity to create
a crazy A crazy mess you kind of have to
give your opponent an advantage when
you're playing Magnus Carlsen right so
Bobby has given Magnus an advantage it's
going to be a little bit of a mess
um if Magnus is on Forum he's gonna put
this away and there will be no arm again
right but at least you've created a bit
of a spicy position here
I took all one question on my mind I see
H4 on the board who's playing for a win
who has to win this game on demand is it
white or black this is the best thing
about Magnus Carlson's chats this is the
reason we all you know love watching him
and fell in love when he beat uh LaVon
aronian in the last round of this first
thing field Cub when he didn't have to
play for a win and could have taken a
draw and he did it anyway because I
think that that's the mindset that has
allowed him to be as good as he is that
he doesn't he doesn't think the way
people do as far as being afraid of risk
or what they're afraid of losing right
he just objectively
you know again if Bobby offered a draw
here he'll take the draw but he's not
going to play for a draw he's going to
play for the win and uh probably get the
dub along the way and Danny I have to
just say a very quick story I remember
the British championships last round I
was sitting next to this uh guy on board
one and he only needed a draw to take
the British championships right which is
a massive title and he's there and he's
playing an international Master
dangerous guy and uh the international
Master thinks he's having a nice day off
offers this guy a draw and we all think
yeah okay this guy's gonna be British
champion now what does this player said
he says no I'm like what's wrong with
this guy he's gonna get like 5 000
pounds the British championships and he
turns down the draw and we all know who
that is isn't it this chat here yeah
against Gary Lane and I'm just like how
wow how confident and brave is that to
you know British championships the same
we dream of becoming and he did you win
or it was a draw eventually eventually
but he turned down the draw and it's
like the only way he can't become
British champion is by losing so I was
young and dumb and I thought I could
conquer the world but I like it yeah who
are you young dumb and Brooke
laughs
that makes a lot of sense I love that
story because you know great minds think
alike now we know why you and Magnus are
such good friends both of them refusing
draws in these kind of situations makes
a lot of sense it is the Champion's
mentality and Magnus here not playing
for a draw he's getting the kind of
positions he wants but this also gives
Fabi the chance that he's looking for
it does yeah I mean it's very hard to do
anything in this position as black
except for you've got to wait and you've
got to take your opportunity but um you
know okay well Magnus has thrown a pawn
forward first
um and this is gonna create a change in
the position because uh you probably
have to take on D5 something like that
but uh I don't know what do you think
it's painful because I was just thinking
the same thing you kind of have to take
otherwise the D6 Pawn will be lost and
that's exactly what Magnus wants he's
going to take with the E Pawn and then
put the bishop on C2 and he's going to
play H5 and he's going to crush you
maybe he'll play 95. so I was shaking my
head and you turned to me because I was
like it's a painful move because oh wait
wait Magnus took with the bishop so I'm
missing something
that's not what he wants or maybe this
was too risky maybe he didn't even want
to give up a pawn it still looks like a
fearsome attack but yeah take him with
the bishop that's a uh Twist on the
narrative that we've been peddling for
the last few minutes Bishop takes porn I
guess if he takes with the Queen the D6
Pawn just Falls yeah I guess that's yeah
yeah look he does it I was sometimes
it's so obvious you can't see it right
in front of you right he just takes with
the Queen the D6 Pawn
is falling and what's funny is even if
you objectively like are giving some
sort of chances for black like this is
like this is like a crushing blow for
Fabi right because there's no world
where he's not groveling uh and hoping
for a draw if the Queens come off yeah
at the very best black can hope for
compensation with the bishop pair maybe
but compensation is not the same as
creating serious winning chances and
yeah it's not obvious at all Bishop
takes D5 I don't think it would be on my
radar just looks counter-intuitive to
give up a bishop for a night especially
when the position becomes open but if
you win a pawn in the process
yeah these guys they see everything all
the options every time is there anywhere
that Fabi can uh hold on to that pawn on
D6
looks tough the problem for black is you
would love to jump the Knight out the
way and unleash an attack there we go
against White's Queen with your light
squared Bishop but you needed to protect
your Bishop on B7 and A5 is not
necessarily the best square and there we
go we will see okay not yet a trade of
Queens it will happen on fabi's terms
and at least the Black Knight on C4 is
active but that pawn on B2 is going to
be protected and Magnus doesn't have too
many weaknesses Magnus moving very
quickly isn't he I mean uh it's some
difficult decisions here I mean maybe
black has some counter play here though
as you said David he's got two Bishops
if he can um get his Pawn back you know
then it is probably going to be better
you know with uh this break B4 that
could be coming up to try to unleash the
dark Square Bishop I mean it looks uh it
looks like there's still a lot of play
left here to me okay uh stylistic Choice
here I'm going to put it to the uh to
the panel oh okay just as uh he plays
rookie eight I was gonna say in this
position is it an option do you take on
B2 and at least change the imbal of
pieces here you would give up one piece
but you're gonna get one of the Rooks
back dangerous postpones maybe he said
no he didn't go for this Fabiano I think
it was a great idea and I think that
might have been the dynamic imbalance
that that he needed i i i a good call
out David I think he should have yeah
it's just okay evaluation boss says
still level but changing the nature of
the position is often a good thing and
okay he missed that and now after B3 the
Black Knight is forced to the edge of
the board it's most likely going to jump
in here but white is just going to
defend this pawn and everything's
covered at least for now
yeah I will say that and I and again you
know it's normal to be frustrated when
you're down a game playing Black against
the best player of all time but I feel
like fabi's looked a little dejected at
the start of this game he took a bunch
of time on move one he's kind of like
this is an uphill battle and and feeling
a little frustrated and maybe maybe he
just
didn't see that didn't look for that
opportunity I mean it's possible he's
been the player who's been pushing the
last two games he had the edge in game
two and in game three wasn't able to
convert it to an advantage to a winning
Advantage but this one as well the
opening he's trying the Queens are off
the board but is this like a queenless
middle game and is there still hope for
Fabi here I think it's definitely hope
right I mean like you've still got two
Bishops you're Brooks are active
um you can try to open up the bishop
even more for that last line uh but you
know and uh you know the game is alive
right the game's definitely alive and it
could be a lot more dead than this uh
when you're playing they're like Magnus
he can kill it straight away I was just
thinking these guys have played so much
right I mean Fabio fabby's played Magnus
Carson for the world championships do
you think fabby's like a bit annoyed
with Magnus is like I'm not that bad
it's gone again it's not oh my God how
do I beat this guy keeps he keeps doing
me in I mean I mean or is he more like
oh I really want to you know play Magnus
and actually you know get my against him
I you know I wonder which one it is I
don't know players like Fabi they
probably wish they were born in a
different generation I mean
right and he'd probably a fair if it
wasn't of Magnus and you know he
probably would be world champion at some
point you know I mean we've said this
before but he didn't lose the game in
classical chess to Magnus Carlson in the
world championship right and had
opportunities game six in game eight
right I mean so I think uh definitely
one of those there's a lot of people who
can argue that you know how many people
would have had an NBA championship if
not going up against Jordan right but
that is what it is and I think Fabi I
think Bobby maybe looks at the chances
now right the world has been shaken up
with Magnus Carlson
declining to defend the title so who
knows what is in Fabiano caruana's
future he's been playing phenomenal
chess
um number three in the world currently
just won a gcd event as well just yeah
well it's funny too it's finals
regardless of how this works out Bobby
has been in two finals in the CCT right
but both both times he got there through
the winners bracket
one time he was in the winners bracket
throughout but the second time he did
fall to the elimination bracket and then
rose again ah okay okay he faced him
twice oh that's right that's right okay
yeah I was remembering the Hikaru
Nakamura match oh that was such a
fantastic run for Fabi staying in the
winners bracket but a heartbreaking one
in the end a witch Hikaru eventually won
and so I'll be here playing aggressively
he brings his Rook into the game the two
Bishops that you were talking about the
C Pawn for white for Magnus can be a bit
of weakness uh David you've been all day
we've been focusing on nights on the
edge but that Black Knight on A3 that
can be a power piece for black hair yeah
this night if it ever jumps in it's
gonna come with power you can imagine it
if the Brooks will disappear coming in
to win some white pawns if it ever jumps
in to this Square it's going to be
really scary so Magnus pretty much has
to leave a rook on C1 to keep this
Knight caged and
we do a bit of math mathematics maths
maths maths whatever it's called
then the white Rook is more powerful
technically than the Knight and uh if we
cancel those out it's a big gain for
black so yeah Tanya it's definitely not
over sure I quite like Black's position
yeah I mean if I was going to pick a
side I'd pick black because uh you got
the pressure and I don't think Magnus
looks that comfortable I mean he's not
he's not got the teapot out yet he
hasn't got his leg out yet you know he's
uh and it's just like black has the
pressure yeah he's got the two Bishops
yep I mean there are many ways white can
defend this clearly but you know it's
still it's still nice to have that
pressure at least you know in a muscle
situation right I think there's good
chances here you know I agree Bobby took
a sip of water and quickly responded to
Rook E3 with Rook d8 which apparently
the computer didn't like I'm wondering
if there's some sort of hidden hidden
resource hidden tactic the bar is
creepily climbing up steadily and slowly
I feel like this must be some inhuman
computer tactic here because Bobby
played it instantly they both
body language suggests that Bobby's
getting more comfortable not Magnus and
um like what is the tactic on Rook d8
that we're not seeing yeah so the engine
suggestions we see in front of us it
says that Rook takes Rook is by far
White's best move here other moves are
fine they keep the balance but Rook
takes rook and we're gonna see it
actually on the board but what's the
idea why is it Bishop E5 maybe I guess I
think maybe Knight to even if he's
attacking attack forces the Bishops off
the forces the bishop to take the Knight
because of F7 and of course Magnus finds
it immediately immediately so yeah on
the board and if you force one of the
Bishops to depart then suddenly white I
think here has a clear Advantage clear X
report and now this night you can tell
probably missed that too the way he just
yeah he that was not a like uh and like
because now it's Ops Code Bishops too
which only increases why it's drawing
chances I think uh yeah it's just a Pity
as well this Rook has no good Retreat
squares if you step the whole way back
this night can capture this Pawn because
I think maybe he was banking on this pin
this skewer but the Knight can jump out
the way hit a loose piece I wonder if
that's what he missed at the end I think
that might be it might have been what do
you missed can we back up then to see so
if if the computer gives white The Edge
because of Fabiano's Rook e to d8 what
was the move there because I agreed with
Simon momentum was going farby's way the
bishop here looks good for black what
was the move here I'm going to be a bit
naughty and check the computer it says
C4 uh C4 yeah maybe not the most obvious
move but it does support The Rook with a
pawn and at least if the Rook trade
happens this Pawn will help the Black
Knight get into the game potentially and
might paralyze or at least slow down
some of the white pieces boom not
necessarily easy but yeah unfortunately
a Miss from Fabiano and this is the uh
ruinous position he's left with Knight
to E5 and this Pawn is dropping or
he'll have to part with his Bishop
yeah Magnus big favorite now surely
massive fragrance especially if you just
need a draw yeah I mean uh
that's a big move wasn't it Knight to E5
yeah I mean massive move there and I I I
I don't even know how you can keep
things rolling now really I guess
magnus's
and if you're forced to trade that
Bishop for the night that's all dreams
over yeah
Bishops it's it's like
smelly has an aroma yeah Smelly Cat what
are they feeding you yeah oh that's the
question what has Magnus been eating
because he's been on this crazy farm
with the nine out of nine in the grand
Chester and then winning his first match
did it surprise you how critical he was
of his quality of play on day one here
nah not at this point I know Magnus too
well and actually all of the top players
it tends to be a thing that they very
rarely Revel in their wins they just
forget the losses or the the small
inaccuracies that they could have made
uh that they did make that's kind of
what sticks with them they're
perfectionists all of them and that's
why they're so good that's why they are
champions uh but yeah I want to see the
celebrations more I want to see them
saying yeah I played like a boss in this
in this game and okay there we see the
trade and it's not a happy trade I think
Magnus will say he played better today
do you know I was just looking at his
position and I was thinking what happens
if Rook D2 sorry I took a jump in the
chest but I was just thinking if white
puts the bishop on F6 and just puts a
rook on d8 it's just like it's actually
quite simple right I mean you can you
know black can't do anything uh so is is
so so horrible and a nice spots playing
well I mean that's such a good Bishop
isn't it and uh this Rook is gonna be
very painful to Black and Unstoppable
that was the only activity I could see
black attempting to get and if we were
talking about lights on the rim are dim
Knights on the edge what was it nice and
the edge fall off the head nice on the
nights on yeah Knights on the side
because Bishop six once played and right
you know threats of Bishop to E7 now
black has a Pawn on C5 on a dark square
that could be right for the picking
Black's the Knight on the edge of the
board almost trapped yeah it's just
stinky too many things yeah and maybe
the king can even come into just too
much isn't there too much going on here
what does this should be six because
Here Comes Bishop E7 and how do you deal
with the uh the parliament oh Magnus
didn't play it I wonder if he first just
stopping the black Rook from uh stepping
down to the second rank nice control
type of move at this point it feels like
anything is good enough to kind of
maintain the advantage converting will
be another thing but he doesn't need to
convert how do I get how do you get that
Knight out you know how many sayings can
we get with the Knights on the rims the
knights on the rim are dim the what's
the other one night's on the edge fall
off the Hedge all of the Hedge Knights
on the side I cannot abide I cannot
abide like it nice on yeah
[Laughter]
all right wow but that's not a happy
night there that's definitely a donkey
as we've been calling out with the moves
that we've seen the changes in the
position and uh Magnus uh creating some
tension on the queen side how should
Fabi react to this it's a tough one it's
like Sophie's Choice here the white
Bishop is threatening to actually combat
and hit
night on the edge the edge of the board
so if you're not careful you might just
lose a piece but then again you don't
really want to block down that flank
that side of the board because your
knight will be stranded there forever
White Knight is about to enter D5 a nice
supported Outpost
everything it's just all these small
things adding up and okay he's jumped in
finally but it feels like again Simon
your idea of the white Rook getting in
if the black Rook ever leaves the open D
file is uh that's going to be the killer
blow okay the knight's out but it's
coming at the cost of another Pawn
this does not spell uh good news for
Fabiano you can tell on the body
language again as experts here in the
studio that's expert body language yeah
I think I think Magnus will play a three
and then if the Rook takes A2 he's gonna
he's gonna try to land his Rook on the
eighth rank somewhere yeah okay we play
Z5 a little more direct even though it
allows 94 I guess he'll just take the
eight bun and for Fabi right now is this
frustrating just this position and this
outcome you want to push you want to
fight for a game and then you have this
one slip allowing magnets to trade in
the center how difficult is it for
Fabian is he truly motivated to try this
position I don't know that we're looking
at the most motivated Fabiano caruano
we've ever seen um I think I think he
kind of knows that this one is uh
is uh the writing's on the wall but also
he's not gonna offer a draw because
Magnus will decline the draw like Magnus
won't even take the draw at this point
he doesn't want to be disrespected like
that that's a shark mating too there's a
Checkmate coming here even if the even
if the Knight takes the bishop it's over
of course so anyway yeah I don't think
he's that motivated but I think Bobby
will be back tomorrow I mean you you
called out that uh he has been in the
losers bracket before so we'll see it um
I'm I don't know what I'm more excited
for tomorrow we shouldn't start
previewing it yet but I think this one I
think this one is pretty much over
probably not offering a draw because
because Magnus won't take it yeah three
pawns down it's just uh hopeless at this
point unfortunately I gotta hope for
that haven't you so and uh one last
trick one last trap yeah that's what
he's got to try for yeah definitely but
I mean he's played so well today Magnus
hasn't he I mean yeah yes I mean what
can you do when you're playing someone
who who's playing like a computer you
know he's playing unbelievable Jason I
think Fabiano's play hasn't been that
bad I mean it's been been pretty good I
mean he's had some half chances but uh
not ever really winning chances at all
in any of the games but he's played he's
he seems to play okay yeah I don't think
he's played that badly no I think he's
playing very well yeah it honestly was
that the first game yeah the first game
where Magnus won the preparation battle
Magnus chose a weapon that Fabi didn't
see coming went right into the heart of
of you know the type of position that a
lot of people avoid against karwana in
those white sides of those open
Sicilians he got the dub and then after
that it's like now I'm just in shutdown
mode right match strategy for the win
and look at that Magnus locking up the
cage for that black king not allowing a
Trader pawns not allowing the black king
to centralize itself and still mating
threats persist this one is I think in
its final stages you can tell body
language he's getting ready to resign
well he's mentally he's been resigned
for a while
yeah
and where you can take the bishop Connie
if he wants to play on a little bit but
the White Knight is also just dominating
the the white the black Bishop as well
so I mean uh if black can somehow get
his Bishop I'm really scraping them I'm
really just scraping the bottle here
whatever the saying is scraping the
bottom of the barrel barrel that's the
one yeah
looking at picking up a third Pawn in
the position attacking that night you
really can't do much except trade and
three pawns up is what it's going to be
four in a minute
disappears and we go four point
Advantage maybe we'll go for some
stalemate idea I was just about to say
that that if there's a blunder of Rook
A8 I think maybe there's a style Matrix
I think rookie Thor and Brooke takes
Bishop is is pretty I know the king gets
out I'm trying to lose it I'm doing my
best you know so but uh I mean he's yeah
he can body language you don't have to
be an expert even to to work this one
out right it's okay I mean it's like
sometimes it is uh it is what it is when
you're when you're watching greatness
right it's like we always want every
match to end in an Armageddon comeback
fashion yeah simulatory Saga or Notre
back but you know we still got uh about
20 000 people watching across twitching
YouTube and wherever else you might be
people like watching magnets do Magnus
things repetition there a Magnus takes
it because it gets him the match Wick
tree what a match performance this has
been by the world number one taking down
wall number three Fabiano caruana tough
day for Fabi which puts him in the
elimination bracket Magnus continues his
run in to the Winner's bracket and
perhaps today he is feeling better about
the quality of his play it was quite a
convincing win there David by Magnus
yeah it was smooth in the end and Magnus
didn't take that risk to try and win it
was a draw but that was enough and it
was actually Fabby here in this position
who when he let the chances slip Rook to
E3 the last move from White and a bit of
a blunder unfortunately Rook to d8 just
careless and neglecting White's
resources C4 would have kept the game
very very tense with the idea that now
you can recapture with a pawn and
Black's Knight is back in the game
anything was still possible Rook to d8
as we saw a bit earlier did allow a
trade and this was the Hammer Blue
Knight to E5 attacking The Rook
attacking the pawn and destroying
Black's winning chances
chess is brutal sometimes the most
natural looking ones are the ones that
get you into trouble and that's what we
saw in that end game which means that
Magnus Carlsen continues his run in the
winners bracket and he will be playing
against not the back Abdul satro Fabiano
caruana and Levon aronian go down into
elimination bracket and these are
moments that you're glad that this is a
double elimination because you don't
want to lose Autumn players like Lev and
Fabi you don't want to lose out on Lev
or fobby or their opponents who they're
facing tomorrow Wesley so of course
gonna be one of those guys anyway yes I
can't wait for for both brackets
tomorrow and uh it'll be fun it'll be a
lot of fun and right now we're gonna
have fun as the winner is joining us
Magnus Carlson after his win against
Bobby Magnus congratulations
thank you
Magnus yesterday you won in three games
but you were quite critical of your play
are you happier with how you played
today
yeah I think my my uh play was a lot
better today uh I think the first game
was really really good
um like I I think I played really
um
really well my brain was also also
working well in in a position that was
far from easy to play because my kings
in the in the center so that's uh that I
think was a really good game uh the
second game was kind of four but
um the third was okay uh and then the
fourth I think I played a little bit
carelessly in the opening and he
actually had a very decent position
where uh I think it was not really worse
but then he made one careless move uh
and um then I just took over
um or I got well I got in D5 and after
after that I can I can never really
never really lose so uh even though like
he has waste just so if he equalized
again there is no way you could play for
a win after that
first game it was very impressive to
watch how much of that was preparation
um
yeah in in Zara in the blitz so I was
kind of surprised
that he he was he was very surprised I
don't know maybe he had some small idea
which he didn't want to show or was not
so sure what to play I wasn't yeah I
wasn't sure about about that
um but uh
I mean I had to to think on my own
pretty pretty early
um but um I felt like I understood it
pretty pretty well so I was very happy
with that
Magnus tomorrow you're moving on to play
the young Notre back of do sator of a
world rapid Champion how excited do you
get for matches like that against
players who a lot of people are looking
at as you know who knows what happens in
five ten years potential World
Championship level Talent so how excited
do you get for matchups like that
he's worst he was championed in 2021 and
I took it back in 2022.
you're right I'm sorry but uh but anyway
how excited are you for that that
matchup
I think it's uh it's a very good uh good
um I have to say he played an amazing
game today the first
uh the first game like that's an opening
I never I've never seen before
um and um
he is very very good practically so
um a very different kind of player from
from whom I played today
and uh Magnus you've been playing one A6
quite a lot recently title Tuesday and
yesterday has there been a reason that
you've been playing uh this opening
anything particular or just there that
you felt like it
actually Peter just told me like a while
ago that he'd been checking A6 for fun
and he said he wasn't that bad so
um
we were like briefly discussing what to
play against Jordan and then I just said
[__] it I'll play six uh because he's
he's so well prepared but I thought as
long as I got to play play chess against
him it's it's fun but then actually in
the in the second game where I went
um A6 and then C6 like he actually went
for one of the really really one of the
most dangerous plants there so he
clearly checked something even though
and Magnus has been a really busy few
weeks for you but you're looking super
relaxed during this tournament what's
your trick have you been spending the
days before the games
um you know today uh I went for I went
for a swimming just before the first
game which I think helped me a lot
um
yeah but today it's so you know uh it's
so cold outside that actually it was
warmer in the in the sea than in there
which uh and it was like which was it
was nice
um but uh but yeah as I said like
yesterday I was a bit tired but today I
feel feel fine then I and the play
showed it as well
and Michael you you have quite a lot of
chairs in your room we noticed uh uh
you're not gonna sell any of them on
eBay for your fans at all or give them
any away as prizes
no uh whenever I am on the rare
occasions that I I do streams I need the
chairs for the idiots in the back
which uh
one of them in the past for sure
yeah we were talking about that in the
studio Magnus we really appreciate your
time talking to us thank you so much for
sharing your thoughts
thank you all the best for tomorrow
Magnus Carlsen continues in the Winner's
bracket we've got a big day coming up
there uh let's take a look at our aim
chess rapid bracket and there we have it
we will start with the losers
quarterfinals Fabiano caruana taking on
Wesley Seoul another Clash of big names
and then Levon aronian playing against
the underdog Eduardo duruzaga who was
extremely impressive today in the
winners final it is the big clash
between not a back and Magnus Carlsen
what do you think about that one uh
Danny starting at the top notorbeck uh
taking on Magnus I obviously bespoke and
Magnus of course the Triple Crown uh
owner when he won the world rapid back
from from notorbeck but the youngster
has won a World rapid Championship he's
uh he's obviously a talent that we all
have our eyes on and I can't wait to see
what him and Magnus get into I love how
Magnus said that you know he won in 21
and then I took it back he made wait to
tell me that and I was sort of referring
Loosely once a world champion always a
world champion but Magnus wasn't going
to let that slide and I like it I think
he's ready for tomorrow he's ready for
tomorrow and Simon notabeck is ready for
tomorrow because he said it himself that
he wants to play Magnus which is a
matchup that you're excited about well
that one's going to be really really
juicy I mean they're both fantastic
players but then the All-American clash
as well I mean Wesley so is playing uh
you know against
um there we go Fabiano I nearly forgot
for a second there'd been a long day but
that's going to be really exciting both
those players played many times before
and hard to predict yeah I'm also
looking forward to it to Arizona against
Iranian Underdog for sure terazoga but
he surprised us today with some
fantastic chess and yeah so much more
action guaranteed tomorrow it's going to
be epic and it's going to be a fun day
of Chess not it back abductor potential
future world champion taking on the gold
Magnus Carlsen and that's one match you
don't want to miss also a big losers
bracket coming up it's gonna to be super
exciting we can't wait for the action
we'll see you tomorrow
whoa
[Music]
Agnes takes it because it gets him the
match with three what a match
performance this has been by the world
number one
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you